ESTABLISH A QUORUM CASCAIS HERE
I CAN SEE HERE BALLY HERE DAILY
HAIR MCGUIRE HERE MCGUIRE HERE.
STERN. STERN HERE HE JUST
MISUNDERSTOOD EARNED DO YOU
HAVE ANY STEP WITH YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE NOW IF YOU COULD YOU
COULD YOU IDENTIFY THEM. I DO I
HAVE OF MY DISTRICT DIRECTOR
JEREMY WOLF IS IN THE ADJACENT
ROOM. YEAH EXCELLENT THE QUORUM
IS ESTABLISHED GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING A FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS SONORA
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WHICH SOME MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING. ROUGHLY AS YOU
SEE HER FROM CAR. USE OF RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE ON THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT AND MAYBE FOR YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOUR RATES INTERESTED COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE HAVE. TWENTY FOUR
MEASURES ON TODAY'S CALENDAR A
COUPLE OF DISCUSSION ITEMS A
SMALL SENATE AGRICULTURAL
BUDGET- PLANET AND THAT IF.
CHECK IT WILL BE SMALL SENATE
WILDFIRE PRETENSION RESILIENCY
PACKAGE SO LET'S START OFF WITH
THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS THE SENATE AGRICULTURE
BUDGET PLAN- LET'S GO TO THE L.
A. 002% AND THEN WE WILL HEAR
FROM. OUR GOOD FRIENDS IN THE
MINISTRATIONS SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD SECRETARY ROSS AND
DIRECTOR BELCHING ME. KATE
ALEJO. I'M GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE. THANK MINUTES
WITH THE LATEST ANALYST- OFFICE
IS BEEN ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE
AND CAN STAFF TO PRESENT THIS
AGRICULTURE A BUDGET PLAN- WITH
AGRICULTURE BUT PLAN IS. OF
SEVERAL. ARTICLE TO FOR HUNDRED
AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUND- THIS IS MADE UP OF A
EIGHTYMILLION DOLLARS FOR A
GRANT PROGRAM TO INCENTIVIZE
ALTERNATIVES. CULTURAL BURNING
IN ORDER REDUCE AIR POLLUTION.
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION FOR THE
FORMER PROGRAM WHICH IS A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES FUNDING
TO REPLACE AGRICULTURE
EQUIPMENT. IN ORDER TO REDUCE
SOME POLLUTION. NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT SPENDING
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S TRANSITION TO
SAFER SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT PROPOSAL. FUNDING
WOULD GO TO DPR FOR ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT OTHER PROGRAMS.
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
GRANT PROGRAMS WITHIN DPR AND
CFA. I WILL PROVIDE MY NEEDS-
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS. FIFTY MILLION
FOR THE ALTERNATIVE ANYWHERE
MESSAGE THAT ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM WHICH
IMPLEMENTS NON DIGESTER
PRACTICES TO REDUCE AND AVOID
METHANE EMISSIONS. AND TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CDFA TO
CREATE A DNA BARCODES BARCODE
REFERENCE LIBRARY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND SEX. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ONE SURE THERE'LL BE SOME
QUESTIONS LATER ON BUT WHEN WE
HEAR FROM THE ADMINISTRATION MY
COLLEAGUES- TALKING IN THE HALL
RIGHT NOW SO WE DON'T WANT WE
JUSTTURNED TO- SECRETARY-
BLOOMIN HAS A- HAS IT'S BEEN.
ALL OVER THIS CULTURAL
PRACTICE- THE PROPOSAL GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING JERRY
HOUSE THE YOU DOING. I'M IN THE
GREEK LOTUS THEY SAY. IT. THIS
IS A RECORD THAT MANY HERE BLUE
I'M SECRETARY KELLY- AND SHARE
AYE AYE BE SO MAIN ON THE ****
MIL INCREASE THAT ASPEN OF THE
PROPOSED I'M ALSO TRUMP AT THAT
THANK BANG OUT. WELCOME I'M
ALSO HAPPY TO THOSE BUT I'M
PRIMARILY GET FOCUS. THE MIDDLE.
I'M AND JUST GIVE KIND OF A I
WILL EVEN THAT HAPPENS. TO GO
TO QUESTIONS AND WE LOOK HAVE-
AS THE MEN. A COMPLICATED WAY
ARE SIMPLE WAY OF SAYING
SOMETHING COMPLICATED WHICH IS
THAT IT'S BASICALLY THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION. AND IT'S
COLLECTED IS A FLAT RATE ON-
HAVE POUNDS OF PESTICIDE SOLD
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE POTENTIAL
HEALTH OR ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PESTICIDES
AND- YOU KNOW IT IN DOING THIS
JOB FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS AND
BEFORE THAT WORKING WITH WHICH
THOMAS- IT'S CLEAR THAT EVERY
SINGLE PASS AND CHAT. AND
COMMITTEE WANTS TO MOVE AWAY TO
LESS TOXIC PESTICIDES IF YOU
TALK TO FARMWORKERS OLE-
FAMILIES THEY EAT FOOD ALL
SUPERMARKETS THAT SELL FOOD-
THE FARMERS THEMSELVES. I'M SO
WE THIS THIS IS REALLY PART OF
AN INTEGRATED PLAN TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO MOVE CALIFORNIA
TOWARDS LESS TOXIC PESTICIDES
ISN'T THE SOLE WAY OF DOING IT
BUT IT'S PART OF THAT
TRANSITION. SO AT THE MOMENT
WITH SENDING A PRETTY CLEAR
SIGNAL- THAT'LL PESTICIDES ARE
EQUAL BY TEARING IT NAMELY THE
MORE TOXIC PESTICIDE THE HIGHER
THE FEES WILL BE ASSESSED FOR
SENDING A CLEAR MARKET SIGNAL.
TO EVERYONE TO MOVE TOWARDS
LESS TOXIC MATERIALS- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A AND
NECESSARY IN INNOVATIVE CHANGES
SUPPORTS. THIS TRANCE
TRANSFORMATION AS I DESCRIBED
IT SAYS. ONE ONE OF THE MAIN
WAYS THAT WE CAN HELP FARMERS
AND I WAS RECENTLY- IN FRESNO
TALKING TO FARMERS WAS. THAT
THEIR ISSUE IS THAT THERE'S
OFTEN A WILLINGNESS CHAD TO DO
IT BUT NOT THE TOOLS TO HELP.
FARMERS WHO INCREDIBLY BUSY I'M
DOING A WHOLE SET OF THINGS I
UNDERSTAND HOW TO MAKE THAT
CHANGE SO THE KID MAILED BOTH
ENCOURAGES THE USE OF LAST TEXT
TOXIC PESTICIDES BUT ALSO MOST
IMPORTANTLY. AND THIS IS KIND
OF I THINK A KEY ISSUE THAT'S
COME UP AGAIN AND AGAIN IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS PEOPLE ARE SAYING
WELL. WHY DON'T YOU JUST FIND
THE BUDGET DEFICIT- THAT EXISTS
WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION WHICH IS BETWEEN
EIGHT AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE'RE SAYING IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS CHANGE WE REALLY NEED
TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT AND
FARMERS AND IN THE FUTURE. OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND SEVEN THE
PROPOSAL TODAY WHICH- COMES OUT
A TOTAL OF. ABOUT FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. REAL SPEND
MOST OF THE MONEY ON WORKING
WITH PHAM AS WELL WITH
ACCENTURE THAT USE IN OTHER TO
DO WHAT'S CALLED INTEGRATE PEST.
IT'S AT. HOW HOW DO THINK OF
THIS IS DID BUT HAD WE PROVIDE
THOSE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE FARMERS WILL ALSO LOOKING
AT STRONGER ENFORCEMENT. AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT TO PRODUCE
BETTER ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES- WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME THROUGH THE AB SIX ONE
SEVEN PROCESS REALIZING THAT
COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE ADJACENT.
TO FIELDS THAT ARE STRAIGHT-
HAVE A VERY STRONG CONCERN
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IMPACTS OF THAT SPRING AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE TWO THINGS
WE HAVE. ENFORCEMENT THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS WE HAVE
NOTIFICATION SO. PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY'RE BEING
SPRAYED. ALL THE FIELDS
ADJACENT TO THEM BEING SPRAYED
AND WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE EXACT ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES ARE. SO IN SUMMARY- WE
REALLY WANT TO. DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN TO SPEED UP THE
DEVELOPMENT AND MOVEMENT
TOWARDS EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES
THAT'S WHERE. THIS HAS TO
HAPPEN- WE NEED TO SPEED THAT
RESEARCH PROCESS OUT SO THAT WE
CAN- ALSO SPEED UP DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION. SO
THAT THE HEAD LESS TOXIC
PESTICIDES ALL THE ALTERNATIVES
THE. QUICKER THEY GO ON TO THE
MARKET. SO JUST FOR CONTEXT
WE'VE BEEN USED THESE INTEGRATE
PEST MANAGEMENT. PRACTICE TODAY-
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE OTHER
ELEMENTS IN THE ISLAMIC
PROGRAMS- WHEN YOU LOOK AT. THE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM- FROM HIS
ZERO TAYWAN TRACTORS THAT
THERE'S A WHOLE PAUL PATTON IN
PRACTICE THE PEOPLE ARE DOING
IT WE JUST WANT TO. DO THIS IN
THE CONTEXT OF PESTICIDES MOVE
THOSE TO HAPPEN QUICKER. SO WE-
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS THIS IS
THE TIME TO DO IT- WE NEED THE
FUNDING TO HELP MAKE- THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT- REMOVES
AFTER THIRTY YEARS OF NOT
RAISING THIS FEE- WE WANT TO
EXPAND AND MONITORING THAT'S
ANOTHER CRITICAL ELEMENT THAT
HAPPENS IN THIS PLANCHETTE. IS
WE TRIED TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THAT WHEN MEASURING THE TOXIC
AND CRITERIA. I AND
CONTAMINANTS BUT WOULD NOT
MEASURING PESTICIDES INSTEAD OF
WORKING WITH THE END RESULT IS
BALD WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SET UP
PILOTS. WE NEED TO EXPAND THAT
NOW. I'M WE CONTINUE TO WORK
AND BUILD ENGAGEMENT THROUGH
THE STATE- MEETING WITH BOTH
PESTICIDE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
AND MEETING WITH TOM GROUPS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE HEARING
THAT ISSUES INVOLVED ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS- THAT WE'VE HAD IS
WELL JUST LET'S JUST FIND THE
P. OPPORTUNITY IS. WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE SURE ALL SPECIALLY
WITH BOTH INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT AND MONITORING THE
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SAD THAT WE HAVE. A
LONG TERM FUNDING TRAJECTORY
WHAT WE'RE HEARING AGAIN AND
AGAIN IS DOWN. YEAH WE LOCK TWO
YEARS OF FUNDING BUT REALLY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
STUDY INTEGRATED. PEST
MANAGEMENT FUNDING THAT GOES
ON- DAY IN DAY OUT AND SOME
PREDICTABILITY WHICH THE MAIL
PROVIDES SAID IN CLOSING I'M
AGRICULTURE IS A FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR INDUSTRY. THIS
PROPOSAL IS AN INVESTMENT AND
ITS FUTURE AND CALIFORNIA'S AND
WITH A CHANGING CLIMATE WHICH
WILL LIKELY. BRING NEW AND
DIFFERENT PEST PRESSURES IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WE MAKE THIS.
NOW TO IN HEALTH POLLINATOR
HEALTH. THE SOIL AIR AND WATER-
WHICH'LL FOUND TO STATE AGRA.
SECTOR AND WITH THE I'LL CLOSE
AND I'M TEN BACK TO YOU CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT I'M- THIS IS. THIS
IS THE ISSUE THAT BRINGS MANY
MANY GROUPS TOGETHER- I'M I
HOPE E'LL GET TO BE ABLE TO
REACH RESERVE RESOLUTION ON IT
THIS. SESSION THANK YOU YEAH
AND THEN S. FOLKS ARE LOOKING
AT THE- THE BUDGET PLAN ON AS
OUTLINED ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE IT SHOULD UNDER THE
HEADING OF TRANSITION TO A
SAFER SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT. IT SHOULD BE A TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM OF FORTY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY NOT IT SAYS IT
SAYS FORTY SO WE'LL HAVE THAT.
I SECRETARY BLOOMFIELD AT THE-
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL YOU
KNOW IF IT AGAIN WE- EACH MALES
WORTH THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
THREE POINT NINE MILLION AS FAR
AS YOU GO OUT INTO THE DISTANCE
BUT YOU WERE THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEFORE US THE SENATE
AGRICULTURE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
TALKING ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
MILLS TO SUPPORT COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS. AND
IN ANOTHER YOU KNOW MILFORD TO
ENHANCE YOUR BEDSIDE MONITORING
THERE'S A THIRD OF A MILL FOR
THE- AB- SIX ONE SEVEN BUT IT
DIDN'T ONLY TWO BILLS FOR THE
FIVE FIVE PM PROGRAM AND THEN
ANOTHER MALE FOR THE EDUCATION
OF- FIVE PM. AND THEN BUT A
MILL THERE INTO MILLS BASICALLY
FOR- THE RESEARCH AT- C. ISSUE
IN AT- THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. CAN YOU TELL ME
SOME IDEA OF HOW YOU THINK THAT
THE COUNTY ACT COMMISSIONERS
AND A TWO AND A HALF MILL SAID
THEY WOULD BE GETTING. AND ALSO
THE- THE OUTRAGE WITH THE CAL
THE HEALTH SYSTEM MERCY ISSUE
SYSTEM OF THOSE WORK TOGETHER
AND WHAT CAN WHAT CAN THE
FARMERS ON THE- ON THE GROUND
EXPECT TO COME FROM THIS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TO THOSE
COUNTY FOLKS. YEAH I'M I'M
HAPPY TO GET INTO THAT AND ALSO
SECRETARY ROSS- AND DIRECTOR
DOES SEEM TO CONTROL CAN ALSO
BOASTED IT. JUST SEVEN PEOPLE%
I'M LISTENING ON. CONFUSED
BECAUSE IT IT IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS
LIKE WHEN WE SET TO MAIL IT'S
NOT TWO MILLION IT'S THE MIDDLE
FEE WHICH IS. THE NEW MALCHOW
PAD- PESTICIDE SOLD- SO IN THIS
PLAN JUST BROADLY BECAUSE THIS
DOES THE FOLKS PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WILL
MAINLY BE USED THE EXTENSION
AND OTHER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THEY THEY'VE BEEN DOING IS A
SECRETARY RUSSELL WILL ATTEST.
AN INCREDIBLE JOB FOUR YEARS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO- TO FAMAS BUT THAT MONEY HAS
BEEN VERY INTO INTIMATE AND- WE
ARE KNOWN AROUND THE COUNTRY AS
AS HAVING ONE OF THE BEST IBM
PROGRAMS BUT IT HAS BEEN A VERY
FUNDED IBM PROGRAM- AND SO WHAT
THEY WOULD DO IS THEY WOULD
WHAT WITH THE I. COMMISSION AS
BUT OFTEN SEPARATELY- TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BASED ON THE TYPE OF CROSS
BASED ON THE- TYPE OF PASSED.
THE LOOK AT HOLISTIC SOLUTIONS
AND REPLICATE THOSE SOLUTIONS
THAT HAVE WORKED IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE OR COUNTRY OR EVEN
THE WILD THE ACTIVATION IS HAVE
A VERY SPECIFIC REGULATORY ROLE
UNDER FEDERAL PESTICIDE
REGULATIONS- THEY'RE ACTUALLY
THE DELEGATION GOES ALL THE WAY
TO THE AG COMMISSIONERS THOSE
AT COMMISSION IS KIND OF HAVE A
DUAL ROLE ONE IS THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE APPOINTED BY THE LOCAL.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BUT
THEY ALSO RECALLED BACK OUT TO-
BOTH HAD SECRETARY ROSS AND
DIRECTED ALL CD- IN THE CONTEXT
OF PESTICIDES THE ADVANCE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ISN'T
PESTICIDE DRIFT DRIFT IS A TIME
WHICH MEANS PESTICIDE IS GOING
AND BEING SPRAYED FONG ON NON
TARGET- ENTITIES WHICH COULD BE
AND HAS IN THE PAST
UNFORTUNATELY BEEN FARMWORKERS
THEMSELVES HAS BEEN SCHOOLS-
HAVE BEEN LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
NON TARGETED MAKING SURE THAT
ENFORCEMENT HAPPENS. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE ALL THAT BECAUSE WE
OWN THAT FEDERAL DELEGATION-
THAT WE'RE ENGAGING SETTING
CLEAR PERFORMANCE METRICS
CLEAR- ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES
ALL WHAT NEEDS TO BE ACHIEVED
SO THAT COMMUNITIES CAN FEEL
SAFE AT THE MOMENT. WHEN WE
TOLD HIM WE NEEDED THESE AS
ASSEMBLY. SOME OF EVER. DATA
FOR IN ABOUT INCELS. WE ONLY
GET AOUT TO FACT- HOW WILL
WORKING. AND IT NEEDS TO
TRAINED AND FUNDING HELP THAT
THE THAT COMMISSION. CHAD WHO-
I DO. WAY TOO MUCH WAY TOO
LITTLE- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
ALL THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE WORKLOAD IS AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE PUT ADDITIONAL SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE PROJECT
TO HELP THEM- SO WE CAN- BALLOT
OLE. OLE OLE SECRETARY ROSS CAN
TALK THROUGH THE BUDGET FILM IN
MORE DETAIL AS CAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT
BASICALLY THE GOAL IS. IS TO
PROVIDE CONSISTENT LONG TERM
FUNDING TO ALLOW THE SYSTEM- TO
WHACK IN A WAY THAT- THAT THE
AND COMMISSION IS HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED IN TERMS OF FUNDING
WE HAVE WHAT WE NEED IN TERMS
OF. ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ASSURANCES. THE PUBLIC HAS- IN
THIS PROPOSAL THE ABILITY THE
FUNDING TO HELP THEM ENGAGE
BECAUSE OFTEN. THERE THERE'S NO
WAY OF A BUILDING THAT LOCALS
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. TO BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE IN THESE COMPLICATED
ISSUES- AND THAT WE ALSO HAVE
THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT MONITORING TO SHOW. THAT
THE PESTICIDES- STAYING WHEN
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO- AND WITH
THAT I WILL TURN IT BACK TO
YOU. OKAY I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE GOT OTHER. MATTERS ON
THE TIER YEAH THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME CRITICS THAT BELIEVE THAT
YOU KNOW THE MOST TOXIC
PESTICIDES FARMERS REALLY DON'T
WANT TO USE THAT AND ONLY USE
IT SPARINGLY. IN THE MIDDLE
MALLETS AND. THEN BY PUTTING A
HIGHER. MILL FEED ON THAT. YOU
WERE- IT COMPROMISED THEIR BILL
TO RAISE THEIR CRY- WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY AND WE WILL HEAR FROM
THOSE CRITICS BUT WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY JUST. GENERALLY ON THE
PHILOSOPHY OF THE MELFI. THANK
YOUR QUESTION CHAD YES SAID
THAT THE BASIC PHILOSOPHY OF
THE MILTIE IT IS MUCH LIKE HOW
THE- DEVICES THE USE FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE TO A HIGHER
FEE ON THE MOST POLLUTING-
SUBSTANCES- AND THEN THE NOTE
IN THE CASE OF THIS. WAS SAYING
JUST AS YOU DESCRIBED THAT THE
MORE TOXIC THE COMPONENT AND
THIS IS IN US DECIDING IT-
WE'RE BASICALLY LOOKING AT THE
LABEL. AND US ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY COMES OUT
WITH AS LABEL- AND WE DIVIDED
THAT INTO THREE SAID THE LEAST
HARMFUL WE'RE GOING TO
ENCOURAGE BY HAVING THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF FEE- AND- THE MOST
WILL HAVE THE HIGHEST FEES AT
THE MOST TOXIC FOR THE- DETAILS
UPSET. VERY BASIC APPLICATION
OF THE FOOD- PAGE PRINCIPLE
WITH TRYING TO USE FINANCIAL
MECHANISMS AND INCENTIVES TO
SAY HELLO ON THE SHELF HERE-
YOU SHOULD SEE THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY COSTING LESS. I WANTED
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY AS
WELL TO SAY SOMETHING THAT'S
OFTEN NOT. UNDERSTOOD ABOUT
PESTICIDES SALES IN THE STATE
HAAF OF THEM I'M SURE WHITE
HOUSE YOU HAPPEN IN THE OPEN
AREA SO HOT FOR THE MAIL IS
GENERATED THROUGH ELEVEN SALES
THAT BLEACH THAT'S MOSTLY
THINGS UNDER YOUR KITCHEN
COUNTER- SO THE WAY WE'RE GONNA
MAIN HERE FROM AGRICULTURE
TODAY THEY PAY HIGH OFF OF THAT
SHE- SAID IN THIS SCHEME. OF
THE FORTY FIVE MILLION- DAY
WOULD PAY HOSTAGE TWO AND A
HALF MILLION THE REST JUST TO
GIVE YOU A CLEAR EXAMPLE- AND
THERE'S A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
BRANDS THAT SELL THESE BUT A
NON TOXIC WINDOW CLEANER. WOULD
BE LESS EXPENSIVE THAN A BLEACH
ALTERNATIVE AND WHEN YOU SEE IT
ON THE SHELF IN FRONT OF YOU-
AT A SUPERMARKET YOU WHICH DAY-
THIS ONE'S BOTH LESS EXPENSIVE.
AND BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT PLAYS OUT ACROSS THE
ENTIRE- PANOPLY. PESTICIDES
SOLD AND. YET HAS A SITE
INCLUDE. EACH IS OLD OF THIS.
BECAUSE THAT WILL READ. BY US
IN THE TRI GOVERNMENT AS SO
IT'S SEND THE MARKET SIGNAL
THAT CLEAR- JUST AS WE WOULD
WITHIN. VEHICLE IF YOU IT'S
SIX. THAN A D. CAR. I AS THAT
ONE IF YOU SEE IT'S LESS IT'S-
TO. A A LESS TOXIC PESTICIDE
OUR GOAL IS TO MOVE THE MARKET
IN THAT DIRECTION
PROGRESSIVELY. ONCE AGAIN A
FINE EXAMPLE OF THAT URBAN
RURAL PARTNERSHIP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. LET'S NOT TURN TO
SECRETARY ROSS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST WITH THE
OFFICE OF PESTICIDE- MISTER.
BOSSINEY SECRETARY ROSS HEY
MISTER CHAIRMAN MORNING AND
THANK YOU- I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS-
SHARE IT SHOWS GREAT
PROFICIENCY AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT VERY COMPLEX AGRICULTURAL
SYSTEM- SO I DON'T WANT TO BE
REPETITIVE BUT I DO WHEN I CALL
IN TWO THINGS ONE IS THE ROLE
OF AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS-
IT IS UNIQUE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK HAVING
THAT VOCAL ARM OF A REGULATORY
AGENCY HAS BEEN A HUGE
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE SUCCESS OF
AGRICULTURE DURING THE
CONTINUAL ADAPTATION THAT IT'S
DONE- AND ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO NEW REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. THEY OFTEN TIMES ARE
THE SPONSORS AND SPRAY SAFE AND
OTHER- FIBER TO THE TEETH TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE
NEW REGULATIONS ARE BUT THE
CHANGES ARE AND HOW TO
OPERATIONALIZE THAT SO THEY ARE
VERY IMPORTANT PARTNERS PRESS
AND I JUST WANTED TO CALL OUT
THE ROLE BECAUSE. IT IS UNIQUE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SECONDLY WE HAVE LOST OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES IN PARTICULAR
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC TO. THE AGRICULTURAL
AND NATURAL RESOURCES DIVISION.
WHICH IS OVERSEAS COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION. AND THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE HELD ON CAMPUSES. WITH
SPECIALIST WE DO THE RESEARCH
TO CREATE THE CONTENT IN THE
KNOWLEDGE. AND GIVE US WHAT WE
NEED TO BUILD OUT PROGRAMS BUT
WHAT MAKES BUT COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION SYSTEM. SUCH A VALUE
PROPOSITION IS THE TRANSLATION
OF THOSE RESEARCH FINDINGS. TO
THE END USER AND A VERY
PRACTICAL WAY IN THEIR REGION
AND THEIR CROPS. THEY
OFTENTIMES ARE DOING FIELD
TRIALS TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
WHAT'S POSSIBLE. AND BEING ABLE
TO INVEST THE MAP. ON A ON A
CONTINUAL BASIS WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE- IT'S LOST THAT
SPENDING BY PM PROGRAM HAS LOST
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING OVER THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS- WE ALSO LAS
SPENDING FOR THE FILE. DEBATED
FARMING SYSTEMS WHICH IS A
SMALL GRANT PROGRAM THAT WE
RUN. AND I WOULD ALSO SAY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE IN BASIC
PASSED PROGRAMS THAT WE OPERATE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. WE OFTEN TIMES
WHEN THERE'S A NEW CAST WE ARE
DEVELOPING THE CUTTING EDGE IPM
APPROACH TO DEALING WITH THOSE
INFESTATIONS. AND WE CONSTANTLY
ARE LOOKING TO OUR PARTNERS AT
UC COOPERATIVE EXTENSION. THE
ROLE OF CSU IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY ARE
EDUCATING THE NEXT GENERATION
OF PEST CONTROL ADVISORS AND
PAST MANAGERS WITHIN FARMING
OPERATIONS. SO BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM A STEADY STREAM OF
FUNDING. THAT THEY CAN USE TO
MAKE SURE THEY GOT BOOTS ON THE
GROUND WITH PERSONNEL. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO DO
THE RESEARCH ON CAMPUS. WE
BELIEVE WILL MAKE THIS A VERY
ROBUST PROGRAM AND TRULY
ASSIST. IN SUPPORTING THE
TRANSITION OF AGRICULTURE TO
MEET THE MULTIPLE. DEMANDS FROM
THE MARKET PLACE AS WELL AS THE
REGULATORY. THAT WE HAVE WITH.
AND I YOUR- TO MAKE THIS
COMMENTS SECTOR COULD YOU.
ENLIGHTEN ME ON THE DNA BARCODE
REFERENCE THE LIBRARY OF
CALIFORNIA ONCE THIS IS ONCE
THIS REFERENCE LIGHT BEER
BREWERY IS COMPLETELY BUILT OUT
HOW MIGHT IT HELP US IN THE
FUTURE LEADERS. YEAH SO IT'S A
VERY EXCITING- POSTAL I WAS
THRILLED TO SEE MY FRIENDS-
WORKING ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS
AND IT REMINDED ME OF WHAT
WE'VE WORKED ON SO HARD OVER
THE YEARS TO DO SEEK BANKING.
ALL WITH OUR NEW DIAGNOSTIC
TOOLS AND THE NEW ABILITY TO
SEQUENCE FACT THAT GENETICS-
THIS WILL HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN OUR
ECOSYSTEMS HOW IT'S MOVING AND
I BELIEVE IT CAN HELP US-
IDENTIFIED BASIC PASSED EARLIER
BUT ALSO TRACK- HOW ARE
POLLINATORS ARE MOVING AND
WHERE THEIR DECLINES ARE AS WE
REALLY WORK AND NEW
PARTNERSHIPS WITH INDUSTRY ON
POLLINATOR HEALTH. IT WILL
INFORM OUR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DO EXTENSIVE
TRAPPING AND LOOK FOR ALL KINDS
OF TOOLS TO EXCLUDE AND BASIC
PASSED WITH SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD IS EXACTLY RIGHT WE
ARE SEEING NEW INVASIVE PASSED
WE'RE SEEING THEM HERE FOR
LONGER- SEASONS- AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THE MERITS OF THIS
WILL INFORM OUR PROGRAMS. GIVE
ME A VERY PRACTICAL WAY. AND
WHAT IS THE IMPROVE AS
UNDERSTAND IT WILL ALSO MADE.
THIS BRIDGE. OF GENETIC.
MATERIAL AVAILABLE FOR ACADEMIA
AND FOR FARMERS AND RANCHERS-
WE HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
ENTOMOLOGIST I'M NOT ONLY IN
THE NATION BUT WE HAVE SOME
WORLD RENOWNED EXPERTS AT OUR
AT OUR PLANT DIAGNOSTICS LAB.
AND WE SEE THIS AS BEING A VERY
HELPFUL TOOL FOR OUR WORK AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
ADDITION TO CONTINUED RESEARCH
AND PROTECTION OF OUR
POLLINATORS AND BIODIVERSITY
HOTSPOT. YES SECRETARY ROSS
GIVEN THAT RICH URBAN RURAL-
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA DO YOU
SEE THAT AT SOME TIME THAT EVEN
URBAN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH
SIZE SPECIES POLLINATE WHICH
PLAN IN WHICH EATS WHAT PASSED
THAT THERE MAY BE. SOME
COMMUNICATIONS TO SUBURBIA UP
AT THIS IS THE TYPE OF. DO YOU
WANT TO PUT YOUR BACKYARD
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO ATTRACT
THIS PAST WHICH COULD EAT THIS
BAD INVASIVE SPECIES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I MEAN IS
THAT WE END UP WITH THIS YEAH
DEFINITELY BECAUSE- THERE ARE
THERE ARE ENTITIES- DATABASES.
THAT ARE HOUSED AT SEVERAL OF
OUR UNIVERSITY AND ACADEMIA
PARTNERS- I WILL CALL OUT IN
PARTICULAR THE ROLE OF
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION WHICH
HAS. A PERSONNEL IN EVERY
COUNTY IN THE STATE AN
EXTENSIVE- MAKEUP OF CITIZEN
SCIENTISTS AND MASTER GARDENERS
WHO WORK SPECIFICALLY ON THESE
KINDS OF THINGS SO THAT THE
MORE INFORMATION WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO ARM THEM WITH THAT
INFORMATION. AND TEACHING- THE
RIGHT PLANTS IN THE RIGHT PLACE
AND HOW TO DO- THE LOWEST
IMPACT PEST MANAGEMENT POSSIBLE
THIS IS THE TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT CAN BE USED- THROUGH THAT
SYSTEM OF PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
THERE DOING COMMUNITY OUTREACH-
TO GARDENERS TO GOLF COURSES-
AND TO BERMAN LANDSCAPERS A
VERY IMPORTANT AUDIENCE IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION. WHILE
THERE MUST BE SOME PEOPLE IN
SUBURBIA THAT REALIZE THAT OUR
AS OUR STAFF REPORT POINTS OUT
A 99% DECLINE IN MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY IN LAST FORTY YEARS AND
IF THEY KNEW. WHAT TYPE OF
PLANT THEY SHOULD PUT IN IT
WHEN THEY GO TO HOME DEPOT
WHEREVER THEY GO THAT PLANTS
PLANTS. UP THERE MIGHT BE GOOD
INFORMATION. E. GOOD LET'S. GET
TO. THE S. MANAGEMENT WE HAVE
DIRECTOR OF BELT ALL STEAMY
WHICH IS THE DAHLE SINI WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF PRESS
REGULATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER SUPPORT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S TIERED
MIL PROPOSAL TODAY AND FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CENTRIST IN THE
WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT. WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF REALLY GOOD
MEETINGS WITH LEGISLATORS WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH OTHERS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS. WE MET WITH
NOW. NEARLY THIRTY LEGISLATORS
AND WE WERE HERE BEFORE SEVERAL
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES. BUT
IMPORTANTLY WE'VE ALSO REACHED
OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE REALLY FROM
THOSE THAT SUPPORT THE-
PROPOSAL TO THOSE THAT HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT WE
REALLY KEPT AN OPEN DOOR IN THE
OPEN MIND WHEN IT COMES TO. OF
THE WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO
ACCELERATE THAT TRANSITION TO.
SAFER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE WAYS
TO MANAGE PASSED. I WOULD OFFER
SIMPLY A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
DATA POINTS TO HELP OF THE
CONVERSATION TODAY. THE FIRST
IS THAT A MILL IS ONE TENTH OF
ONE PENNY. SO IT'S A PRETTY
SMALL AMOUNT- AND THAT ACCOUNTS
FOR SECRETARY BLUMENFELD SAID.
85290% OF THE DPR FONG WHICH IS
REALLY THE PRIMARY. OPERATING
FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT. AND
THE SECOND THING THAT I WOULD
ABOUT THE ALCHEMIST AND YOU'VE
HEARD FROM BOTH SECRETARIES ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE AYE
COMMISSIONERS. IT REALLY ARE
ARE ESSENTIAL PARTNERS IN THE
STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OF THEIR ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED OR
SO PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT
STAFF AN ENVIRONMENTAL
BIOLOGIST. THAT WORK HAND IN
GLOVE WITH. DPR AND CDFA TO
ENSURE THAT. PESTICIDE USE LAWS
ARE BEING ENFORCED
APPROPRIATELY THAT PESTICIDE
ILLNESSES ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED PROBABLY. THE
TRAINING SESSIONS FOR PESTICIDE
USERS HAPPEN ON A REGULAR
BASIS- THAT SAMPLING PRODUCE
FOR ILLEGAL PESTICIDE RESIDUE
AMONG MANY OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES. SO WE FEEL
LIKE THAT INVESTMENT INTO
IMPROVED COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT IS GOING TO BE
REALLY. ESSENTIAL GOING FORWARD
AND FINALLY I WOULD JUST ADD
SHERMAN BY CAL SKI THAT. THIS
ONE EXAMPLE OF WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING BUT WE'RE
REALLY MOVING ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON WAYS TO
EFFECT THIS TRANSITION TO SAFER
AND MORE SUSTAINABLE WAYS TO
MANAGE PASSED. OUT WHEN WE TOOK
ACTION ON FOR PURIFIES. IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. MONEY WAS
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
TO INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESEARCH FOR ALTERNATIVES.
AROUND QUARTER OF AUSTIN THAT
IS A CENTRAL PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL REALLY.
LOOKING AT BOTH CDFA MTPR
PROGRAMS TO FIND THAT ALL
IMPORTANT RESEARCH. AND THEN
WE'RE ALSO WAS IN THE MIDST OF
THE KICKING OFF THE WORK OF A
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
WORK GROUP WHICH IS GOING TO
LOOK AT WAYS TO OFFER
CALIFORNIANS A ROAD MAP FOR
MORE SUSTAINABLE WAYS TO MANAGE
PESTS. WHETHER IT'S IN THE BACK
FORTY OR THE BACKYARD OR A
PUBLIC PARK WERE IN OPEN SPACE
OR- JUST ABOUT ANYWHERE YOU CAN
IMAGINE AND WE'VE REALLY
COLLECTED A GOOD. DIVERSE CROSS
SECTION OF CALIFORNIANS FROM
ACADEMICS TO PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES TO. CHEMICAL COMPANY
REPRESENTATIVES FARMERS AND
OTHERS WHO WILL HELP GUIDE THE
WORK OF THAT WORK GROUP OVER
THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR SO
IMPORTANTLY WHAT'S INCLUDED
NETWORK GROUP ISN'T URBAN
COMPONENTS AS WELL SO AS
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD POINTED
OUT. IN A PEST MANAGEMENT
EXISTS IN THE URBAN SPACE AS
WELL SO. WE REALLY FEEL LIKE
THIS IS A GREAT PROPOSAL THAT
MOVES THE STATE TOWARD SOME. OF
THAT CONTINUED TRANSITION TO
SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE WAYS TO
MANAGE PASSED. INTO THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT FARMERS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING I PM SINCE THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND- YOU ONLY
NEED LOOK AT OF THE ALMOND
INDUSTRY AND FOLKS. IN THE
CITRUS INDUSTRY STRAWBERRIES.
YES GREAT EXAM OF TRUE I CAN'T
WE- THIS WILL. DOUBLE DOWN ON
THOSE INVESTMENTS REALLY MAKES
THAT WERE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
AS A STATE. AND SO I FEEL GOOD
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING ON THE
PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
ANSWERING QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE YEAH I
WANTED TO JUMP IN ON THE AIR
MONITORING NETWORK THE
PESTICIDE CARE MINING NETWORK
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HAS. LOTS OF POLLUTION
PROBLEM FAMILY I'VE I'M ALWAYS
FIGHTING ABOUT REDUCING CARBON
VERSUS SOME CLEANING UP THERE
THEY'RE ALL THEY'RE POLLUTION
PROBLEMS CAN YOU. EXPLAIN HOW
THE- YOU KNOW. I DON'T THINK
THE FARMERS OF THE PEOPLE BY
BLEACH ONE OF. FOR THE WHOLE HI
THERE POLLUTION PROBLEM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TELL ME HOW YOU
TARGET JUST THE PESTICIDE
MONITORING UNDER THIS PROGRAM
SO PEOPLE REALIZE THAT THOSE
WHO PAY THE FEES WERE GOING TO
BE MONITORING AND IMPROVING
THEIR QUALITY THAT THE
PESTICIDES. DIMINISHES SURE YOU
KNOW THE PESTICIDES CARE
MONITORING NETWORK THAT EXISTS
TODAY CONSISTS AT DPR OF THREE
PERMANENT LOCATIONS. OF THOSE
CARDS SITES GENERATE
INFORMATION AND DATA TO
IDENTIFY IMPACTS AND TO. INFORM
AND BETTER GUIDE OUR REGULATORY
EFFORTS HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE. WHAT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
ADD ANOTHER FIVE AIR MONITORING
SITES TO THAT. WE HAVE HAD OVER
THE YEARS- CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE AIRPORT
TO. USE ANOTHER FIVE SITES AND
HAVE WORKED WELL WITH THOSE
SITES BUT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
THEM PERMANENT NOW. AND NOT
ALLOWED YEAR MONITORING WORK
THAT WE DO HERE AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO- SUFFERED THROUGH
THE VICISSITUDES OF THE STATE
BUDGET PROCESS SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT.
PARTICULARLY AS YOU POINT OUT
SHERMAN MAKOWSKI OF FOR
PESTICIDE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
IN THE VALLEY. BUT WE ALSO DO
IMPORTANT THEY'RE MONITORING
WORK FOR EXAMPLE IN VENTURA
COUNTY AND IN THE SALINAS
VALLEY AND I'D LIKE TO EXPLORE
WITH COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS
WHERE OTHER AIR MONITORING
SITES MIGHT BE LOCATED IN THE
FUTURE. TO ENSURE THAT. WE'RE
DEVELOPING THE MOST ROBUST. HOW
TO SET THAT WE- AND TO THEM
TEND INFO. REGULATORY ACTIONS
THAT WE MAY TAKE IF WE FIND FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THEIR- EXCESSIVE
EXIGENCES A PARTICULAR
FUMIGANTS OR OTHER PESTICIDES
IN. DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE. SO I MEAN I ASSUME YOU
KNOW WE'RE SPENDING A BUNCH OF
DATA ON AIR MONITORING.
EQUIPMENT IN. THE CAP AND TRADE
I'M NOT THAT'S NEXT WEEK HEALTH
I'LL BE MAD NEXT WEEK BUT- YOU
GET THAT THAT IS WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT WE'RE EXPANDING
THIS. YEAR MONITORING THESE
FIVE LOCATIONS BUT THE ACTUAL
DATA THAT COMES IN. THERE IS HE
IS IT EASY TO SEPARATE- THIS IS
THE DEPARTMENT PESTICIDES THIS
IS THE SAN JOAQUIN AIR QUALITY
BOARD THIS IS FROM. POLLUTING
TRUCKS DIESEL TRUCKS I MEAN IT
IS THAT SOME OF THE CHEMICALS
THAT SHOW UP COULD ONLY BE FROM
THE PESTICIDES RIGHT AYE AYE OR
TO MATCH AND- RIGHT AND SO THE-
BEST. MY THAT WE DO FOCUSES ON.
THIRTY ONE SPECIFIC PESTICIDES
AND THEN FIGHT DEBT RIDDANCE SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THIRTY SIX.
PESTICIDE SPECIFIC. THE DATA
POINTS SECRETARY BLUMENFELD I'M
JUST GONNA USE IT AND ALLOW
SAID- GERUND AND SAY THAT THE
WHAT WHEN YOU GUYS SEE ONE OF
THESE- AND MONITORING
FACILITIES THAT THAT DOES
PESTICIDE IT IS BASICALLY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EQUIPMENT
AND SENSORS- AND SO IT'S VERY
VERY NARROWLY SPECIES EIGHT
EIGHT TO THE SPECIFIC. REYES
THIRTY ONE PESTICIDES THAT BOWS
MENTIONING YOU COUNTING IT OUT
THROUGH A NORMAL PM TWO POINT
FIVE ALL OF THAT ARE THAT AND
MONITORING THAT LOOKS UPSET OR-
OR DUST YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THAT LEVEL OF DATA
THE ONLY OTHER THING THAT I'D
SAY IS THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF
THAT EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN
PROCESS SO AS WE DURING
COMMUNITY MEETINGS. TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ISSUES AND
CONCERNS THIS IS ONE OF THE TOP
ISSUES THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
COMMUNITY GROUPS IN
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS THE
BALLAST POINT ACROSS THE STATE
NOT JUST. IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. OKAY AND I KNOW THAT
THE MANY ARE LAW TO THE- KNOW
THAT INTEGRATE. MANAGEMENT DOES
LIVE. PESTICIDES JUST REDO THEM
SO ON THIS WE'RE GONNA IT- PUMP
UP THE GRANT PROGRAM IN THE OUT
REACH PROGRAM. IS THAT SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE ALREADY. BELIEVE
IT I GUESS IS A FOR LACK OF
BETTER TERM THEY'RE THEY'RE
USING AN INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT TELL ME WHAT YOU
THINK IS GONNA HAPPEN OF
ASSUMING THIS COMES UP. HOWEVER
WE ARE PEOPLE GONNA GET THE
GRANTS THAT HAVE BEEN WAITING
EVENT TONIGHT WHERE YOU GONNA
GET OTHER- BRAK ARE YOU GET IT
HOPE TO CHANGE THE PRACTICES OF
SOME. LATE ADOPTERS RIGHT THE%
EARLY ADOPTERS ARE ALREADY YEAH
I GET THAT RIGHT AND THEY MAY
NOT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY SO THEY
CAN GET THAT MONEY BACK TELL ME
HOW YOU SEE THE GRANT PROGRAMS
IN THE- REGION IMPLEMENTATION
WORKING. WELL SPEAKING FOR THE
DPR GRANT PROGRAMS AND- I'LL
LET SECRETARY ROSS SPEAK TO.
SEE HERE AS GRANT PROGRAMS.
AREN'T RICH PROGRAMS FOR
RESEARCH INTO ALTERNATIVES ARE
OFTEN IF NOT ALWAYS OVER
SUBSCRIBED SO I THINK THAT WITH
THIS INVESTMENT. FROM THIS YEAR
NO PROPOSAL WILL BE ABLE TO
MEET THE DEMAND THAT ACADEMICS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE. COME TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON FOR VARIOUS.
RESEARCH INTO THE BIO
PESTICIDES AND BIO CONTROLS OR
OTHERWISE TOXIC WAYS OF.
MANAGING PASSED IN THE
AGRICULTURAL ENVIRONMENT
INCREASINGLY IN EUROPE AND
FIRE. IN ADDITION SIR YOU KNOW
THERE THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT INTO. THE NON GRANT
IPM PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE HERE
DPR WHICH INCLUDE ARE HEALTHY
SCHOOLS. PROGRAM IN. AND
VARIOUS OTHERS HE AT THE TO
WE'VE CREATED INTEGRATED
CUSTOMER BRANCH IN. THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WHICH REALLY
HAS WORKED WITH. CHILD CARE
CENTERS AND SCHOOLS AND OTHER
SENSITIVE SITES AROUND THE
STATE TO ENSURE THAT FROM TO
ADMINISTER THE KINDS OF%
PESTICIDES THAT YOU MAY FIND IN
THE CLEANING CLOSET. ARE DOING
SO IN A WAY THAT. DOESN'T
IMPACT THE HEALTH OF STUDENTS
OR OTHERS WHO WORK IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS FOR THE
APPLICATORS THEMSELVES. SO
THEY'RE SORT OF A TWIN
INVESTMENT INTO BOTH THE GRANT
PROGRAMS AT DPR WHICH ARE
SUBSTANTIAL HAVE YOU KNOW THE-
REALLY IMPORTANT RESULTS. AS
WELL AS THE IPM PROGRAMS. THAT
WE HAVE HERE IN HOUSE. SECTOR
RESCUE JUMP IN REAL QUICK I THE
CITY OF. I WOULD LOVE TO OUR
GRANT PROGRAMS ARE FAIRLY SMALL
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'REVERY
EFFECTIVE THEY DO IN SEVERAL
THINGS ONE IS WITHIN A STATE
THAT HAS FOUR HUNDRED CROSS
MANY OF THEM ARE SO SPECIALIZED
THAT IT'S HARD TO ATTRACT. A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT TO
CREATE PEST MANAGEMENT TOOLS
FOR SOME OF THOSE CROPS THERE
IS A REGIONAL APPROACH THAT'S
FUNDED THROUGH THE FARM BILL
CALLED I ARE FOR THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE WHAT WE CALL BURKE AND
CROPS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ALTERNATIVES. AND BEING
ABLE TO PUT SOME STATE FUNDING
OUT THERE WITH THAT KIND OF
WORK IS A CLEAR SIGNAL THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVES
TO THE MOST TOXIC PESTICIDES AS
A WAY TO GET THAT SYSTEM GOING
IN THAT DIRECTION THAT'S ONE
WAY WE DO OURS. THE OTHER ONE
IS IN IN RESTARTING THE
BIOLOGICALLY INTEGRATED FARMING
SYSTEM THIS IS ABOUT- A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
COULD BE A RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IT COULD
BE USED TO COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION. THAT ORGANIZES
GROUPS OF FARMERS- IN A REGION
AROUND THE COMMODITY TO DO
DEMONSTRATION OF HOW TO DO MORE
SYSTEMS APPROACH TO NOT JUST
LOOK AT THE PAST MANAGEMENT
CASE BUT TO LOOK AT THE OVERALL
SYSTEM INCLUDING SOIL HEALTH
AND OTHER PRACTICES THAT WILL
REDUCE THE PAST PRESSURE AND
REDUCE THE NEED FOR
INTERVENTION. AND THIS IS THE
WAY WE'RE FOCUSING ON
INCORPORATING ALTERNATIVES TO
THE MOST TAXED TAXING PAKCIK
PESTICIDES AND OUR THIRD ONE IS
ON PROACTIVE I PM. WHERE WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO USE OUR
MAPPING TOOLS TO SEE EMERGING
PAST ISSUES AGAIN IT'S
PARTNERING WITH THE RESEARCHER
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND A
COMMODITY GROUP TO START TO
TEST WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
IMMEDIATELY SHOULD THAT HAPPEN
AND THAT'S USUALLY AROUND
BIOCONTROL WHICH IS FINDING A
FRIENDLY PASSED. THAT WILL WILL
DESTROY THE AND BASIC PASSED
THOSE ARE. THREE EXAMPLES OF
HOW WE USE OUR VERY SMALL
PROGRAMS REALLY. BEST AS A
WHOLE. I WOULD SAY PRO. THAT
PAIR OF. THEMSELVES DOING
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOR
OTHER FARMERS WITH COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION ON FIELD TRIALS IS
ONE OF OUR MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS
AT GETTING THOSE PRACTICES OUT
THERE AND REALLY GETTING
ADAPTATION AT SCALE IN
CALIFORNIA. EXCELLENT AND I
KNOW SECRETARY BLUMENFELD I
REALLY WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU ON
THAT THE TIERED MIL FEE BUT DID
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ABOUT
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION. SIX
WHICH IS SIXTY MILLION ANNUALLY
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS ON THE
AGRICULTURAL BURNING AND WHAT
THIS MAY MEAN UP PROPOSALS FOR
THE AIR QUALITY IN THE- IN OUR
AGRICULTURAL BASIS. WELL THEN
YEAH THANK SEVENTY ROSS AND I.
HAVE BEEN ACTING ON THIS ONE AS
WELLWITH THAT EVERY SOURCES.
BOARD- SAYS. RIGHT THIS I JUST
VERY THE REALLY WANT TO COME
AND- AGRICULTURAL IN THE
VALLEY- THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
IS AN ASH AND- IS IN SEVERE NON
ATTAINMENT OF THE FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR ACT STANDARDS CHáVEZ I WAS
AND PARTICULAR MAD AT AND- IT'S
PARTICULARLY STUBBORN ISSUE
BECAUSE OF THE TOPOGRAPHY. OF
THE VALLEY- WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
THAT YOU KNOW A IN IN WAYS TO
THE TO THE LA BASIN BUT HAS A
LOT OF UNIQUE CHALLENGES SO.
OVER THE LAST DECADES
AGRICULTURE. VOLUNTARILY IS
COME AND STEPPED UP TO THE
PLATE AND SAID HOW DO WE HELP
HOW TO EXPAND RESEARCH HOW DO
WE THINK ABOUT ADOPTING NEW
PRACTICES- THE FOLLOW PROGRAM
IS YOU KNOW. POSSIBLY FUNDED
THROUGH USDA WITH OTHER
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL TRACTOR
CONVERSION PROGRAMS PROBABLY IN
THE WILD. AND THE FAMAS LOOKING
EVERY DAY AT WAYS OF THINKING
ABOUT. DIFFERENT FARMING
PRACTICES THAT HELP REDUCE
EMISSIONS SO I JUST WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY FOR
THAT. AND THEN SECONDLY SAY IN
THIS PARTICULAR AREA AND THAT
ANY- WHICH IS. A LONG AND
COMPLEX ISSUE WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD I'VE GOT TO A
POINT WHERE DOES THE SCIENCE
WAS IN THAT WE NEED TO SET AN
END DATE FOR THAT- BUT WE
REALLY CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT
PROVIDING MEANINGFUL. I'M
FUNDING TO ALLOW PRACTICES THAT
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING TO
NEED TO HAPPEN IT JUST NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IN A CONTROLLED MANNER-
ON THAT SONG SO THAT THE
EMISSIONS DO NOT CONTRIBUTE TO
AIR POLLUTION AND SO. THIS THIS
IS- BEEN A AB EIGHT VERY- I
THINK COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
WITH THE AGRICULTURE- THEY DO
NOT. ONE NECESSARILY IF YOU'RE
THERE IN THE ROOM THEY WOULD BE
LIKE WE LIVE LONGER BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE RESOURCES
BOARD- HAS. EIGHT EIGHT DATE ON
ENDING AND BANNING AND IN THAT.
REMAINING THREE YEARS WE NEED
TO WORK. TO GET THAT TO THE TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS ISN'T. THAT
IS REALLY PART OF - AND-
HOWEVER. AROUND OUR OUR THAT.
TO A LOT OF THE WOULD WILL BE
DIFFICULT I'M AN EXAMPLE AND
CHAD IS. THAT KAREN IS MOST
FAMILIAR WITH BECAUSE IS AN
INDUSTRY THAT SHE REPRESENTED
BUT IN THAT. IN THE TABLE GRAPE
AND WINE INDUSTRY- THE HOMAGE-
THAT'S BUILT OUT OF METAL AND
HAS WIDELY GOES THROUGH THE
VINES HARRY HOW YOU TAKE THAT
Y. ALEX- SO THAT IT CAN
PROBABLY BE. AND AND HOW YOU
MANAGE THOSE MATERIALS THESE
NEED TO ALSO BE TRANSFORMED AND
SO THERE'S A LOT OF- ON THE
VERY POSITIVE SIDE THAT RELATES
TO REGENERATIVE. AG AND WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. THIS
IS A NEW TO BUY CHIPS STRINGS.
SO THAT DOZEN NEED TO KNOW BE.
IT CAN BE CHIPPED- AND- PUT
BACK NTO THE SOIL I'M AS AN
AMENDMENT- TO HELP THAT OIL
HEALTH AND THAT COMMON IN THE
SOIL BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
FUNDING TO DO IT SAID THIS IS A-
THANK. YOU PROBABLY WON'T FIND
AN ISSUE THAT KAREN AND I FEEL
MORE PASSIONATE ABOUT. HOW THE
OTHER THAN IBM AND THIS ONE YET
ANYTHING ANYTHING YOU CAN DO TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM- AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL. DETAILS ON IT AT THE
END OF THE SEASON SECRETARY
ROSS SAID TO COMPLEMENT WHAT I.
WAS SAYING HOPEFULLY THANKS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S. I'M SORRY
SECRETARY. NO I WAS GOING TO
CALL IN FARMERS AND HE'S REALLY
GOOD. THANKS FOR THE ALL I DID
WANT TO COME THAT THIS IS A
PRETTY EXPENSIVE EQUIPMENT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND WE
HAVE A PARTICULAR CONCERN ABOUT
HOW THE SMALL AND MID SIZED
GROWERS ARE ABLE TO DO THIS-
INSTEAD SO THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME TAX. TO WORK WITH
THEM BUT THE INDUSTRY HAS AS
THEY ARE- THEY KNOW THAT THIS
CAN WORK. I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE
MORE RECENT ONE OF A NEW
PRACTICE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND THROUGH OUR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS UNDER HEALTHY SOILS.
WHICH IS CALLED WHOLE ORCHARD
RECYCLING WHICH IS A HUGE
COOPERATIVE HUGE PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT CAN COME OUT AND
LITERALLY PULL OUT THE WHOLE
TREE. AS WE KNOW. ALMOND
ORCHARDS LAST POSSIBLY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND THEN THEY ALL
HAVE TO BE REPLACED- IN THIS
PULLS THOSE TREES OUT AND THEN
DOES THE CHIPPING RIGHT THERE
IN THE FIELD. AND THEN
REINCORPORATED INTO THIS ALSO
WE CAN CONTINUE THAT CARBON
SEQUESTRATION PRACTICE- THAT
ONE IS A NEWER PROJECT FOR US
AND IT IS NOW FUND IT'S ARE
HEALTHY CELLS PROGRAMS. AS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR THE ALMOND
INDUSTRY BUT SMALL FARMERS WILL
HAVE SMALLER AMOUNTS OF WOODY
BIOMASS STAND. THERE WILL BE A
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO GET.
THIS KIND OF EQUIPMENT AND
THESE KINDS OF PRACTICES
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY- TO
ACCOMMODATE THE DIVERSITY OF
FARMERS THAT WE HAVE. EXCELLENT
WELL LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
PANEL I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
VICE CHAIR DALIAN AND ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO LIKE TO. HAVE
QUESTIONS OF OUR PANEL. OR THE-
WITH A- BATTLE OFFICE. SENATE
ALI THANK YOU A MISTER CHAIR SO
I'M I DIDN'T I WANTED. SLOW
DOWN A LITTLE BIT ACT TALK
ABOUT THE SO I WANT TO SHOW YOU
THIS IS A- THIS IS ISSUE BY DPR
THIS IS ACTUALLY AND
APPLICATORS PERMIT I BELIEVE
I'M THE ONLY LEGISLATOR THAT.
HOUSE ONE. I SHOW THIS IN EQ-
WHICH IS ALLOWS ME TO USE. S.
TRAINING ME TO USE. HERBICIDES
PESTICIDES ON MY PHONE. AND I
HAVE TO GO TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION EVERY TWO YEARS TO
MAKE SURE THAT MY EMPLOYEES AND
I'M DOING USING SAFE PRACTICES
ON OUR FARM SO I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT I DO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND IN THIS AREA
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT. BARMY
I'M A FARMER AND WE GET WE GET
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN SACRAMENTO.
THAT YOU KNOW. SHARE THEIR
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT HAPPENS ON
FARMS. AND IT'S REALLY NOT.
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS ON FARMS
ITS IT'S- MAYBE- THEY'VE BEEN
EDUCATED IN THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
ON THE GROUND AS MUCH AS MAYBE
THE SECRETARY AND SOME OTHERS
BUT I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE CHALLENGES OF BEING ON A
FARM IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE ALL
FIRST OF ALL NUMBER ONE I'M
JUST FOR EXAMPLE I'M DOING SOME
ORGANIC FARMING I JUST STARTED
THE PAPERWORK LAST YEAR TO FOR
THIS LAST WEEK TO- START DOING
ORGANIC FARMING BUT I DO NEED
THE TOOLS OF HERBICIDES I DON'T
USE ANY PESTICIDES THANK GOD I
DON'T HAVE ANY BUG PROBLEMS- SO
FAR I HAVEN'T HAD THOSE- BUT IN
MY DISTRICT I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU THAT. 95% OF THE-
STRAWBERRY PLANTS NOT TO BURY%
ITSELF BUT THE PLANT THE
NURSERIES ARE IN MY DISTRICT
AND THEY GROW THE PLANT SO THAT
IN WATSONVILLE THEY CAN. GROW
THE VERY. FOREIGN BORN MEXICO
OR SOMEPLACE ISN'T ALL OVER THE
WORLD. AND THERE'S CERTAIN-
FUMIGANTS AND DECIDES IN
HERBICIDES IT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
THERE IS NO OTHER ALTERNATIVE
FOR THESE PESTICIDES AND
HERBICIDES AND THEY USE THEM AS
MOST FARMERS THE FIRST POLICY
THAT'S A COST NUMBER ONE TO
APPLICATIVE TO YOU TO BY THE
CHEMICAL TO ALWAYS IN THE COST
TO IT AND SO WE ARE CONSTANTLY
TRYING TO DRIVE OUR COST DOWN.
BECAUSE WE COMPETE IN A GLOBAL
MARKET I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT GETS MISSED IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT IS THE WE COMPETE IN THE
GLOBAL MARKET. AS WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT WANTING TO BE THE
LEADERS IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL-
SPACE AND WE ARE WE HAVE THE
SAFEST FOOD IN THE WORLD AND WE
PRODUCE. THE GREATEST VARIETY
OF COMMODITIES IN THE WORLD
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE DO A
REALLY GOOD JOB AT IT BUT
FARMERS HAVE TO STAY IN
BUSINESS. AND WHEN YOU TO STAY
IN BUSINESS MEANS THAT YOU'RE
COMPETING AGAINST. OTHER
COUNTRIES MEXICO. IS A HUGE
COMPETITOR OF OURS WHEN IT
COMES TO. THE SALAD BOWL OR
THOSE TYPES OF COMMODITIES
STRAWBERRIES THINGS THAT WITH
FRESH FRESH PRODUCE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME REGULATIONS
THAT WE HAVE NOR DID THEY HAVE
THE SAME LABOR LAWS OR THE I
MEAN THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
ON. SO IF WE WANT TO BE LEADERS
IN CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE TO KEEP
THE FARMER ON THE GROUND. IF
YOU'RE RUNNING OUT OF BUSINESS
YOU HAVE DEFEATED YOUR PURPOSE
BECAUSE HE'S THEY'RE MOVING TO
OTHER COUNTRIES. WHICH THEY
STILL SELL THEIR PRODUCTS HERE.
BUT IT PUTS THE FARMER IN
CALIFORNIA AT A DISADVANTAGE SO
I JUST WANTED LATE I WANTED TO
SHARE SOME OF THE THINGS. THAT
ARE. ARE DIFFICULT AS SOMEBODY
WHO DOES IT EVERY DAY. I WAS ON
A TRACTOR SATURDAY WHEN. WHEN I
WAS WORKING ON ONE ACTUALLY
WHEN THE CHAIR CALLED ME TO
TALK TO ME ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS WE HAD IN THIS. COMING
UP IN THIS COMMITTEE. SOMEONE
SAY I SUPPORT AG COMMISSIONERS
WE HAVETO CALL THEM BEFORE WE
APPLY AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
WE'RE GONNA APPLY. PRODUCT TO
OUR FIELD SO THEY KNOW THAT
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO WITH
THERE'S STANDARDS ON WIND. A.
N. ALL KINDS OF PROTOCOLS OF
SAFETY FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
EMPLOYEES. WHEN YOU SPRAY IN
FACT I DON'T ALLOW ANY MY PLACE
OF WORK TO DO IT I DO IT
BECAUSE IT'S JUST A BETTER WAY
TO KEEPING. THEM SAFE. BECAUSE
OF THE REGULATIONS ARE. VERY
STRICT SO I WANT TO SAYI'M I'M
A BIG PROPONENT OF THE AG
COMMISSIONERS AND THE UC. I'VE
DONE MYSELF. PROJECTS ON MY
LAND WITH THE UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION TO. TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO FARM IN A MORE.
EFFICIENT AND MORE- FRIENDLY
SAFE. FOR THE ENVIRONMENT SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE ONE
AREA THAT I CAN TALK ABOUT AND
I BELIEVE THAT I'VE SOME OF
EVEN I DON'T HAVE A COLLEGE
EDUCATION TO PROVE IT. I HAVE A
LIFETIME IN THE GENERATIONS OF
FAMILY ON THE SAME PIECE OF
LAND. MAKING IT GROW THINGS FOR
PEOPLE TO EAT. SO I WANT TO
JUST THAT'S THE PREFACE OF WHAT
WAS IT THE MIL TAX I HAVE A
pI HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP COMMENTS
THAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT. IT'S
NOT ALWAYS. IT SEEMS TO ME AS A
LEGISLATOR THAT. YOU KNOW ONCE
SOMETHING GETS IN THE PIPELINE
THERE'S NO POSSIBLE WAY TO EVER
CHANGE IT WHEN IT WHEN IT. ONE
IS NOT WORKING RIGHT WE HAVE
SOME PROBLEMS WE'VE BEEN TO
I'VE BEEN TALKING IT WITH DPR
IN OUR LAST HEARING. EARLIER
THIS YEAR. I ASKED THE- THE
SECRETARY ABOUT MARIJUANA GROWS
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT LATER
IN THE IN THE POLLUTION. THE
MASSIVE POLLUTION THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE RULE- THE
URBAN RURAL AREAS. OF THE STATE
SO BUT HERE'S MY QUESTION I
WANT TO JUST MAKE A STATEMENT
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THIS YEAR THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT STAFFING THIS
IS THE DPR WAS THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT POINT SEVEN P. Y.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
ENTIRE STAFFING WAS THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO WHICH
IS EQUATES TO GROWTH OF TWENTY
TWO P. WEISS OVER THE FIVE
YEARS THE BCP INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF P. WISE BY FIFTY ONE
IN JUST TWO YEARS. SO CONNECTED
THIS IS MY QUESTION CAN THE
DEPARTMENT FIND THAT MANY
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS TO FILL
THESE POSITIONS. SOME GROWTH
MAY BE REASONABLE BUT THIS IS
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF GROWTH WE
WENT FROM A HALF A MILLION
DOLLAR. I B. I P. M. FUNDING TO
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION.
THAT'S A SEVENTEEN FOLD IN A
VERY SHORT TIME SO. AS IT AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN AROUND
GOVERNMENT MAYBE TOO LONG TO
FIND OUT THAT. CAN YOU ACTUALLY
GET IT DONE WE HAD THE HEARING
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT. LOOKING AT OIL
WELLS AND THERE WAS TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS IN THAT AND THEY HAD
THEY HAD HIRED THREE IN THE
YEAR IN THE US FOR TWENTY SIX
MORE SO I'D LIKE TO. LET SEVEN
THOUSAND ELECT TO HAVE THEIR
INTERNAL SOCIAL JEANNIE TALK
ABOUT THE- INCREASE IN IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS HAVE POSITIONS
AT THE DEPARTMENT PESTICIDES
AND IT CAN THEY GET THE
QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO EVEN AND IT
IS OUR THE RESEARCHERS AT.
AVAILABLE AT THE UC'S DUST DUST
IS THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS.
SENATOR DOLLY I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
QUESTIONS HERE AND YOU SPEAK
WITH REAL AUTHORITY ON THESE
ISSUES AND I'M SURE YOU ARE THE
ONLY LEGISLATOR TO HAVE ONE OF
THOSE CARDS IN YOUR WALLET. AND
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'VE WORKED WITH BOTH YOUR
AYE COMMISSIONERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE PR
STAFF PRESUMABLY OVER THE
YEARS. ON THOSE ISSUES. YOU
KNOW YOU RAISED SOME GREAT
POINTS ABOUT. THE USE OF
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
TOOLS AND PRACTICES AROUND THE
STATE AND SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
YOU POINTED OUT THE- YOU KNOW I
PM THAT BIG IPM TOOLBOX
CONTAINS THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT YOU'RE USING IN YOUR
OPERATION. AND THAT FARMERS ARE
USING ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT IT DOES IS
ALSO FOCUSES THOUGH ON. A MORE
SUSTAINABLE WAYS TO MANAGE
PESTS IN THE BIO CONTROLS AND
CULTURAL PRACTICES. HABITAT
MODIFICATION THAT'S ALSO A
CENTRAL PART OF I. P. WITH
REGARDS TO YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT STAFFING- YOU
KNOW OUR STAFF HAS GROWN OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS BECAUSE
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE GROWN
OVER THE LAST. SEVERAL YEARS
AND WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO DO MORE
AS A DEPARTMENT. AND I THINK
THAT THOSE ARE GOOD THINGS
ENGAGING WITH COMMUNITIES IS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF THAT WE'VE
REALLY DONE A LOT OF WONDERFUL
WORK THERE- WITH REGARDS TO
BRINGING NEW STAFF ON SIR YOU
KNOW THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR. A
STATE AGENCIES. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY
IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN CHALLENGING
FOR US BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
IDENTIFY. A LOT OF QUALITY
CANDIDATES FOR WORK HERE DPR-
YOU KNOW I HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE. A
NUMBER OF WHICH ARE IN THE
FIELD THE BULK OF WHICH ARE IN
SACRAMENTO AND THEIR SCIENTISTS
AND GETTING ON. A HIGHLY
QUALIFIED ECO TOXICOLOGIST
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA
EFFORT BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT. AND IN TERMS OF THE
EXPANSION OF THE IPM PROGRAM
WHERE WE'LL SEE. A NUMBER OF
NEW STAFF I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO MEET THAT
CHALLENGE AND GET THE RIGHT
PEOPLE ON BOARD TO HELP US
DELIVER THESE PROGRAMS FOR.
CALIFORNIANS AND FINALLY I
WOULD JUST SAY ON THE CAMPUS
ISSUE YOU AND I HAD A GOOD
EXCHANGE WHEN I WAS BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO AND SINCE THEN WE'VE
DONE SOME FOLLOW UP. WITH YOUR
STAFF ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS AROUND THE STATE
TO. ADDRESS THE POLLUTION THAT
YOU FIND AT ILLEGAL GROW SITES.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND COUNTY SHERIFF'S WHERE WE
CAN. AND BEFORE TOO LONG I'M
GOING TO TAKE YOU UP ON YOUR
OFFER TO COME UP TO YOUR
DISTRICT AND- AND DO A LITTLE
BIT OF A TOUR BUT- WE'RE
WORKING HARD ON THAT AS WELL. I
THINK YOU KNOW THE CENTRAL PART
OF YOUR QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
WE WILL BE ABLE TO FIND STAFF
I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN. WELL
THANK YOU FOR THAT I WHEN I
ALSO WANTED. IT THANK YOU FOR
THE- WHAT MY ACTUALLY MY-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DOLLY DID A TOUR
AND ASKED FOR SOMEBODY TO COME
FROM THE DEPARTMENT- UP TO
SISKIYOU AND- THEY WERE ABLE
TO. MEET THAT OBLIGATION SO I
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
THAT- DURING OUR EQ HEARING I
MENTION IT TO SENATOR ALAN AND-
IF THE CHEROKEE Q. WHO WHAT WAS
GOING TO GO AS WELL SO WE'RE
GONNA DO A TOUR- SOON AND I. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
SOMEBODY FROM THE AGENCY IS
ABLE TO GO AND SEE- WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE ENVIRONMENT-
MAINLY AND- SISKIYOU COUNTY
IT'S OUT OF CONTROL AND NOT
RIGHT. SO I THOUGHT. SO THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO TOUCH
ON WAS THE BURN IF THAT'S OKAY
WE. WE MOVED INTO THAT IS IF WE
MAY. SO THOSE ARE NOT
FRUSTRATION MIND- SO AS MANY
LEGISLATORS KNOW THAT I'VE I'VE
WORKED ON BIOMASS FOR IT SEEMS
LIKE MY WHOLE LIFE- IT IS
COMPLICATED AND IT'S DIFFICULT
AND- BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IT
MAINLY ON THE ON THE FOREST
FIRE PART BUT- WHEN WE DID. AB
EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH WAS A
TRAILER BILL SOMETIME AGO I'VE
WE ACTUALLY EXTENDED BIOMASS
CONTRACTS ARE OF FORCED THE
UTILITIES TO BUY ENERGY FOR
BIOMASS PLANTS IN THE IN THE E.
J. COMMUNITY CAME IN AND MANY
IN IN MANY INSTANCES AND
OPPOSED OUR LEGISLATION- AND
MAINLY IN THE VALLEY AND SO- WE
HAD A 60% HI HI HI. HI THE FUEL
HAZARD ZONES AND 40% COULD COME
FROM ANYWHERE ELSE AND THAT GOT
CHANGED IN THE SENATE THAT TIME
I WAS IN THIS ASSEMBLY BUT BUT
THE POINT IS THAT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT OPEN BURN. AND YOU TALK
ABOUT THE VALLEY THE BASIN AND
THERE ARE HUGE CHALLENGES AS-
WAS STATED EARLIER ABOUT JUST
THE TOPOGRAPHY OF THE VALLEY
AND HOW. IT DOESN'T CARRY THOSE
EMISSIONS OUT SO IF YOU'RE
GONNA IF YOU'RE NOT GONNA IT IF
YOU'RE NOT GONNA OPEN BURN. IT
IF YOU CAN BURN IN A CONTROLLED
ENVIRONMENT IT'S A LOT LESS-
CARBON IN AND POLLUTANTS. AND
BUT DURING THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
OF WRANGLING THE E. J.
COMMUNITY IN THE VALLEY HAS
OPPOSED. USING BIOMASS PLANTS
AND THEY SHUT HIM DOWN SO THERE
IS NO PLACE NOW FOR THE FARMER
TO TAKE THAT ALMOND TREE- OR IN
THE SMALL FARMERS IN THE BIG
FARMERS FARMERS THE I HEARD THE
SECRETARY ROSS TALK ABOUT DOING
SOME. YOU KNOW- MULCHING IN
PUTTING THAT BACK IN THE SO AS
A FARMER I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU- SOME OF THE PROCESSES THAT
YOU'RE NOT SURE ON THE GROUND
AND SEE YES YOU CAN. YOU CAN
TAKE THE BIOMASS AND PUT IT
BACK IN THE GROUND IN A BUILDER
SO WE ALL KNOW THAT I DO I USE
BIO CHAR MY OWN FARMS IS AS A-
AS A- A SOIL. ADDITIVE THAT IS
VERY HELPFUL IN THIS AND STORES
CARBON AT THE SAME TIME. BUT
THE PROCESS IS THAT ACTUALLY A
TAP ON THE GROUND ARE VERY
DIFFICULT AND NOT EASY TO DO
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S FUNDING
FOR SOME OF THOSE. PROJECTS IN
INTO QUITE FRANKLY IN SOME IN
JUST LET PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
BUT I DON'T WANT I WILL I GET
IS THE POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
THAT. YOU CAN'T FORCE EVERYBODY
IN THE SAME BOX OR HAS TO BE
MORE THAN ONE TOOL. TO GET
WHERE WE WANT TO GO AND IF WE
DON'T HAVE BIOMASS PLANTS THAT
BURN. YES THEY BURN AND THEY
AND THEY BECAUSE EMISSIONS BUT
THE MISSIONS ARE SO MUCH LESS
THAN AN OPEN BURN. AND WHEN
THERE IS NO OTHER OPTION THAT'S
A BETTER OPTION THAN AN OPEN
BURN OPTION AND SO- I JUST WANT
TO TIE THAT IN TO. TO THE
SUSTAINABLE FARMING MEANS THAT
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET EVERY
THERE'S NOT EVERY SINGLE FARM
IS NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE ALL THESE TREES
BACK INTO THEIR FARM IT JUST IT
TAKES A LONG TIME FOR THAT. TO
BREAK DOWN AND ACTUALLY BECOME
ORGANIC MATERIAL THAT'S GOING
TO BE USABLE AND STORE THAT
CARBON. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT THAT WE YOU KNOW. IN
SACRAMENTO WE TALK ABOUT
FARMING AND WHEN YOU GET ON THE
FARM IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT.
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT BALLGAME.
AND I WANTED TO TIE THAT BACK
TO MY- OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT.
IF WE DON'T HAVE CALIFORNIA
FARMERS HERE. YOU KNOW. I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW MANY. PEOPLE I
KNOW THAT HAVE BEEN. FARMING IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A LONG TIME WHO
JUST PUT A CONSERVATION
EASEMENT ON THEIR LAND AND
WALKED AWAY FROM IT. BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT WILL PAY YOU TO
FOLLOW YOUR TO SET IT ASIDE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT. NO MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY AND I
KNOW THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
SOON BUT IT'S HAPPENING
INCREMENTALLY AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO COMPETE. SO
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR- I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE
A REAL GOOD CLOSE LOOK AT THIS
MAIL- P. AND HOWARD'S. HOUSE
DIVIDED UP IN THE AG COMMUNITY
ARE GOOD STEWARDS OF THE LAND.
AND IF YOU GO OUT AND MEET WITH
AND THEY'RE AWESOME PEOPLE THAT
YOU SEE PEOPLE ARE GREAT THAT
COMMISSIONERS ARE AWESOME WE
HAVE SEVERAL THERE WERE AT
LEAST WHEN I WAS AT THE COUNTY
WE HAD SEVERAL AG
COMMISSIONER'S. POSITIONS OPEN
IS A VERY DIFFICULT-
REQUIREMENT TO BE AN AG
COMMISSIONER SOME ACT MISTERS
WERE SHARED WITH OTHER COUNTIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST PARTNER
THERE A TECHNICAL AND IT'S A
RIGOROUS- THE SCHOOLING TO GET
TO WHERE THEY TO GET THEM AND
SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS
THAT WE CAN IF WE CAN GET TO
WHERE THEY WANT TO GO HERE SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THERE'S
TWO AND A HALF. MILL IS. PART
OF THE FEES ARE IN THERE FOR
ACT. OF DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANY. IMPORT RE HAVE DO YOU
THINK YOU NEED TO YOU WANT TO
DO ON THIS FIVE HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION DOLLAR RECORD SENATE
AGRICULTURAL PROPOSAL. HEY
CHRIS LEISURE KNOW WHAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I WOULD
JUST START OFF. BY SAYING WE'RE
STILL IN THE SENATE
AGRICULTURAL BUDGET PLAN- BUT
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS.
JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE COMMENT
IN RELATION TO- THE MIDDLE
SEGMENT- AS NOTED IN THE SENATE
ACT PACKAGE IT ONLY INCLUDES
LIMITED TERM GENERAL FUND FOR
THE TRANSITION TO SAFER
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT-
WHICH I SECRETARY. MENTION IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OVERALL- IN TERMS OF
A STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE. OR THEY
NEED TO EXPAND IDEA ANOTHER
ACTIVITIES DESCRIBED PREVIOUSLY
SO JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT- THAT YOUR
NOSE THAT'S WHEN APPROACH WHICH
WE BELIEVE IS A SUSTAINABLE.
LONGER TERM SOLUTION- THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORTED BY THE
APPROPRIATE REFERENCE REVENUE
SOURCE- THE MIDDLE ASSESSMENT
RATHER THAN A JOB. THANK YOU
MISS A STEP TOWARD YOU DON'T
IT'S OKAY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO ACTUALLY SUPPORT ONE
OF THE SENATE PROPOSALS THAT WE
HAVE IT'S ALL RIGHT WE LIKE
THAT WE LIKE TO THINK OF IT AS
A PARTNERSHIP. I KNOW SOMETIMES
<c.red>T APPEARS THAT A PARTICULAR</c>
WERE HERE IN SUB TOO BUT YOU
KNOW IT'S ACTUALLY OKAY FOR
FINANCES SAY. GOODNESS GRACIOUS
THAT WAS A GOOD IDEA WE'RE
GOING TO GO WITH THAT SO WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN
UP WILL IT'LL IT'LL BE BACK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEES AND THE
SECOND TIME THINKS. EVERYBODY
WHO TESTIFIED AND PARTICIPATED
AND LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS
ANOTHER SMALL SENATE PROPOSAL
FOR A WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
RESILIENCY PACKAGE THIS.
OPPOSES OF FIVE. DOLLAR PROGRAM
OVER A FIVE YEAR IN LET'S HEAR
FROM THE- KELLY ALSO OFFICE TO
BE THIS. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HELEN
CHRISTINE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE THIS
MORNING OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
ASKED TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
SUMMARY OF THE SENATE'S
WILDFIRE PACKAGE FOR YOU TODAY.
BUT BEFORE YOU JUMP INTO TE
PROPOSED PACKAGE I WANTED TO
PROVIDE SOME BRIEF CONTEXT ON
RECENT WILDFIRES IN THE STATE
AND THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE
THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST MONTH. WITH
REGARD TO RECENT FIRES- I DO
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO NOTE THAT
AND MANY OF THE LARGEST AND
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA'S RECORDED HISTORY
HAVE OCCURRED OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND OF COURSE
TWENTY TWENTY WAS A
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING
WILDFIRE YOUR FOR THE STATE.
THE PATTERN OF INCREASED
WILDFIRE RISK IS BELIEVED TO BE
CAUSED BY MULTIPLE FACTORS
INCLUDING HISTORICAL FOREST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES CLIMATE
CHANGE AND INCREASED
DEVELOPMENT IN THE WETLANDS.
NOTABLY UNCONTROLLED LARGE
WILDFIRES SUCH AS THE ONES THAT
WE THOUGHT RAVAGE THE STATE
LAST YEAR CAN HAVE A VARIETY OF
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES
THE ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
ECONOMY AND OF COURSE STATE AND
LOCAL BUDGETS. THE LAST MONTH
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED IN EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE THAT ALLOCATED
VERY SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
TOWARDS MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
FOCUSED ON WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND MITIGATION EFFORTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE INCLUDED FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE CURRENT YEAR FOR ROUGHLY
TWO DOZEN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
OVER HALF OF THE FENCE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION
SUPPORTED PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO
PROMOTE HEALTHY FORESTS AND
LANDSCAPES GENERALLY BY
REMOVING. HAZARDOUS FUELS. MORE
THAN ONE THIRD OF THE- HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT MILLION. THE END
STILL. DATE OF WILDFIRE FUEL
BREAKS AND THE REMAINING FUNDS
TOTALING FIFTY FIVE. TO PRY
FROM. CAN HARD. FORCED ECONOMIC.
AND SCIENCE BASED ME FOR
MANAGED. I SO ARE THE TOTAL WAS
FOR MOST OF IT FOR HUNDRED
NUMBER MILLION WAS FROM THE
FUND A ONE TIME. HI THERE ARE
FINDS HUNDRED TWO FIVE MILLION
WERE FROM G. YEAR AT.
CONSISTENT WITH ASKING. OH ONE.
THIRTY EIGHT. OF THE EARLY ACT
WELFARE PACKAGE WITH A- TO
ENABLE. TO START WORK. ON CRIED
RATHER THAN WAITING TILL
PASSAGE THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. IN I STARTED WORK
IMMEDIATELY ADMIN. IN THE- THAT
IT ANTICIPATES THE PROJECT WILL
BE IN PLACE. ROUGHLY ONE FIRE
SEASONS THANTHEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN OTHERWISE. AND WE KNOW
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S
EXPERTS BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
IS AT SIGNIFICANT RISK FOR
ANOTHER VERY BAD FIRE SEASON
THIS YEAR GIVEN HOW HOT AND DRY
IT SPENT. WITH THE EARLY ACTION
WELFARE WAS PASSED WAS AND
KNOWLEDGE MEN MAN MAN. BUT IT
WAS REALLY A FOR STEP I BASED.
CERTAINLY BUT A FIRST STEP AND
THEN WORKED ANYBODY CONSIDERED
AS PART OF THE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS. FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. WITH THAT CONTACTS
THE THING PROPOSE. IT PACKAGE
ADDS THIS NEXT STEP. AND THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES BILLION DOLLAR.
IN FUNDING FOR USED OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS FOR PROJECTS
AND PROGRAMS THAT PROMOTE
HEALTHY BY LANDS. REDUCE THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
I NAY COMMUNITIES MORE
RESILIENT TO WILDFIRES WHEN
THEY DO OCCUR. THIS IS A GREAT
THE SENATE PROPOSAL PROVIDES
FOR BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO BE SET ASIDE IN
A NEW SPECIAL FUNDS THE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCE SPENT. THE INTENT IS
THE EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION WOULD
BE USED FROM THIS BAND AND IT
WOULD BE WOULD BE APPROPRIATED
EACH YEAR BY THE LEGISLATURE-
AND THAT WOULD HAPPEN FOR FIVE
YEARS. AND THE SENATE PROPOSAL
ALSO PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR FROM TWO YEAR
AFTER FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
THAT IS WITH A SENSE EXTEND THE
COMMITMENT UNDER SB. NINE A
ONE. SO NOW TO BUY YEAR. FOR
THE BUDGET THE SAN PACKAGE
PROVIDE ONE BILLION DOLLARS SO
IT EIGHT HUNDRED AND- ABOUT BE
FROM THE- PREVENTION AND- FIND
INTO MY- MILLION. EACH YEAR. IT
WOULD BE ALLOCATED AS- IN THE-
TART ON PAGE TWO OF THE AGENDA-
THERE'S A- GOING IN THIS FIGURE
OUT TRY TO WATCH IT WATCH
THROUGH IT. I THE FUNDING
PROVIDED IN SIXTH. THE FIRST K.
THAT YOU'LL SEE IN. TABLE IS
RESULT. WILDLY SOME. THAN HALF
OF THE FACT. FIVE THIRTY. WE GO
TOWARDS. IN THIS CASE. AND
THESE PLEASE. WERE GENERALLY
MAKE WHILE LANDS MORE RESILIENT.
VERY HAS. FUEL THIS INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND- FIVE. FOR FOREST.
PROGRAM FIFTY NINE. FOR THE
FOURTH IMPROVE MY PROGRAM FOR
SMALL- TWENTY MILLION THE
FOURTH. LEGACY AND- NURSE.
PROGRAM FIFTEEN. FOR URBAN
FORESTRY. NINETEEN MILLION FOR
TRAVELING GAUGE MEANT. NINETY
MILLION. FOR EACH OF TWO
DEPARTMENT THAT DEPART. PARKS
ARE. AND THE- OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
TO SUPPORT WHILE. MANY ON THE
LAND. AND IN A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE MILLION
TO VARIOUS CONSERVANCY TO
SUPPORT FOREST. AND LANDSCAPE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS. THE NEXT
CATEGORY IS WHILE FUEL. ABOUT A
QUARTER OF THIS IN THE- TO
HUNDRED FIVE. WE GO TOWARDS
THESE WILDFIRE KILL BREAKS
BASICALLY FORTY MILLION FOR
CALIFORNIANS FIRE CREWS
PROJECTS EIGHTY MILLION FOR
FIRE PREVENTION GRANT FORTY
MILLION FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE
ENHANCECREATORS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE FORESTRY CORPS
PROGRAM. AND SIXTY MILLION FOR
THE REGIONAL FOREST AND FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM. THE REMAINING
CORE. OF THE FIND THE PAST
WOULD BE ACROSS NEXT K.
COMMUNITY HARDENING STANCE
BASED MANAGE. ECONOMIC STIMULUS-
SOME OTHER PROGRAM. WITH REGARD
TO COMMUNITY HARD NAY. THERE'S
ABOUT A FORTY FIVE MILLION THIS
CASE- AND MOST OF IT THIRTY
MILLION WOULD GO TOWARDS HOME
HARDENING THE REST. WOULD GO
TOWARDS DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTORS SEVEN MILLION FOR
THAT ACTIVITY AS WELL AS LAND
USE PLANNING AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION OUTREACH AND THERE'S
EIGHT MILLION FOR THAT. I NEXT
SPENT BASED MANAGEMENT THERE'S
FIFTY THREE MILLION FOR THIS
CATEGORY WHICH INCLUDES TWENTY
MILLION FOR ECOLOGICAL
MONITORING AND RESEARCH.
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR REMOTE
SENSING FIVE MILLION FOR PERMIT
EFFICIENCIES EIGHT MILLION FOR
THE USE OF SATELLITE DATA. I'M
SORRY FINALLY THE SATELLITE
DATA AND EIGHT MILLION TO
CONDUCT WILDFIRE COMING
ADAPTATION. SO NEXT OF COURSE
CAN TO THERE'S NINE MILLION FOR
THIS CAT. WHICH IS THIRTY THREE
MILLION KIND OF FOR. TWENTY
MILLION FOR WORK ABOUT. SIX
MILLION FOR MARKET DEVELOPMENT
AND TEN MILLION FOR
TRANSPORTATION GRANTS FOR
TIMBER AND WOOD REMOVAL.
FINALLY I THERE'S FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION PROPOSED FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS MOST OF THIS IS A
FIFTY MILLION IS PROPOSED FOR
FOREST AND WATERSHED HEALTH.
PROJECTS THERE'S ALSO EIGHT
MILLION FOR COOLING CENTERS
EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND BACKUP
SOLAR. SO YOU'LL NOTICE IN THIS
TABLE AND IT ALSO HAS A COLUMN
THAT SHOWS WHAT WAS IN THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGING YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT MANY OF THIS MANY
SIMILAR PROGRAMS WERE FUNDED AS
PART OF THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE BUT THIS- CERTAINLY
AUGMENT THE FUNDING TOWARDS.
THOSE PROGRAMS I ALSO FIND A
FEW NEW PROGRAMS. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE SENATE PROPOSES
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS AND
EVALUATION MEASURES AND THESE
MEASURES ARE INTENDED TO HELP
THE LEGISLATURE ASSESSED THE
OUTCOMES THAT ARE ACHIEVED WITH
THE SPENCER THIS IS A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION OF.
STATE FUNDING AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL HELP AND ENSURE THAT
WE KNOW WHAT THAT THE RESULTS
OF SPENDING IN THE THESE FUNDS
ARE AND CAN HOPEFULLY INFORM
FUTURE DECISION MAKING ON THE
PART OF THE LEGISLATURE. THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
MR CARSON LET'S A LET'S HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES- SECRETARY CROWFOOT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WHAT
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL. FOR IT SO MUCH
SENATOR WILL LISTEN FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP IN PASSING THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE. I CAN REPORT
THAT THANKS TO THAT ACTION AND
STATE DEPARTMENTS ARE
PURCHASING EQUIPMENT. I IN REAL
TIME CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO
SURGE UP ON PROJECTS AND WE'RE
GETTING A FUNDING OUT TO
GRANTEES IN REAL TIME. SO BIG
THANKS- WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THAT EARLY ACTION PACKAGE AND
ALL THE PROPOSALS HERE TODAY. I
THINK THERE IS BROAD ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SENATE ON THIS WILDFIRE
APPROACH CLEARLY WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THERE NEEDS TO BE A
QUANTUM LEAP. OF INVESTMENT.
INTO UP FRONT PROACTIVE ACTIONS
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE WE TALK
ABOUT REALLY THREE CONCENTRIC
CIRCLES. INVESTMENTS WITHIN
COMMUNITIES ON HARDENING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. PLANNING
AROUND COMMUNITIES ARE WITH
THESE EMBLEMATIC. OP ARE
MERGING SEA PRODUCTIVE FUEL
BREAKS AND ACROSS LANDSCAPES WE
USED TO CALL US FOREST
MANAGEMENT BUT THAT'S A
MISNOMER THIS IS LAY.
MANAGEMENT RECOGNIZING THAT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA OUR.
COMMUNITIES I HAVE DIFFERENT
LANDS IT'S OUR THEM WHETHER
THAT'S- OR- OAK WOODLAND ARE
KIND OF FOR. THIS BUDGET FOR
THE FOR TIME- REAL CONSCIOUSLY
AVOID A ONE FITS ALSO FROM SAN.
REALLY IDENTIFY THAT ARE
REGIONAL. AND WHILE. CHALLENGES
AND THEIR WHILE BY SAFETY.
REALLY PROUD THAT OUR BUDGET IN
IN THE DEBATE OF REGIONAL
PRIORITIES- THAT WILL FOCUS
MOST IMPORTANTLY ON PROTECTING
THE COMMUNITIES FROM THE UNIQUE
THREATS IN EACH REGION. I AND
SO WE FIND THE OUTSIDE
INVESTMENT INTO THAT THOSE
REGIONAL PRIORITY SETTING AND
THEN OUR GOAL WITH THIS WAS
BUDGET IS TO OVER TIME OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS ACTUALLY IN
BASK. IN THE PIPELINE OF
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS DOES NOT
START AGAIN STOP AGAIN- ALSO
MENTIONED THAT WE MAKE WE CAN
IN SOUND INSTITUTIONAL TO
GETTING MORE DONE INCLUDING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GETTING
MORE TRAIN FOLKS ACTUALLY OUT
THERE TO DO THE WORK SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS. WE CAN MOBILIZE
SMALL BUSINESSES ACROSS OUR
MORE RURAL AREAS TO ACTUALLY DO
MORE OF THIS WORK AND THEN
CRITICALLY REGULATORY
EFFICIENCY FRANKLY HISTORICALLY
IT'S BEEN TOO HARD TO DO THE
WORK WE NEED TO ACROSS
LANDSCAPE AND GROWTH SO.
THROUGH EFFICIENCIES LIKE THIS
OUR VEGETATION TREATMENT
PROGRAM PROGRAMMATIC E. IR
WE'RE CREATING ESSENTIALLY- I
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
APPROVAL OF THE LANDSCAPE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS WHAT USED
TO TAKE YEARS WELL. NOW TAKE
MONTHS. SO BETTER REALLY- WITH
YOU KNOW YOUR LEADER IN ALL THE
ON THE- AND GLAD TO. I'M YOU
AND QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
A MENTOR HUGE. REPORTER HIS
TEAM CAL BY. THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY
THE CORNERS OF THIS. THIS IS
TRUE A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
THOUGH INCLUDE I HAD TO. ACROSS
OUR AGENCY AND ACROSS OTHER AGE
AS SO MY JESSICA MORE HERE TO
ANSWER SPECIFIC AS- I GUESS ONE
OF THE THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE SOME PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY YOU SEE
THAT THERE'S MONEY IN THERE
FOR. SUBSIDIZING TRANSPORTATION
BECAUSE THERE'S ADDITIONAL
MONEY IN THERE FOR PLANTING
TREES IT IS ONE THING TO HAVE
IN THEIR THREE CREEK TO TREES.
AND GET THE TREES IN IN THE
GROUNDS WORK WHERE THEY'RE
NEEDED- I GUESS SAID DEPUTY
MOSS FOR MORRIS. OF THAT THE WE
DON'T KNOW IF THOSE TO THE
RIGHT NUMBERS BUT WE'D LIKE TO
HAVE YOUR INPUT ON THAT AND
ATTENTION AS YOU GUYS GO
THROUGH YOU'RE- A REVISION YOU
TALK TO THE FINANCE DOWNSTAIRS.
ON IF THAT'S THE RIGHT NUMBER
AGAIN THIS IS A FIVE YEAR
PROGRAM SO. THE ATTENTION TO
MORE TREE PLANTING MORE MARIE.
OF WHAT PRODUCTS FROM THE
FOREST FLOOR TO GET TO THESE
BIOMASS FACILITIES WOULD BE
IMPORTANT. YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD. DEPUTY WELL LET ME JUST
SAY FOR PHILOSOPHICALLY I IT
TURNED OVER JUST MOMENT THE
PHILOSOPHE WE ARE. THAT WE NEED
TO. LEVERAGE MORE PRIVATE AND
BASS. IN EAGLE I BASE.
LANDSCAPE RAJ. SIMPLY PUT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BE AT THE
STATE OR THE FEDERAL WON'T BE
SUFFICIENT TO ACTUALLY DO THE
AMOUNT OF. ENVIRONMENTALLY
BASED- LANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT
THAT WE NEED TO DO SO. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED OBVIOUSLY PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU ALL HAVE. IDENTIFIED
ADDITION PROPOSED- BUT PROBABLY
I SPEAKING I THINK WORKFORCE.
ALIGNED JUST GOT. ABSOLUTELY
AND SAM WE ARE REALLY EXCITED
TO SEE THAT PROPOSAL WE PUT
FORWARD I'M MOVING FORWARD AND
WITH WHAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF-
CONSENSUS AND CLARITY AND
SPECIFICALLY ON THE QUESTION OF
HOW DO WE REALLY ON LEVERAGE
BUSINESS AND CAN USE THIS
INVESTMENT. TO NOT ONLY HELP
JUMPSTART CATALYZED MORE
BUSINESSES IN THIS SECTOR
PARTICULARLY IN MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVEN'T HAD
MANY OPPORTUNITIES- BUT THEN
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT AT LEAST
IS BECOMES A SUSTAINABLE
OPERATION AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE AREAS. THAT WE PROPOSED IN
THE STRATEGY IN THAT- IS GOING
FORWARD IN THE BUDGET WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE CLIMATE CATALYST
WHICH IS CREATING SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS TO HELP AND UP
SMALL BUSINESSES WHETHER IT'S
IN THE WOOD INNOVATION SECTOR
SO. IN THE ANNUAL OF THIS
BIOMASS OR IN THE TRADITION
SACK WHERE YOU'RE AT- MICRO
THAT GO THE BACK OF PICKUP
TRUCKS THAT. SMALLER WOULD
COMING OUT OF THE IS SHIP- AND
TO WIN BUT INSTEAD HAS NOT. TO
BE MAILED IN LUMBER AND CREATE
JOBS THAT'S ALSO WHY WE'RE NOT
IN THE WERE FORCE YOU ASPECTS
OF THIS PROGRAM LIGHT
ADVANCEMENT IN. COLLEGES HELP
TRAINER FOR THIS AND INVEST TO
GROW LIKE CHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
A PARTNERSHIP EACH SIERRA
COUNTY- CALAVERAS COUNTY AND-
AND EIGHT TRIBES IN THE AREA
THAT WILL HELP THAT TRAINED
THEM IN BECOMING BUT WORK CREWS
SHOW THAT THE WORK IN
INVESTMENT WE'RE PUTTING ON THE
LANDSCAPE. IS ACTION WORSE IN A
LONG TERM AREN'T RELIABLE
EFFORTS AND ONE ASPECT I WANT
TO POINT OUT IN OUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WENT FORWARD IS
WE REQUESTED LONGER. HER ON
THESE DOLLARS FOR THEM TO BE AN
EXPANDED- OVER ABOUT YEAR
PERIOD IN THE FROM IS SO THE
WOULD BE BY CAN LARGER CRY. AND
THEN THE COMMUNITY CAN OR. YES
WE DID HEAR THEM ON THAT ONE
BECAUSE THE FIVE YEAR PLAN
INCREASES THAT YOU KNOW
CONTINUED FUNDING THAT'S GOING
TO GO ON AND MORE TIME TO SPEND
THAT BEFORE I GET TO CHIEF-
PORTER CAN YOU COMMENT QUICKLY
ON THE MONIES THAT'S- DIRECTED
TO THE PARK AND RECREATION
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM AND FISH
AND WILDLIFE WHAT. A SECRETARY
CROWFOOT WHAT THIS MIGHT MEAN
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF
INVESTMENT FOR OF RESILIENT
WILDLAND SAID THOSE TWO
AGENCIES INTO THE STATE'S
SYSTEM. YEAH WE HAVE TO WALK
THE WALK WITH STATE LANDS AND
PARKS AND FISH AND WILDLIFE.
STEWARDS SOME OF OUR MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE LANDS
IN THE STATE. AND HISTORICALLY
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN THE
INVESTMENTS IN PROACTIVE YOU
KNOW. LANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT
RESILIENCE MEASURES. SO THIS IS
A HUGE INVESTMENT AND
PROTECTING BEES BE SENSITIVE
LANDSCAPES. ARE STATE PARKS
IMPRESSION WILDLIFE ARE ARE
READY TO DO THE WORK AND AS I
MENTIONED BECAUSE THEY'VE
RECEIVED SOME FUNDING IN THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY OUT THERE I GETTING
THE EQUIPMENT AND AS JESSICA
MENTIONED YOU KNOW THAT THE
LENGTH OF OUR PROPOSED
INVESTMENT. WILL ALLOW ACTUALLY
THE PROJECTS THERE YOU KNOW
CONTINUE AND HAS TO WORK
THROUGH THESE PIPELINES OF
PROJECTS. BECAUSE STATE PARKS
IN ECOLOGICAL PRESERVES OUR
NEXT TO PRIVATE LANDS THIS ALSO
DOES A BETTER JOB OF PROTECTING
THOSE PRIVATE LANDS AND NEARBY
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRE. VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHT DOES. DIRECTOR
PORTER WITH CALIFORNICA I THINK
YOU'RE HERE THANK YOU HERE GOOD
MORNING ANYTHING IN THIS FIVE
YEAR SENATE PACKAGE THAT YOU
LIKE THAT YOU LIKE TO COMMENT
ON. WELL YOU GOOD MORNING-
SHARE Y. CASKEY AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- WHAT I'D SAY
ABOUT- OUR OUR- THE BUDGET THAT
IS PROPOSED IS THAT IT REALLY
IS A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR SEVERAL YEARS- AND
THAT TRULY IS- THAT WE NEED A-
HOLISTIC SOLUTION- WE NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT LANDSCAPE
RESILIENCE- WE NEED TO BE%
LOOKING AT FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECT WORK IN BETWEEN. AND
LOOKING AT- DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AND HOME HARDENING IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THOSE HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES AND WE FEEL THAT
OUR- EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS-
THAT WE'VE BEEN FEEDING AND- SB
NINE NO ONE HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN INCREASING THE PACE
AND SCALE- THAT THOSE EFFORTS
HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
TO MOVING US FORWARD AS A
STATE- THE THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS- THAT CAME OUT OF THE
FORTY FIVE DAY REPORT- TO THE
GOVERNOR IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ALL OF THOSE PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED ALL OF
THEM. I HAVE. IN THOSE
PROGRAMS- AND CONTINUING OUR
EFFORTS TO DO A FIRE PREVENTION
AND INCREASE OUR NEED IS THAT
THE- DEMONSTRATED NEEDFOR MORE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT TYPE OF
WORK AND TOO RESPONSE TO
WILDFIRES AS THEY OCCUR. A DRUG
TO PORTER I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
NEGOTIATION BETWEEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE GOVERNMENT
TO- TREAT OR TO PAY ATTENTION
TO A MILLION ACRES IN THE
FOREST LAND IN AND GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY PROPOSAL LOOK FOR ONE
BILLION DOLLARS SAID WEPRESUME
TO ACHIEVE THAT SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THIS WAS. WAS THE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT FROM THE
JANUARY BUDGET WAS THAT ENOUGH
TO TREAT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ACRES WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA PORTION IF THIS WERE
TO PASS AND THERE WAS ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IS THAT GIVE US
SOME ADDITIONAL THE OR CAN YOU
TELL US HOW WE HOW THAT'S GOING
TO TREAT THE GOAL OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES AND
THEN. NATURALLY BEGS THE
QUESTION HOW OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS DOING- WE LIKE TO
THINK THAT THIS IS A SIGNAL TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THAT
TOO THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
AND THIS LEGISLATURE SERIOUS
ABOUT ATTACKING THIS AND WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THEM PUT SOME MONEY
ON THE TABLE ALSO SO IF YOU
COULD ADD. THAT ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS. D. FOR YOU OKAY OKAY
IF I JUST SOME LEVEL- BRING UP.
SO AS YOU KNOW CENTER THE
GOVERNOR WITH THE U. S. FOREST
SERVICE CHIEF LAST SUMMER
SIGNED THIS SHARED STEWARDSHIP
AGREEMENT COMMITTING EACH THE
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES PER YEAR. OUR PROPOSED
BUDGET FROM JANUARY WOULD
ACHIEVE THAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES ALL WE THINK A
YEAR OR TWO EARLY SO WE WOULD
BE MEETING OUR OUR- COMMITMENT.
IT'S VERY CLEAR TO US AND WE
MADE IT CLEAR PUBLICLY AND
PRIVATELY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO INCREASE
ITS INVESTMENT INTO ITS
REGIONAL AGENCIES MEET THEIR
COMMITMENT. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
HAD CONSTRUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DIRECTLY AND WE'VE HAD. GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA DELEGATION SO. I
REMAIN HOPEFUL ACTUALLY WILL
SEE. A COMPARABLE INCREASE IN
INVESTMENT ARE SIGNIFICANT
SIZEABLE INCREASE OF INVESTMENT
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY ARE ON THE
HOOK WITH THAT COMMITMENT FOR
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES-
DRIVEN BY THE FEDERAL AGENCIES.
I'M SO LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
ULTIMATELY THE FEDERAL BUDGET
THAT COMES OUT AND. PROVIDING
THE CAPACITY FOR THEM TO DO
THAT. OUR CHIEF ANYTHING YOU
WANT ADD THEIR- NO SECRETARY
GROWTH WHAT YOU YOU HIT IT
RIGHT ON- THIS INITIAL
INVESTMENT WILL GET US- TO THAT
NUMBER SOONER THAN WE WOULD
HAVE WITHOUT IT. EXCELLENT
PROBLEM IN THESE THERE'S A OF A
MIX CHIEF WITH THEM THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT'S GOING DIRECTLY
TO CAL FIRE IN THE GRANT
PROGRAM YOU RENT AND OUR
PARTNERS IN THE CONSERVANCY
THAT ARE DOING WORKING CAN YOU.
ENLIGHTEN US OF HOW THE
CONSERVANCY'S AND CAL FIRE WORK
TOGETHER. ON THE SAND ON THE
PROPOSAL OR- HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE
WORKING TOGETHER BETTER. OTHER
POLLS OUT. IT CHAIR I WILL A
REFERENCE ONLY THE CAL FIRE
PIECE OF THAT- WE ARE
COORDINATED WE DO HAVE A
REGULAR MEETINGS AND- AND TALK
ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THERE AREN'T AND
THERE ISN'T- UNNECESSARY
OVERLAP BUT THERE IS
COORDINATION AND- SO THAT IS-
VERY WELL TUNED PROCESS WHAT-
IS IMPORTANT I THINK TO
RECOGNIZE IS THAT THESE GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE OVERSEE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND WE ARE ABLE
TO- OF FUND THE PROJECTS AND
GET THEM ON THE GROUND AND
HOUSE FOR THE NEXT ROUND CYCLE
WHEN IT COMES OR BE ABLE TO
SHIFT BETWEEN ARE DIFFERENT-
CONSERVANCY'S OR IT OR
DEPARTMENTS- APPLICATIONS THAT.
THAT MEET THAT. NEEDS TO WHERE
THE MONEY IS. WE JUST. I WOULD
JUST THAT THE TEMPERATURE STATE
CONSERVE IS WE HAVE A
REMARKABLE TOOLS ACTUALLY NEED
A WILDFIRE RESILIENCE BALLS
THANKS HERE IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY FOR EXAMPLE THAT
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED REGIONAL
PRIORITIZED- PROJECTS THAT
THINK AND HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING OUR CONSERVANCY THEN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LIKE WHY
SAN DIEGO RIVERS CONSERVANCY
FOR EXAMPLE IS TAKING THIS
EARLY ACTION FUNDING PLUGGING
IT DIRECTLY INTO PROJECTS THAT
DEVELOP. SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THE INVESTMENT IN CONSERVANCIES
ARE CERTAINLY COMPLIMENTARY TO
CAL FIRE- BOTH CAL FIRE IN THE
CONSERVANCIES ARE GONNA BE IN
THE SAME ROOM DEVELOPING THESE
REGIONAL PRIORITIES- WITH THEIR
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
WITH THE COUNTY AND WITH THE
CITY- SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WHERE DOES BRINGING- YOU KNOW
MORE MORE TOOLS TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BY GOD BY RESOURCING
CONSERVANCY THAT ONLY HOPE THAT
THE MONEY THAT THE OPR HAS ON
THE WILDFIRE ADAPTATION PLANS
AND CLIMATE AT A- ADJUSTMENTS
THIS COLLABORATIVE CENTER IN
THERE ARE ALL EVERYBODY'S IN
THE ROOM AND WE CAN WE CAN SAY
OKAY THIS IS WHERE THEY- A CUTE
FIRE DANGER IS. THIS IS A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
YOUR OWN MONEY AND THAT HOW
THOSE THINGS CAN GET PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON THE
PROJECTS. AS SOON AS POSSIBLE-
LET'S FINANCED FIT FOR I GET
THE MEMBERS MEMBERS. HAVE
QUESTIONS. YOU HAVE. ANYTHING
TO SAY ABOUT THIS. LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL. MORNING HERE IN IN
MEMBERS AND STEVEN BENSON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YEAH
SO WE'RE AT WORK WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING REVIEWING THE
PROPOSAL THE AND WE IGNORE ALL
IS THAT IT INCLUDES NEARLY
EVERYTHING THAT WAS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR. AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT WE WERE
WORKING ON THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
APPROACH IT'S OBVIOUSLY HELPFUL
AFTER CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
AND- FOR REVIEWING IT-
OBVIOUSLY WILL BE A MUCH BETTER
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO- TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS WORKS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION ONCE
THE MAYOR VERSIONS RELEASED SO
WILL CONTINUE TO REVIEW THIS AS
WERE AS WERE GETTING THEIR
VISION BUTTONED UP IN AND OUT
AND THEN LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH EARLY.
ACTION AND- IS THAT GOING THAT-
THE COMMENTARY MADE TODAY. THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE WE THINK
IT'S REALLY. A IN THE FIRST.
AND WE THINK IT IT REALLY HELPS
TO GET SOME THINGS GOING RIGHT
AWAY AND- AND JUST LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WE HAD
AS WE WORKED OUT THAT PACKAGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
BENSON WE WILL FEEL NO. ILFC
TOWARDS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OF THE MAY REVISE ACTUALLY
EXCEEDS. WHAT THE SENATE IS
LAID OUT TODAY IF YOU. ARE SO
BOLD DOWNSTAIRS IS TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN. LITTLE
SUB TO IN THE SENATE THAT WOULD
BE OKAY WITH US- OKAY LET'S-
LET'S TURN TO VICE YOU'RE
DALITS ARE WITH SOME QUESTIONS.
WELL I WANTED TO GIVE SENATE
MCGUIRE CHANCE IF HE WANTED TO
JUMP IN ARE YOU SURE GO HEAD
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO I WANT TO
START FIRST. FIRST I WANT TO
SAY- THIS IS EXCITING TIME I
THINK FOR CALIFORNIA TO FIRST
OF ALL BE TALKING IN THE TERMS
THAT WERE AT LEAST TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT I'VE LONG
FOR A LONG TIME SO I WANT TO
THANK THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY IN. AND THOSE FOLKS WHO
WERE WHO ARE. CHALLENGED WITH
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO. PUT
THESE PROJECTS ON THE GROUND SO
I JUST HAD A QUESTION I KNOW
THAT OUR TARGET WAS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES. AND
WHAT WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO MEET
THAT GOAL- FINANCIAL WISE
THAT'S I THINK SOMETHING THAT.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE ANSWERED IF
YOU HAVE THAT THAT THE
INFORMATION. YEAH JESSICA
YOU'RE PROBABLY BEST TO
CALCULATE THOSE IN YOUR HAD.
AND WE SAID THAT YOU KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BUDGET BEING
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT BY ONE
THOUSAND ACRE GOLF YOU KNOW A
YEAR OR TWO EARLY BUT I THINK
WITH THE SENATORS ASKING FOR IS
LIKE WHAT'S THE MONEY BUT THE
RESOURCES NEEDED FOR THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES. YEAH IF
YOU AVERAGE IT OUT IT COSTS
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AN
ACRE- SOME MAKERS ARE CHEAPER
SOME MAKERS YOU KNOW ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE AT FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AN ACRE BUT ON AVERAGE
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AN
ACRE- SO. YOU KIND OF DO THE
MATH ON THAT FRONT- BUT ONE OF
THE BE YOUR CONSTRAINTS. IS BUT
YOU CAN'T JUST PUT MONEY. AT
THE PROBLEM AND SAY HERE'S-
HERE'S THAT AMOUNT PLEASE GO
AND STAND AND DELIVER THE
SPEAKERS YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS.
THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES WHICH IS
WHAT'S SO EXCITING ABOUT THIS
BUDGET THAT IT ADDRESSES SOME
OF THE UNDERLYING ISSUES. THAT
HAVE BEEN SLOWING HER PACE SUCH
AS- INCREASING THE WORKFORCE.
PUTTING MORE EQUIPMENT ON THE
LANDSCAPE TO GET THIS WORK
DONE. HAVING MORE- PARTNERSHIPS
AND COLLABORATIVE. I'M AT THE
TABLE TO START EXECUTING THIS-
AND- I AND SO THAT IS WHAT'S
GOING TO BE INCREASING. OUR
PACE IN ADDITION. TO THE DIRECT
RESOURCES. TO ACTUALLY GET
THESE PROJECTS DONE. OKAY THE
YOU- SO. WANTED TO JUST STATE I
THOUGHT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WAS SUPPOSED TO
CONDUCT ASSESSMENT HAVE THEY
HAVE A- HAVE THEY DONE THAT.
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND- SPECIFIC
PROJECT THE TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE REQUESTED FOR
THEM TO ASSESS THEIR OWN LAND
YES HAS THAT BEEN IS I'VE BEEN
COMPLETED AND I BELIEVE THAT'S
UNDER WAY WE CAN GET BACK TO
YOU WITH MORE INFORMATION ON
THE STATUS OF THAT PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU- SO THE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO JUST SHARES
THAT I DON'T KNOW. THAT I
SERVED ON THIS YEAR ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY FOR. SEVEN YEARS.
AND I THINK THE CONSERVANCIES
ARE A GREAT PLACE- TO SEND
RESOURCES QUITE FRANKLY THEY-
THEY PARTNER- AT LEAST THE
SIERRA. CONSERVANCY WHICH I
SAID ON ON. DON'T KNOW WHAT
EXACTLY OTHER WITH THE OTHER
STRUCTURES OF THE OTHER ONES
ARE BUT- AND THAT. THEY HAD IN
IN ON THE CONCERT IN THE SIERRA
NEVADA CONSERVANCY THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER- AND
THEY DO A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
THE ACTUALLY GETTING PROJECTS
ON THE GROUND AROUND COMMITTEE.
COMMUNITIES AND THEY WORK WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEY DO
THEY THEY- HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PARTNER THEIR GRANDSONS ERIC
EXTEND THE MONIES AND- IN A
VERY BROAD WAY TO BRING IN LIKE
A QUICK DOLLARS. THEY WORK WITH
THE R. C. D.'S IN THE AND THE
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS I KNOW THAT-
DURING THE BUDGET HEARING- ON
THE EARLY ACTION STUFF SENATOR
THERE TO ASK THE QUESTION.
ABOUT WHAT THE PERCENTAGE WAS
SO I'M ASSUMING THAT WILL COME
LATER I'M NOT ACTUALLY ASKING
THAT QUESTION BUT I JUST WOULD
SAY THAT. FOR ME. A PRIORITY
TO. UP THE AMOUNT TO- THE
CONSERVANCY'S- I THINK THEY I
THINK IT'S A GOOD DEA I THINK
AND I WANT TO SHARE THAT- THE
NIGHT THE- I THINK THAT CAN.
YOU KNOW HOW FAR IS- THERE
FIGHTING FIRES. THE END AND
THEY BEEN CONSUMED WITH FIRE
THE LAST. COUPLE YEARS AND TO
GET THOSE TWO TO GET THE WORK
THAT WE NEED TO GET DONE AND
AMOUNT ACRES WE NEED TO TREAT-
IS A- TALL TASK. AND TO HAVE A
NOT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO O
THOSE. ON THE GROUND PROJECTS
IS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT. SO I
DID WANT TO ASK I DID SEE A MAP
AND I DID SEE SOME NUMBERS
ABOUT. HOW YOU CALCULATE. THE
AMOUNT OF ACRES THAT ARE
TREATED AND- I DON'T KNOW WHO
WOULD ANSWER THIS MAYBE-
SECRETARY VELCRO FOOTER OR ONE
THE OTHERS- SO I SAW THE MAP
WHERE THEY WERE COUNTING. THE
TIMBER HARVEST TEACH PEATLANDS
IN TREATED ACRES- AND THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE PROJECTS THAT- TO MY
KNOWLEDGE DON'T COST US
ANYTHING THEY'RE ACTUALLY.
MONEY GENERATORS FROM BECAUSE
THEY'RE PRIVATE PEOPLE DOING.
FOR ST- MAINLY ON THEIR PRIVATE
LANDS- SO CAN THAT CANNOT BE
ADDRESSED IS THAT COUNTED IN
THE EQUATION OR NOT BECAUSE IF
IT IS A WE NEED TO. MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE- DOING ACCOUNTING TO
MAKE SURE HOW MUCH MONEY IS
BEING SPENT WHERE- AND I THINK
IT'S JUST DUE TO THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TO KNOW. HOW MUCH WE'RE
ACTUALLY TREATING. OVER AND
ABOVE. WHAT. IT WOULD NORMALLY
BE TREATED UNDER T. H. P. YEAH
SO OUR HIGH IN JUST CAN FILL IN
AND- CORRECT BUT- SHORT OF IT
IS THAT YEAH COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITY THAT'S- YOU KNOW BASED
ON ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS
THAT. IN THE FORRESTER ON
LANDSCAPES DOES COUNT FOR.
WORKFORCE OR LANDSCAPE
MANAGEMENT- AND WE THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WE SAID
YOU KNOW TAXPAYER FUNDED-
INVESTMENTS ARE ARE ONE
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF LANDSCAPE
MANAGEMENT BUT MARSHALL
ACTIVITY. IS AS WELL. SO TODAY
THAT HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
ACREAGE THAT WE FIND. AND I
THINK WE COULD RECOGNIZE OUR
THAT SECTOR IN ACTUALLY HELPING
BUILD OUR WILDFIRE RESILIENCE-
SO DIRECTLY INTO YOUR QUESTION
I BELIEVE IT IS. JESSICA IN OUT
OF THERE. HE MIGHT A LITTLE
HISTORY- AND WHERE THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE NUMBER
COMES FROM THAT COMES FROM THE
FOREST CARBON PLANTS. AND SO
THE WHICH WAS A COLLABORATIVE
REPORT DONE BY SCIENTISTS AND-
AND EXPERTS. AYE IDENTIFYING
WHAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF LAND
OWNERSHIP WORST RECEIVED IS A
HEALTHY FOREST YOU THE
ESTIMATED THERE'S ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION ACRES IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE IN NEED AT THAT. OUT
OF THE THIRTY MILLION ACRES OF
FOREST LAND IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
FIFTEEN MILLION ACRES WERE
NEEDED INTERVENTION. AND AND SO
THE BASS LINE IN THAT TARGET A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES.
ASSUMES IT BUILDS INTO IT ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES- OF
PRIVATE. WE IT TREATED
LANDSCAPES- INCLUDING TIMBER
HARVEST. I AND I AND THEN THE
REMAINDER IS ON THE STATE AND
WE'VE SEEN THE STATE PORTION
AND- REALLY INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY- AND THIS BUDGET
WILL HELP US. REALLY DELIVER
THOSE TARGETS PART OF THE
REASON YOU HAVE. BOTH TIMBER
HARVEST AND VEGETATION
TREATMENT WITH AND IDENTIFIED
BY THAT TARGET IN THE FOREST
CARBON PLANT IS BECAUSE. THAT'S
HOW THE FOR SERVICE DOES THEIR
ACCOUNTING AS WELL- SO IT'S IT
HELPS KEEP PARITY. UNDER AND
COMPARE. WHAT GETTING TREATED
AT WHERE- AND SO I CAN DO TO
CHEAT ORDER TO MAY HAVE.
ADDITIONAL INSIGHTS ON THIS
BEING OUR STATE FORESTER CAN BE
ABLE TO OFFER SOME INSIGHTS
INTO HOW THIS ALL WORKS. CHIEF
THANK YOU JESSICA- STAND
SENATOR DOLLY DOLLY FOR YOUR
QUESTION WHAT I THE ONLY THING
THAT I WANTED TO ADD IS THAT.
COMMERCIAL TIMBER OPERATIONS ON
PRIVATE LAND ARE NOT FUNDED IN
ANY WAY BY ANY OF THESE
DOLLARS. THAT IS WHOLLY
SEPARATE HOWEVER AS US
SECRETARY CHROMEBOOK MENTIONED
THEY ARE APPROPRIATELY
ACCOUNTED FOR AS PLAN
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITY AND TO THE
FORCE PRACTICE RULES UNDER THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION AND- REGULATED BY
US- AS THE INSPECTION AGENCY-
WE DO INSURE THAT THOSE FOREST
MANAGEMENT PLAN I MEAN THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLANS MEET- THE
FUEL REDUCTION. COMPONENT FOR
THE AREA THAT THERE AND SO
IT'S- AND ALL A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH BUT THAT IS WHERE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY AND PRIVATE-
ECONOMICS ARE ACTUALLY DRIVING
SOME OF THE GOOD WORK IN THE
FUEL REDUCTION AND FOREST
RESILIENCE. SPACE I THANK YOU
FOR THOSE THE QUESTION THAT'S
IT'S I THINK IT'S A PROPERTIES%
WELL I'M NOT I'M NOT
DISAGREEING WITH YOU BUT I. DO
WANT TO SAY THAT. WE TALK ABOUT.
THE ROOM THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S BEING SPENT IF YOU'RE
COUNTING IF YOU CAN'T PUT IT
ALL IN ONE POT THE ACREAGES IN
ONE POT I SHOULD SAY. AND HALF
OF THAT OR THREE THOUSAND ACRES
THAT IS BEEN TREATED BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHICH IS GOOD.
WE NEED TO DO THAT. AND THEN
YOU LOOK AT THE SIDE THAT THE
PUBLIC SECTOR ACTUALLY SPENT
MONEY ON WHICH WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. THE COST PER ACRE
GOES WAY UP BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
PAY ANYTHING FOR THE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. MY GOAL IS
BUT- I'M NOT OPPOSED TO
SPENDING THE MONEY I WILL I
THINK PRIVATE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
DOING I THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
HELPING OUT I THINK WE SHOULD
BE AND WE ARE. THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT. BUT WE NEED TO CATCH
ACT WE NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS OUT
THERE. AND I THINK TO A MAN I
KNOW THE PRIVATE SIDE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A PRODUCT
THAT COMES OUT OF THE- IN IN
MANY CASES NOT NOT IN SENATORS
TURNS DISTRICT WHERE YOU HAVE
CHAPARRAL AND THAT'S A 100%
COST AND- AND I THINK. MISS
MORRIS. STATED IT PERFECTLY
THAT SOME ACRES ARE REALLY HIGH
TO. TREAT AND SUMMER LOW- AND
SO IT BUT THE BALANCE IS BUT
WE- BUT ONE MORE COUNTY DOING
ACCOUNTING. WE NEEDED DIVIDE
OUT WHAT IT'S REALLY COSTS AND
FOR THE PUBLIC- BECAUSE- A FEW
YEARS AGO WE PASSED. A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION HERE THAT ALLOWED.
CAL FIRE TO HELP. PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS. DO CONTROLLED BURNS.
AND SO LAST FALL ACTUALLY WENT
IN TO THE LOCAL CAL FIRE-
OFFICE AND IN BEAVER. AND I'VE
WANTED TO DO WANTED TO BURN
BECAUSE WE HAD A WINDOW AND
THAT YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF
PAPERWORK THAT I HAD TO GO
THROUGH TO BE ABLE TO DO A
BURN. IN THE TIME FRAME THAT I
NEEDED TO DO IT AS HORRENDOUS
FOR A SMALL. THE LANDOWNER AS
MYSELF AND SO WHAT WHY SAY THAT
IS THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
ABILITY BE ABLE TO HELP THE-
THE PRIVATE LANDOWNERS WHO
DON'T HAVE A COMMODITY. THAT
ACTUALLY OFFSET THE COST AND WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE
THE REGULATORY PROCESSES FOR
THOSE LANDOWNERS THEY CAN'T
THAT THAT ARE TRYING TO DO A T.
H. P. TO DO THE GOOD WORK THAT
THEY NEED TO DO- AND THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO DRIVE THE COST DOWN AND
TREAT MORE ACRES. SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ACTION OR
STANDS WHAT OF WHAT OCCURS WERE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE IF YOU
THROW MON OF THE SAME POT. SOME
OF THOSE ACRES THE TAXPAYER.
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP
TREAT THOSE ACRES AND SOME
MAKERS THEY DID AND AMOUNTS AND
THE COST. IS HUGE IT'S A IT'S A
HIGH DOLLAR COMPARED TO WHAT-
IT HAPPENED ON THE PRIVATE SIDE
SO I JUST WANT TO DRAW THAT
DISTINCTION I WANTED TO ADD ONE
MORE THING MISTER JOURNAL BE
QUIET- ON THE TRANSPORTATION I
KNOW THAT THE CHAIR. REACHED
OUT TO ME ABOUT THAT THE
HELPING THE TRANSFERRED THE
BIOMASS TRANSPORTATION AND I
JUST WANT TO I THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA I THINK WE'VE DONE
THIS IN THE PAST WE'VE TRIED TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO. TO- HELP.
THE TRANSPORTATION COST OF
BIOMASS WE CAN ACTUALLY GET IT
TO A- RENEWABLE SOURCE- BUT HOW
IT WORKS NEEDS TO BE. THE
DETAILS OF HOW THAT WORKS-
THERE WAS. BECAUSE I'M IN THE
FORESTED AREAS AND I KNOW. THE
CONTRACTORS IN THE PEOPLE THAT
USE THESE PROGRAMS. THAT THE
SYSTEM WAS GAINED AND I DON'T
WANT THAT I WANT MORE ACRES
TREATED. IS THE GOAL IF THE
PUBLIC IS GONNA BE PUTTING
RESOURCES IN IT I DON'T WANT
THEIR ABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
BE. THAT IT. TO BE GAINED AND
IT WAS SO LET ME GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. IF YOU'RE GONNA GIVE.
FIRST OF ALL IN DIVORCE AFTER
WEEK TALK IN BONE DRY TIMES WE
DON'T TALK AND GREEN TOWN SO
WHEN YOU HALL IN A LOAD TO A
BIOMASS FACILITY. IT'S GOT SO
MUCH MOISTURE IN IT THAN A LOT
OF THAT IS THEY THEY DRY IT AND
THEY- FIGURE OUT. HOW MUCH THE
WAY IT IS IN A BONE DRY TIME SO
WE SHOULD BE TALKING IN BONE
DRY TIMES NUMBER ONE. AND THE
SUBSIDY SHOULD BE BASED ON
MILES AWAY FROM THE PLANT. THE
CLOSEST PLANT. BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS. CONTRACTORS FOR THE
PLANTS. GET THE SUBSIDY. AND
THERE ARE HAULING IT RIGHT BY
ONE PLAN TO GO TO ANOTHER PLANT
THAT'S FURTHER. WHICH MAKES IT
WHICH DOESN'T DO THE PUBLIC ANY
GOOD WORK TRYING TO GET BIOMASS
TO THE PLANT. THE CLOSEST
PLANTS WE CAN TREAT MORE ACRES
WITH THAT. WITHOUT SUBSIDY SO I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO- HELP PUT
LANGUAGE IN THERE AT SOME POINT
THAT EXPLAINS LIKE A IT WAS
OVER THIRTY MILES IT'S- SO MANY
DOLLARS A BONE DRY TIENEN NEED
TO GO TO THE PLANT AND THEY
NEED TO BE THE ONES THAT. ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT BACK. TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW THAT LOOKS
SO I JUST WANT TO THROW THAT
OUT BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE. I
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA IF YOU
IF YOU WERE ABLE TO PUT FIVE
DOLLARS. A BONE DRY TIME. AT A
HALF ME AS AS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TONS IT'S GONNA GET.
COME OFF OF OUR FORCES LOT
AWESOME- SO I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT I KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR. TALK TO ME ABOUT IT ON
SATURDAY AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY. THE WEEK WE CAN SET IT UP
IN A GREAT WAY TO WHERE WE CAN
GET MORE DONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR DOLLARS AND- I
WANT TO THANK THE AGENCIES. AND
THEIR STAFF- FOR BEANIE ON
TODAY. I KNOW FINANCES
LISTENING EVERYTHING WAS SAID.
I WILL BE RIGHT ON IT- LET'S GO
TO CENTER STERN. HIS HAS HAD
HIS HAND UP AND- I HAVE. NOT
NOTICED SAID ANIMAL GO TO
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANKS MISTER
CHAIR- ME DROP MY HAND DOWN
HERE OKAY GREAT YEAH MY COMING
THROUGH OKAY. PERFECT ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FIRST STEPPING UP YET
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR- WATER NOW
FIRE- NOT. NOT WAITING IN A
CRISIS BUT LEADING I THINK THE
SENATE'S BEEN REMARKABLY BOLD
HERE AND INITIATING THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND TAKING YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP
CHARGE ANY BROUGHT OUT IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET EARLIER THIS
YEAR SO I JUST ON THE WHOLE I
WANT TO APPLAUD YOUR WORK IN
BEING AGGRESSIVE IN INITIATING
HERE AND TO THE ADMINISTRATION
TO- IN. INVOLVING OUR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE STRATEGY AND LOOKING
SAID THE DIVERSITY OF THE STATE
AND BECAUSE OF THESE FIRES AND-
AND REALLY DIGGING DEEP HERE SO
I SENSE IN THE RHETORIC THE
CATEGORIES THE WAY IT IS ALL
STRUCTURED AS A REAL EVOLUTION
IN OUR THINKING EVERYTHING FROM
YOU KNOW NAMING A WHOLE
CATEGORY RESILIENT WILDLANDS
AND REALIZING THEIR OTHER
WILDLANDS BESIDES FORESTS- DOWN
TO NEED TO FOCUS ON ON PLANNING
AND COMMUNITY HARDENING SO ON
THE WHOLE I MEAN I'M- JUST.
THRILLED THAT- WE'RE PUSHING
THE CONVERSATION FORWARD HERE I
WAS HOPING WHILE WE HAD THE
BENEFIT OF L. A. L. HERE WE GET
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORICAL
CONTEXT FOR WHY I'VE HAD. I'VE
BEEN A BIT OF A- I HAVE- I
WOULD NOT SENATE REQUIRES A BIT
CRUNCHY OVERALL. FEW YEARS ON-
ON ON SOME OF THE FUNDING.
CYCLES AND HOW IT'S- REDID
DIFFERENT FIRE RISK ZONES- SO I
DON'T KNOW IF ELIO IS STILL
ONLINE BUT- ONE OF DISTRICT I
TWO TOPPINGS ON TOUCH SAID THE
SORT OF FORCED HEALTH SPACE
WRIT LARGE. AND THEN THE
HARDENING SPACE- SO
HISTORICALLY LMAO HAVE YOU GUYS
ANALYZED- SO IT'S A ON FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION WHAT
THE- THE REGIONAL BREAKDOWN HAS
BEEN FOR FUNDING HISTORICALLY.
MISTER SINISTER BROWN. YEAH I
CAN- JUMPING ELEVEN NINETY MY
COLLEAGUE CAN ADD- ACTIVATED
SMOKE THINK HE'S LOOK AT THAT
BUT I THINK OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT HISTORICALLY THAN DAY
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE HAS
HAS OFTEN HAD- MAYBE- HAD MORE
THE FINDING IN SOME OF THESE
AREAS THEN AND THEN THE SOUTH
AND IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF
STATE THERE'S MORE STUDENTS
THAT TRADITIONAL FOREST PLANTED
SOME OF THE POOREST HEALTH.
FUNDS HAVE GONE I THINK- MORE
TO THAT AREA BUT MY COLLEAGUE I
BRAIN BROWN THE ALSO HAVE. HAVE
SOME WORDS TO ADD AS WELL.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN- RYAN
BROWN WITH THE L. A. L. JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ON THAT.
MS CHRISTINE POINT WE DID LOOK
PARTICULARLY AT THE-
CALIFORNIA- IS A FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM AS
WELL AS THE FORCE HEALTH
PROGRAM. IN BOTH CASES WHAT WE
LOOK AT WAYS. FOR ALL THE GRANT
PROVIDED OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THROUGH GPRS FINDING.
VERY LARGE SHARE THE FUNDING
AND I CAN PULL UP THE NUMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEES INTERESTED.
I'M SURE OF IT WENT TO USE
CERTAIN REGION OF THE STATE
PREDOMINANTLY THE SIERRA NEVADA
REGIONS. NORTH COAST IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN A MUCH
SMALLER SHARE OF A WIN TO.
SOUTH OF THE TO HELP TAXIS- WE
HAD SOME SUBSEQUENT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WITH THE
RESOURCES AGENCY THEY CAN
PROBABLY SPEAK. MORE TO IT I
THINK THEY'RE PROBABLY SEVERAL
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
OVER TIME- THEY REPORTED FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THEY RECEIVE
RELATIVELY FEWER APPLICATION
FROM SOME OF THOSE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION THAT COULD BE
DIFFERENT REASONS FOR THAT WE
HAVEN'T EXPLORED THAT AND TOO
MUCH THAT THE AT- AND- IT MAY
ALSO HAVE SOME. SOMETHING TO DO
WITH SOME OF THAT FACTORS THAT-
SUPPORTIVE PROGRAMS SOME OF THE
CRITERIA THAT ARE USED TO
EVALUATE PROJECTS SO- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THOSE ARE GIGI R. F.
FUNDED PROGRAMS ARE. FOCUSED IN
PARTICULAR ON- IT WILL RELEASE
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT FACTORS IN
EVALUATING THOSE PROGRAMS AND
IN GRANT APPLICATIONS IS THE-
THE CARBON BENEFITS AND THERE
MAY BE CERTAIN TYPES OF
PROJECTS. ARE THERE MORE
PREDOMINATELY IN SOME OF THOSE
ARE LARGER TREE FOR CITY AREAS
THAT- SCORE BETTER ON ON SOME
OF THOSE CRITERIA. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I'M AND I. TO THE
CHIEF AND THE SECRETARY
CROWFOOT AND THEIR TEAMS AND-
I'VE HEARD I'VE HEARD NOTHING
BUT WILLINGNESS AND- CREATIVITY
ON THEIR PART TO TRY TO. SOLVE
THAT- THE HISTORIC INEQUITY
JUST. THE NUMBERS 3% OF TOTAL
FUNDS FROM FOREST HEALTH
HISTORICALLY OF GOING TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND NINE
PERCENT. OF FIRE PREVENTION
HAVE OVER THE LIFE OF THE
PROGRAMS- BUT- YOU KNOW THERE'S
THEY'RE SORT OF THE LOCAL. THE
LOCAL WILL QUESTION WHERE I
KNOW THERE'S ACTUALLY BEEN
GRANTED TURN IN TURN DOWN OR OR
OR A RETURN BUT THESE CRITERIA
QUESTION- I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
A QUESTION IT'S- MAYBE MAYBE
I'LL START WITH THAT AND- CAL
FIRED G. PORTER YOU GOT. IF YOU
GOT THE- IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
WILLING- IN THE IN THE EARLY
ACTION BUDGET ITEM THOUGH THAT
WE PUSHED PUSHED OUT- ARE YOU
GONNA BE RESTRAINED BY THE SAME
KIND OF CRITERIA AND HAVE TO
SCORE APPLICATIONS. AS RIGIDLY
AS MR BROWN WAS REFERRING TO
WEAR. IT'S SORT OF IT'S THAT
CARBON METRIC OVER EVERYTHING
ELSE AND THEREFORE A LOT OF
THESE OTHER PROJECTS THAT MAY
NOT HAVE. ON A PER ACRE BASIS
THE SAME GHG AVOIDANCE
POTENTIAL BUT A TON OF PUBLIC
SAFETY BENEFITS FOR INSTANCE.
DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY
UNDER CURRENT LAW OR IN THE
PAST ALLOCATION. TO IT TOO TO
BE A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE AS
YOU SAID KIND OF IN THAT
PROBLEM SOLVING MINOR OR IS
THERE IS THERE NEED FOR FURTHER
DIRECTION. THE SENATOR STERN
GREAT QUESTION AND- I'M GONNA
TURN TO OUR EXPERT IN THIS AREA
THAT IS- ANGELA LOUDEST.
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CLIMATE AND ENERGY. YOU CHIEF
CORNER AND THANK YOU SENATOR
SENT THE QUESTION I WE DO HAVE
FLEXIBILITY WITH THE FUNDING-
BOTH THE G. G. R. I. FUNDING
AND THE GENERAL FUND FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY- WE CONSIDER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS- FOR
PROJECTS. AS ONE OF JUST
THIRTEEN CRITERIA IT HAS A BIT
OF ADDITIONAL PREFERENCE OVER
OTHER CRITERIA THAT WE USE FOR
PROJECTS ELECTION ALTHOUGH WE
DON'T- IT'S NOT ARE OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY THE SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT IN THE WAY THAT IT FITS
ECOLOGICAL GOALS IS THAT IT
GETS MORE POINTS THAN ANY OTHER
YOU THAT WE- ARE ABLE TO LOOK
ACROSS ALL OF THE FUNDING. THAT
FORCED HEALTH- IS GIVEN IN THE
EARLY ACTION PLAN WE ARE ABLE
TO LOOK ACROSS ALL OF THE
BENEFITS THAT A PROJECT BRINGS
TO THE PROGRAM- AND THEN TO
SPEAK TO THE POINT ABOUT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CALCULATIONS BUT YES WE DO HAVE
EVEN MORE FLEXIBILITY WITH-
CONSIDERING ADDITIONAL. ARE AT
WITH AN- THE WITH THE PROJECT
WILL BE ON GENERAL. TO NOT NEED
TO PRIORITIZE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT THAT THE CRITERIA
HAVE NOT CHANGED SINCE WE'VE
HAD THIS 3% AND 9% ALLOCATION
BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOT CHANGED
THE SCORING CRITERIA WE HAVE-
WE HAVE PUT AND WE'VE WORKED
WITH OUR OWN STAFF AND WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO- TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL TO DO MORE OUTREACH
FOR. PROJECTS IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE STATE AND TO
ENCOURAGE PROJECTS IN- NINE
COMMERCIAL FOREST ECOSYSTEM
TYPES SO- DON'T UNDERSTAND
ENCOURAGEMENT POINT BUT MY
POINT IS IF. YOU HAVE THE SAME
CRITERIA BEFORE BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE ENCOURAGING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO APPLY. BUT YOUR
CRITERIA ARE STILL WAITING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS A
AT LEAST A CRITICAL METRIC IN
THAT THEY'RE STILL NOT GOING TO.
SCORSO AND NOW THEY WERE USING
GENERAL FUND WHITE WHY DO WE
HAVE TO HAVE THAT METRIC AT ALL
SENATOR I WANT TO JUMP IN HERE
BECAUSE ALSO THE OTHER PIECE OF
YOUR QUESTION IS RELATED TO THE
FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS YES I SO
I WANTED TO TOUCH ON WHAT YOU
JUST SAID AND THEN ASK- CHEAPER
LAND TO SPEAK AS WELL. BUT WITH
THE WITH THE- THE COR CRITERIA
HASN'T CHANGED- THE OUTRAGE IS
THE KEY COMPONENT BECAUSE THERE
ARE PROJECTS THERE ARE VIABLE
PROJECTS IN PROJECT AREAS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT JUST
WEREN'T APPLYING BECAUSE OF THE
WORD FOREST. AND SO I BASS
WHERE THE DIFFERENCE AND
NUANCES HERE WERE WERE WORKING
WITH. THE LOCAL- FOLKS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR YOU AND
ME AND THIS CONVERSATION IS
SOUTH OF THE DASH OF BEES I
UNDERSTAND THAT- THAT AREA- AS
TRADITIONALLY LOOK AT THOSE
GRANTS AS NOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
APPLY- WHERE WE'RE CHANGING
THAT IN THE NARRATIVE IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS BUT WE'RE ALSO- I
WANT TO GIVE. A CHEAPER LAND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
FIRE PREVENTION SIDE OF THIS
BECAUSE IT IS. A HUGE PIECE OF
THE EQUATION AS WELL. THANK YOU
BUT YOU A- THANK YOU ENSURE YOU
OF THE COMMITTEE CHEN AFTER
INTO RECTOR HELP. UP RIGHT OFF
THE BAT- CENTER CEREMONY DRESS
YOUR CONCERN FOR THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAMS- JUST
AS- ENCHILADAS MENTIONED WE TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. OF THE
CARBON EMISSIONS BUT ALSO THE
WILDFIRE AVOIDANCE BUT TO YOUR
COURT APPOINTED TO THE- FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS WE ARE
SPECIFIC BUILD OUT IN VALUE
WEIGHTING FACTORS THAT ARE
WAITED HAD MUCH HEAVIER RELATED
TO WILDFIRE THREATS. FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY- PROTECTION OF
PEOPLE PROTECTION OF HOMES- WE
TAKEN SOME OTHER FACTORS LIKE
LOW INCOME DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY VEGETATION TYPE. IS NOT
A COMPONENT AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY A WILDFIRE AVOIDANCE
WHETHER YOU ARE IN A FORESTED
AREA CHAPARRAL AREA OR ANY
OTHER PARTY CALIFORNIA.
WILDFIRE AVOIDANCE IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF HOW WE
EVALUATE OUR GRAND SO. TO YOUR
POINT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
OUR FOCUS REALLY IS ABOUT
TRYING IN. OUR REGION DO MORE
WORK TO GET GOOD QUALIFIED
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
SYSTEMATIC ISSUE THAT IS
PREVENTING US FROM GRANTING
MORE PROJECTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HOPING THAT.
WITH THE HELP OF YOUR STAFF-
INDIANS WORK WE'VE DONE AND
WORK WE BUT DONE WITH OTHER.
OTHER ENTITIES ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT THIS YEAR WE
WILL SEE MORE GOOD QUALITY
APPLICATIONS DATA WILL ALLOW US
TO HAVE A MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF OUR FIRE
PREVENTION. PROGRAM AND DANIEL
YOU'VE BEEN YOU'RE NOT JUST
SAYING IN THIS HEARING YOU BEEN
DOING THIS WORK BEHIND THE
SCENES TO SO I REALLY WANT. TO
APPLAUD YOU AND THE WHOLE TEAM
FOR. MAKING YOURSELF OF. TO US.
THE ISSUE I I'VE BEEN IS NOT
THOUGH G. THAT- THEY DON'T
QUITE THERE FOR IN THE PRO IS
CALLED FOR. BUT ALL. BECAUSE
RESTORATION PROJECTS WEREN'T.
PREVIOUSLY ELIGIBLE EITHER IN
THE IN THE AUDIT LEAST ON THE
FOREST HEALTH THROUGH THE FIRE
PREVENTION INSIDE SO THAT. YOU
KNOW IF YOU DID INVASIVE GRASS
REMOVAL PROJECT. YOU KNOW
SOMEWHERE IN SAN DIEGO OR
RIVERSIDE OR YOU KNOW. LOS
ANGELES. THAT THE FUNDS WEREN'T
THERE TO DO THAT DID IT BACK IN
PEACE SO IF YOU HAD THE GOATS
COME THROUGH A CANYON AND DO
THE CLEARANCE WELL THEY JUST DO
NEW TO THE LANDSCAPE BUT THEN
YOU HAVE NOTHING. ON THE BACK
AND IN THE FINE THAT MAKES IT
ELIGIBLE TO DO LIKE NATIVE.
LANDSCAPE RESTORATION THERE AS
WELL DO YOU HAVE THAT NOW CAN
YOU DO SAY RESTORATION OR SAY
LIKE THE ROADSIDE TREATMENT
ISSUES ANOTHER HUGE ONE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE. YOU
A LOT OF REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO RIGHT NOW THE
MUSTARDS COMET RIGHT IT'S ALL
ALONG THE ROAD SIDES. AND IT
SPREADS THROUGH THE ROAD SIDES
OFTEN BUT- WE'RE NOT- IT
TYPICALLY HAS BEEN THE FOCUS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN A GROUP
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET A LOT OF
ACREAGE OUT OF THAT PROJECT
RIGHT YOU'RE GONNA GET A VERY
SORT OF. NARROW BAND BUT A VERY
HIGH HEAT YOU KNOW HI
PREVENTION QUALITY. SO DO YOU
HAVE. SORRY TO KEEP DRILLING
FURTHER AND FURTHER DOWN BUT DO
YOU HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO DO.
ROAD SIDE TECHNICIAN AND THEN
ALSO THAT THAT RESTORATION P.
SO ESPECIALLY WHEN AREAS THAT
ARE WORRIED ABOUT EROSION THAT
YOU CAN. YOU CAN KIND OF. DO
BOTH ENDS OF THE PROJECT. THE
MITIGATION THE TREATMENT. AND
THEN ON THE BACK AND THE
RESTORATION. THE SHADOW I I'D
LIKE TO IN YOU ON ON THE
SPECIFIC- WHAT WHAT WE HAVE- IS
A PORTFOLIO OF OPPORTUNITIES
AND- THEY'RE REALLY GEARED
TOWARD THAT FUEL REDUCTION AND-
WILDFIRE AND LANDSCAPE
RESILIENCE- AND THEN COMMUNITY
PROTECTION. SO THERE ARE OTHER
PROGRAMS- THROUGH THE
CONSERVANCY IS BUT ALSO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH NATURAL
RESOURCES CONSERVATION SERVICE
THAT ARE C. D.'S ARE C. D.'S-
AND- AND OTHER FEDERAL
PROGRAMS- RUN THROUGH
AGRICULTURE AND INTERIOR. THAT
ALSO HAVE A SPACE YEAR- AND
THEN RELATED TO ROAD SIDE
SPECIFICALLY AND I HAVE A SPACE
IN THAT RESTORATION PEACE AND
YES WE CAN FIND SOME OF THAT-
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO FOCUS ON ON
THE ACRES THAT THESE DOLLARS
ARE EXPECTED TO DELIVER OVER
TIME- WITH THAT OTHER PIECE AS
AS- ADDITIONAL BENEFITS.
ROADSIDE IT WE'RE WORKING WITH
CALTRANS VERY SPECIFICALLY-
WITH SOME OF THEIR- PLANNING
EFFORTS AND- MINGLING ARE ARE
PROGRAMS AND MAPPING AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
COMPLEMENTARY WORK. ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE- BOTH ROADSIDE IN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THOSE- UPSLOPE
OR DOWNSLOPE AREAS- TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND IS THAT
THROUGH THIS FOREST HEALTH
PROGRAMS THAT THAT CALTRANS
PARTNERSHIP YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THAT YOUR YOUR MAIN
TOOL THAT TO DO THAT MERGING IS
THAT FOR SALE. THAT THAT
PROGRAM ACTUALLY IS SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
FOR YEARS ON BUT BUT NOW- WITH
THE- FOREST AND FIRE RESILIENCE
TASK FORCE FORMALLY KNOWN AS
THE FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE- WITH PATRICK RIGHT AT
THE HELM- WE ARE EMBEDDED
TOGETHER AND WORKING ON THE-
THESE KIND OF ACT. NOT JUST
CALTRANS AND HEALTHCARE BUT
THOSE ARE TWO OF THE BIG- YOU
KNOW WHEN IT'S ROAD SIDE THEN
YOU THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
DON'T PUT A ROUND PEG IN A
SQUARE HOLE HERE SO. IS FOR IS
FORCED HEALTH. THE FINE THAT'S
GONNA DO. THAT WORK OR IS IT
OTHER FUNDS USING THE MIX IT'S
A MIX OF MINES YEAH. I MEAN I
WOULD SAY MOST PROBABLY LOOK
POINT TAKE AND THAT. AS WE
SHIFT. AND EMPHASIZED. THE
REGIONALLY DRIVEN STRATEGIES WE
NEED TO ASSESS OUR HISTORICAL
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE ACTUALLY
THAT THEY PROVIDE RESOURCE AS
AN EQUITABLE WAY ACROSS REGION.
WE DIFFER IN OUR INTERPRETATION
OF DATA YOU INSTEAD 329% WE
THINK 25% OVER THE LIFE BUT WE
TAKE AND- WE NEED IT WE NEED TO
MODERNIZE. ADOPT OUR PROGRAM SO
THAT THEY ENSURE THAT RESOURCES
ARE GETTING ACROSS THE STATE SO
SENATOR YOU KNOW WE FULLY
EXPECT. YOU TO HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE ON THAT I THINK
IT'S YOU KNOW WE CAN REPORT
BACK TO YOU ON THAT ON THE
CHANGES THAT WE MAKE. I GET
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR WHICH IS
OKAY YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A SUITE OF PROGRAMS
THAT CAN BE. EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY ACCESS BY YOUR
LOCAL FOLKS DOWN THERE TO
ACTUALLY. DO ALL THE TYPES OF
WORK YOU NEED TO DO. SO THROUGH
THAT FOR THROUGH OUR WORK IN
THE- WILL WILL ENSURE THAT
HAPPENS AND THEN WE CAN CIRCLE
BACK AND TALK TO YOU ABOUT HOW
THAT'S CHANGED. THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT THAT'S GETTING
ACROSS THE STATE NO MORE I GOT
AWAY. WE APPRECIATE THAT AND I
WOULD JUST SAY. IT'S NOT EVEN
THAT I'M- MY END RESULT MIGHT
MY DREAMS THERE IS NOT THAT YOU
KNOW THE EVERY COUNTY GETS THE
SAME EXACT PERCENTAGE OR THAT
YOU KNOW MY BACKYARD GETS. YOU
KNOW EXT PERCENT IN RIVERSIDE
GET 6% THE METRICS DRIVING THIS
I REALLY TRULY BELIEVE OUGHT TO
BE. CLICK SAFETY RISK THAT THAT
RISK TO LIFE AND PROPERTY AND I
KNOW WE BACKED INTO THE GOALS
OUT OF A CARBON FROM CARBON
PLACE ORIGINALLY IS AS YOU
JERRY SECRETARY PUT IT SO IT'S
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE YOU
GUYS HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO DO
YOUR WORK THIS IS SUPER HELPFUL
FEEDBACK THOUGH AND- AND I
APPRECIATED. AND I JUST I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALSO I DON'T
WANT TO UNDER CUTS THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE GOLD I
DON'T WANT TO UNDERCUT THE MO
YOU WE WANT YOU TO GO I WANT
YOU TO DO THAT WORK RIGHT LIKE
I I'M BODY IN ON BACK TO YOUR
PROJECT I THERE'S A STANFORD
STUDY THAT JUST CAME OUT LAST
MONTH. THAT WAS LOOKING AT THE
SORT OF ACREAGE BASE GOALS ON
LANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT THAT WE
NEED TO GO FASTER FURTHER YOU
KNOW AND WE WANT TO PUSH YOU TO
BE YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO COUNT
WE WANT TO HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE
LET'S TRY TO KNOCK OUT YOU KNOW
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR
OR TRY TO GET ABOUT HALF A
MILLION. I JUST BE WHAT THE
STANFORD STUDY POINTED OUT- IS
THAT THAT THAT FUNDING BACK
PIECE IS ONLY GONNA SOLVE ONE
ELEMENT SO BUT MY SECOND
QUESTION WAS REALLY ON THAT
HARDENING SIDE IF YOU START
FROM MEANS IGNITION AT THE
HOME. AND SORT OF WORKED
BACKWARDS ALL THE WAY TO THE
FOREST VANCE WE'VE GOT. A CO
EQUAL KIND OF EMPHASIS HERE-
WHICH IS WHY I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO JUST YOU KNOW AGITATE ON
THIS POINT EVEN IN OUR SENATE
PLAN HERE- I THINK WE'VE GOT
YOU KNOW 3% OF FUNDING TO
HARDENING TOM HARDEN. I DID A
STANFORD STUDY RECOMMENDS A
THIRD OF THE FUNDING GO TO
HARDENING. SPECIFICALLY IN THE
HOME AND NOT NECESSARILY ALL
PUBLIC DOLLARS BUT SOME KIND OF
YOU KNOW MATCH DEFICIT SO WE'VE
GOT SUCH A BIG EMPHASIS ON THE
LANDSCAPE SIDE BUT ON THE
HEARTENING SIGHT I KNOW WE PUT
OUT THE INITIAL TWENTY FIVE.
AND YOU GUYS CAN TRY TO SCALE
THAT HOPEFULLY WOULD FEED OUR
PARTNERS. IS BEING MADE TO MAKE
IT A HUNDRED BILLION. YEAH
UPDATES FOR US THERE ARE WHAT
WE EXPECT. I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING
TO LEARN IS GO AND YOU DON'T-
COMMIT BUNCH OF MY- RIGHT UP
FOR BEFORE YOU KNOW WHAT REALLY
WORKS. AD NOTING DUES PRIVATE
ENGAGEMENT TO WIN THAT. BERMAN
INSURANCE IS OBVIOUSLY HUGE
FACTOR HERE TO AND DRIVING SOME
OF THAT. THE PRIVATE SECTOR YOU
KNOW ENGAGEMENT I'M NOT YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT SO MUCH THAT WE
WANT. SUBSIDIES TO MALIBU
HOMEOWNERS TO HARDEN THEIR
HOMES WHEN YOU KNOW THEY'RE
SITTING ON A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSE AND WE NEED THAT
HARD. IT'S MORE LIKE THE PEOPLE
IN CHATSWORTH LIKE MANNER ON
FIXED INCOME IT'LL TWO BEDROOM
IN THE WILL WE OR OTHER FOLKS
IN LAKE COUNTY YOU'RE- AN OPEN
BEAVER WHEREVER ELSE YOU CAN'T
AFFORD IT. I WE TALKED LAST
TIME THAT. THE ESTIMATE WAS
THAT YOU GET TWELVE THOUSANDS I
THINK HOMES INSPECTED. OR MAYBE
WAS HOMES HARDENED OUT OF THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION SKILLED ONE
HUNDRED. CAN YOU JUST GIVE US A
LITTLE UPDATE ON. WHERE THINGS
LOOKING LIKE IN THE HARDENING
WORLD WHAT WHAT WHAT SHOULD WE
EXPECT TO SEE IN. YOU KNOW IN
MY FANTASY WORLD I WANT CO
EQUAL ALLEN HARDENING UP
AGAINSTLANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT IS
A BILLION AND A BILLION NOW
WE'RE- YOU KNOW THIRTY MILLION
IN A. BILLION WE GOT A WAYS TO
GO BUT- WE TALKED A FOR THE CAN.
ON THAT I'D BE REALLY HELPFUL
FORMER WILL BE GOOD DON'T MISS
CURSED HAD OR HOW. UP WITH HERE
SO. IN SO EVERY. REALIZES THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED TWENTY FIVE.
BILLION FOR THE ENTIRE. EARLY
BUDGET AND REGULAR BUDGET THIS
IS FIFTY FIVE MILLION IF THIS
PROPOSAL STATUS OF THE RICE YES
TWICE AS MUCH. IT MAY NOT BE A
PERCENTAGE BUT SECRETARY
CRAWFORD DID YOU WANT TO TRY
THAT. YEAH I MEAN AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OBVIOUSLY WE NEED
TO RAMP UP OUR INVESTMENTS
WITHIN COMMUNITY. AND INCLUDES
HOME HARDENING. AND YOU'RE
RIGHT SENATOR WERE WORKING THE
LEVERS AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IN PROPOSED INVESTMENT FOR
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
BEAM UP ON WHICH WOULD BE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PILOT-
JPA IS FORMING BETWEEN CAL FIRE
AND- WE ASK THE MANAGE THESE.
THAT THIS PILOT. FILE WOULD BE
LOCATED IN TWO TO THREE-
SPECIFIC AREAS CERTAINLY ONE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ONE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M SOME
CONSTRAINTS DO YOU THINK
FEDERAL FUNDING ON ON PRIVATELY
OWNED HOMES THAT WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH. AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
WORKING THROUGH WHAT IS THE
RIGHT COMBINATION OF. YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE NASCENT PUBLIC
SUBSIDY FOR THIS WORK.
RECOGNIZING YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN
HIGH HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES SO
HOW DO YOU ACHIEVE SCALE. WE
THINK THIS IS AN AMBITIOUS
PILOT GIVEN ITS TALE OF A
HUNDRED MILLION THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE IN DIFFERENT PLACES THAT
WILL WILL LEARN FROM. AND IT'S
CERTAINLY GOING TO ALLOW US TO
OF ALL ABOUT THE PUBLIC
INVESTMENT IN THE HOME
HARDENING. I THINK YOU KNOW
GONE IS THE DEBATE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE SPENDING MONEY IN
COMMUNITIES OR HELPING. YOU
KNOW EXPAND HOME HARDENING WE
RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO DO THAT.
WE JUST NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS THE BEST ROLE FOR- DOES THE
STATE FUNDING. DOESN'T ANYTHING
YOU'D ADD. MISS KIRSTEN DID YOU
HAVE SOMETHING. OUR THIS IS ON
THE- POINT- I JUST HAD MY- TO-
TO MAKE SURE FOLKS WERE AWARE
THERE IS ALSO. THAT WE IN THE-
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE. BILL
LANGUAGE. THAT WAS INTENDED TO
GET IT SENATORS STERN'S CONCERN
ABOUT THE REGIONAL AND
INEQUITIES AND THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM. AND
SO THAT LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRED HEALTHCARE TO
PRIORITIZE AND PROJECTS THAT
PARTICULAR POPULATION AND LARGE
NUMBER OF STRUCTURED.
STRUCTURES REGARDLESS OF
VEGETATION TYPE. I MEAN HE'S
USING OUTRAGE AND THOSE TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES SO I JUST WANTED
TO. I'M JUST LIKE THAT FOR THE
COMMITTEES TO THE COMMITTEES
AWARE AND- ALERT THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR LISTENING TO OUR
NEEDS. ARE AWARE THAT ON THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN SOME
ACTION TO TRY THAT AND BRING
SOME BALANCE TO THOSE PROGRAMS
AS WELL. HI I HAVE TO MOVE US
ALONG I HAD NO SENATE REQUIRE
HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I
THANK YOU CENTER. STERN AND
THANK YOU. FOR THIS PURPOSE. I
DO I WAS STILL I'M SORRY TO I
DIDN'T GET ANSWER HOW MANY
HOMES THEY PLAN TO HARDEN THE
FUNDING. JUST WEST HOPING TO
GET THAT HOW MUCH WE MIGHT GET
OUT OF THIS BUT WE CAN STILL
LOOK THAT BACK YOU. CENTER
STERN- OFFLINE OKAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'LL BE AT. WE CARE SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
THANK YOU TO- THE SENATE BUDGET
TEAM FOR WORKING THIS ISSUE TO
THE VICE CHAIR CENTER STERN
FURTHER FOCUS ON THIS LANDMARK
INVESTMENT FIVE BILLION OVER
FIVE YEARS- THIS IS WHAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS THIS IS WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS GONNA NEED TO BE
ABLE TO COMBAT THE REALITY THAT
WERE IN. A AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FACE OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND
DECADES I WILL ALSO SAY THAT
THIS IS AN EARLY INVESTMENT
MEANING I THINK WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO DO MORE. THE MORE WE
SPEND EARLY THE LAST WERE GONNA
SPEND LONGER TERM BOTH ON THE
DESTRUCTION THAT WE SEE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS-
WILDLING. END S. SECRETARY
CROWFOOT NOTED NOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS DEEPLY ENGAGED WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS BUT WE
NEED ABOUT TWO TO THREE BILLION
EVERY YEAR MOVING INTO OUR
FOREST LANDS AND WILDLANDS AT
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A DENT IN
THIS MASSIVE PROBLEM THAT ALL
OF US ARE FACING- IN THAT MAY
MEAN ADDITIONAL DOLLARS ON THE
TABLE FROM THE STATE. BUT
ABSOLUTELY I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY FOCUSED
ON IS ENSURING THAT OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME.
AGAIN THOUGH- WILL SAY CANDIDLY
DATE. THE FIVE BILLION OVER
FIVE YEARS. RIGHT THING AT THE
RIGHT TIME. JUST AT FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
GUARANTEE FOR THE WILD AND
RESILIENCY IT'S GOING TO BE A
MASSIVE SHOT IN THE ARM. FOR
THE SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS LET
ALONE THE COMMUNITY HARD THE
FIRE BREAKS. AND WHAT I'M ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR MISTER CHAIR IS
YOUR FOCUS ON THE FOREST AND
WATERSHED RESTORATION. THE
CHAIR AND I WERE TALKING JUST
YESTERDAY ABOUT. THESE LANDS WE
USED THE MENACING NATIONAL
FOREST AS EXAMPLE THEIR NEWT. I
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE THE
SAME FORCE CONDITIONS IN THAT
FORCE FIRST CENTURY. BECAUSE OF
THE DEVASTATION AND HOW HOT
THAT FIRE BURNED. WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON THAT WATERSHED AND
FOREST RESTORATION I THINK
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO PUT MORE
INTO THAT. HERE IN THE COMING
YEARS QUICKLY. CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS I JUST WANT TO
MENTION GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
TWELVE HUNDRED SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ARE MOVING
FORWARD- IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET
THAT WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
GOVERNOR BUT THE STATISTICS
SHOW US THAT WE HAVE TO GO
FURTHER. OVER THE LAST DECADE
WERE DOWN FORTY TWO HUNDRED
HAND CREWS FROM CDCR. INMATE
HAND CREWS FORTY TWO HUNDRED-
AS OF ABOUT SIXTY DAYS AGO WE
HAVE FOURTEEN HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX TOTAL INMATES IN THE SYSTEM.
NOR ADDING TWELVE HUNDRED AYE
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS THIS YEAR
IT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH A DECADE
AGO WE DIDN'T SEE THE DEATH THE
DESTRUCTION THE SIZE AND THE
SCOPE- IN THAT HAS TO BE A
CONTINUED FOCUS UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE NEED TO GO UPSTREAM
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO COMBAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
RESPONDING TO FIRES. YOU KNOW
THAT OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WAS ORIGINALLY GONNA BRING FOR
POTENTIALLY ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE POSITIONS THIS YEAR
FROM CAL FIRE I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
THAT. THIRD I AND I HAVE JUST
ONE LAST POINT AFTER THIS IS
CONTRACT COUNTIES SO CONTRA
COUNTIES- AS WE KNOW- OVER THE
LAST- GOSH ALMOST CENTURY. I
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING FIRE
COVERAGE IN THE COUNTIES THAT
INCLUDE ORANGE LOS ANGELES
VENTURA SANTA BARBARA MORAN IN
KERN- THEY HAVE A FOCUS OF
ABOUT FOURTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL HAND
CREWS IN THOSE COUNTIES. WHAT
WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT AT THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME SPENT ON
FIRE CREWS IN CONTRACT COUNTIES
ARE ON S. ARE ALIENS- AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT HERE IN THE
COMING WEEKS- AND I KNOW THAT
THE ASSEMBLY IS ALSO GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON THAT- IN THE LAST
PIECE OF THE SAY IS A LONGER
TERM IN REGARDS THE BIO MASS
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. IN MAKING
THAT- THAT A MEGAWATT- WORK-
THE COSTS MAKE UP FOR OUR WORK.
IS GOING O BE THAT
TRANSPORTATION COSTS NO THAT
THAT TEN MILLIONS IN THERE BUT
I THINK LONGER TERM ESPECIALLY
TAKING OUT. THOSE DEAD AND
DYING TREES AFTER THE FORCE
WORKING NEED TO HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION IN THE COMING
MONTHS. BUT AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
NO B. S. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
pGRATEFUL I HAD TO MISS ROY AT
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK-
TRULY. INTO THE PROTEINS OFFICE
FOR THEIR DUE DILIGENCE ON THIS
AND I KNOW THAT I SECRETARY
CRAWFORD IS. BEEN ALL OVER THIS
IN THE SECTOR THANK YOU TO YOUR
TEAM AS WELL. TURNED BACK OVER
TO MR. ANY COMMENTS FROM. THE
CHIEF PORTER HAS CREW. OUR
DAILY I WANT CENT REQUIRES
REMARKS. WELL JUST SAVE MOST
BROADLY WE RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE
WE FOCUS ON RESILIENCE TODAY WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
REALLY STRONG RESPONSE CAPACITY
A CAL FIRE YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT THEM IS THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED WILDLAND
FIREFIGHTING FORCE IN THE WORLD
SO- YOU KNOW IT ANOTHER TIME WE
CAN GO INTO MORE IN DEPTH IN
TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS. IN IN
BUILDING THAT CAPACITY- BUT
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE IN
THE ENTIRE- COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP JUST IN EXPANDING
THE CAPACITY OF CAL FIRE WE'VE
DONE YOU KNOW EXPANDED CALPERS
RESPONSE ABOUT THE I DON'T OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS SO
RECOGNIZED THAT CONTINUES TO BE
CRITICAL. WE'RE REVIEWING THOSE
APRIL LETTERS AS WE AS HIS
HEARINGS GOING ON OKAY WELL
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
EVERYBODY BUT IT WITH THE
MINISTRATION FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS NOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING IN FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
YOUR SCREEN AND I WILL NOW SIT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPATING
NUMBER IS 844-291-4815 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE FIVE SIX
ZERO SEVEN SIX NINE DETAILS
DIRECTIONS AND HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE OR ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET YOUR
DEVICE. YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON TO TESTIMONY OVER
THE. FOR IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM. WITHIN YOU FOR YOUR- I
MAINTAIN DECORUM OR ATTEMPT TO
MAKE THE CORE DURING THE AS
DISCUSSED IN ANY INFO WHOSE
DISTRICT MAYBE REMOVED FROM
THEIR MEETINGS. AND HOW TO
CONNECT MUTED PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE AFTER. AT THIS TIME
AFTER REFER DISCUSSION ITEMS WE
HAVE TWENTY FOUR ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA SEE OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
VOTE ONLY PEOPLE CAN HAVE GIVE
THEIR INPUT. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
IS MADE TO SEE STREAMLINED HERE
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN THIS CLOSE THE SAME MANNER
AS CUSTOMARY THERE'RE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS PROTECT SHE'S
PLEASE BEAVERS. PAGE FOR ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. I CAN BE
HEARD LAST- FOREVER. PHYSICALLY
HERE TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
MASK ON WHILE YOU'RE PRESENTING
TO US COVER YOUR NOSE. AND
MOUTH AT ALL TIMES SO. LET'S
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING AND
HEAR FROM. THE MEMBERS IN. OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM
THREE ONE NINE ONE. PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND- TRUSTEE COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF A NUMBER OF
AGRICULTURAL CLIENTS THE FIRST
ONE EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO
THE SENATE FOR PUTTING FORTH AN
AGRICULTURAL FUNDING PROPOSAL-
IT'S BEEN WELL THOUGHT OUT AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR IS IT AT HIS
SEEKS TO ADDRESS LIKE TO MAKE
JUST A COUPLE MINOR COMMENTS ON
THAT PROPOSAL ITEM TWENTY THREE
FIRST OF ALL FORMER FUNDING THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR FORMER
FANTASTIC AS YOU KNOW IT IS A
GREAT PROGRAM INCENTIVE BASED
PROGRAM THAT DELIVERS REAL
RESULTS AND IS ACCOUNTABLE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE MONEY FOR
AG BURN I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
OF TWO NOTED THAT THE ONLY
REASON WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
ISSUE HERE TODAY IN THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IS BECAUSE THE
AIRPORT REJECTED THE PROPOSAL
FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN AIR
DISTRICT FOR THEIR REDUCTION IN
AG BURN ANY MONEY FOR THIS
ISSUE NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED ON
THE SAN JOAQUIN AIR DISTRICT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE FOCUS
IS COMING FROM AND IF WE MAKE
THIS OPENED ALL AIR DISTRICT
ONLY GONNA SLOW DOWN THAT
PROCESS AND REALLY MAKE IT
UNATTAINABLE FOR THE SAME
WALKING A DISTRICT TO ACHIEVE
THE GOALS SET OUT. ON METHANE
DIGESTERS THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
IS THE REASON WHY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT METHANE DIGESTION THE
REDUCTION OF METHANE IN DERRY
IT DOES NOT HAVE A TECHNOLOGY
PREFERENCE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
REDUCTION OF METHANE WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
SHOULD BE SENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEM TO
DETERMINE WHICH TECHNOLOGY IS
BEST USED TO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS IN THE DAIRY INDUSTRY
AND THEN FINALLY. HOW ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION WE DO SUPPORT THE
PET DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL IF STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED WE DO NOT
SUPPORT A TILT CURED MIDDLE
SEGMENT WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
IT'S BEEN JUSTIFIED AND THE
BASIS FOR IT IS NOT WELL
SUPPORTED WE ALSO DO NOT
SUPPORT THE FULL PROPOSAL OF
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S GOING TO
CREATE STAFF POSITIONS- AND
IT'S GOING TO CREATE A BURDEN
ON THE INDUSTRY. WE THINK IT'S
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE FOR THE
SENATE TO CONSIDER FUNDING WITH
GENERAL FUND AT THIS TIME-
BECAUSE WE. DO HAVE THE GENERAL
FUND TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BUT
WHEN THAT SENT WHEN GENERAL.
GOES OUT. THAT WILL BE BORN
BACK BY INDUSTRY. TO SUPPORT A
PROGRAM WHICH WE DON'T BELIEVE
HAS BEEN FULLY JUSTIFIED SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. S.
MAKAYLA. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS MAKAYLA
HERE ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES ON
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR MISTER CHAIR
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP AND THAT OF THE
SENATE ON WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
IN THE ENGAGEMENT OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE- WE DO
SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS WE
APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATION
ALSO WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
WE'VE HAD WONDERFUL
CONVESATIONS WITH SECRETARY
CROWFOOT A CHIEF PORTER OF MISS
MORRIS AND OTHERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND HOPE TO SEE
THESE FUNDING PRIORITIES I
WOULD LIKE TO NOT GO THROUGH
ALL OF THEM BUT SPECIFICALLY DO
CALL OUT THE ONE MENTIONED BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO GO BIZ FOR A
TRANSPORTATION TO GET SOME OF
THOSE FUELS OUT OF THOSE OUT OF
THE FOREST. I ALSO AGREE WITH
SENATOR OF MCGUIRE WHO SAID WE
HAVE A LONG ROAD AHEAD. IF THE
STATE AND THE FEDS ARE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR COMBINED ONE
MILLION AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
JUST SHY OF THIRTY FOUR MILLION
ACRES IN THE STATE SO INDEED WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO. THE
OTHER POINT I'D LIKE TO RAISE
WHICH WE DID WITH THE EARLY
ACTION- EFFORTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR. IS WE
ALSO HOPE THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF POLICY CHANGES THAT
ARE MADE. INCLUDING ON
PRESCRIBED FIRE LIABILITY.
HOPEFULLY A ONE PERSON IN
CHARGE TO GO AFTER THOSE OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES- ON
THE STATE SIDE. AMONG OTHERS SO
WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT- MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW OPEN THE PHONE
LINES TO HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. LET ME CHECK TO SEE
IF MEMBERS ARE IN TWENTY FORTY.
NOT SEEING ANYONE LET NOW LET'S
MOVE TO THE- PUBLIC COMMENT. C.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OPEN
THE WINDOWS OF YOU WHO WISH TO.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ON YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO FIRST TO
WIND. THIRTEEN THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I AM
LOCAL COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE NON ACT
TESTIFYING MANUFACTURES AND NO
CARE AND I'M COMMENTING ON THE
SENATE PASSED BUDGET PLAN. SHE
THAT SENATE PROPOSAL USE
GENERAL RATHER THAN AT YOUR
EMAIL STRUCTURE HOWEVER WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH GROWING
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET BY 40%
WHAT OUT INCLUDING ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES.
ESPECIALLY AS THE SECRETARY
NOTED NON ACT PESTICIDE MAKE UP
FIFTY PERCENT. OF THE MAIL
FUNDS BUT SECRETARY ALSO KNOWS
THE BACK MAJORITY OF THE FIVE
CANADIAN IN THE PROPOSED
INCREASE WILL GO TO- ACT
PROGRAM. IN TWO YEARS WE
ANTICIPATE BEING BACK HERE
AFTER YOU PAY 15% OF THE VASTLY
INCREASED BUDGET SO WE URGE THE
SENATE TO ADOPT A LOWER LEVEL
OF FUNDING THIS YEAR TO ALLOW
TIME FOR A HOLDER DEPRESSION.
WHEN COMPARTMENT ON HOW FUNDING
COULD BEST BE. THANK YOU. NEXT.
ONE TWENTY. THE MORNING CARE
CAUSED IN NUMBER- IS JAY THE
NAME THANK- WE FAMILY FARMERS I
AM WHILE WE'RE STILL DANGER THE
PROPOSAL CAPITA SUPPORTED THE
PROPOSED MIL SHE AND SOME HAND
DEVELOPED WITH THE TOLD. FOR
PLEASED WITH ADDITIONAL TA
FUNDING AND AFTER HOURS ALONG
WITH OTHER ASPECT OF THE SENATE
PROPOSAL BUT ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN EIGHT THOUSAND SMALL AND
MID SCALE FAMILY FARMERS AND IN
LIGHT OF THE STATE BUDGET
SURPLUS CASH URGES YOU TO ADD
THE BARING HONESTY CRITICAL ONE
TIME INVESTMENT. AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FIFTH PROGRAM AND TEN MILLION
FOR TOOL LIBRARIES URBAN AND
RURAL FARMERS CAN ACCESS
EQUIPMENT SECRETARY ROSS
HIGHLIGHTED BOTH OF THESE
SEVENTEEN MILLION FOR REGIONAL
FOOD HUBS TO REMOVE BARRIERS
FOR SMALL SCALE FARMERS TO
ACCESS INSTITUTIONAL MARKETS IN
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR BEGINNING
FARMER AND FARM WORKER TRAINING
PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN MEETING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATORS AND STAFF FOR
MONTHS TO PUSH THESE URGENT
INVESTMENTS AND WOULD WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS FOR
MORE IN DETAIL WITH YOU ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IF I WAS NOT
CLEAR ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR WE'RE THE COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO HOLD THAT MATTER OPEN
AND WAS SACKED WE MOVE QUICKLY
TO THE PUBLIC KIND FIVE WERE
HOLDING ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
AND NUMBERTWENTY THREE OPEN
PLEASE MODERATOR. QUEUE UP THE
NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT. M. PARDON
ME ONE MOMENT. TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY TWO. I THINK CLEARLY
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS ALL MAKING
WITH THE PACIFIC FOREST TRUST
THANK YOU FOR AN EXCELLENT
HEARING TODAY IN A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION- WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS IMMENSE PROPOSED
PACKAE. WE THINK THAT ARE YOU
MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL BY CLICKING
ON THE BUDGET RESOURCES OKAY
THINGS ARE THAT THIS YEAR THE
BLOODY THINGS TAX- BUT HAVING
THAT PREDICTABILITY OF YEAR
OVER YEAR FUNDING FROM THE
STATE IS CRITICAL FOR BUILDING
THE MOMENTUM AND THE CAPACITY
TO REALLY GET THE SCALE THAT WE
NEED TO IT'S HARD TO DO THAT
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT ONE YEAR
AT A TIME. ENTERED THE BUILDING
ON THE PORTFOLIO APPROACH THAT
WILL INDEED MEASURES AND EARLY
PRACTICAL. EXCELLENCE HE THE
FUNDING FOR. THIS THE AROUND I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD TO. BUT
ALSO ONE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MENTAL THE ONE
THAT CONSERVE. BOARD IN THE
FACT. THE RESULTING. ONLY COVER
OF THESTATE NO OTHER COUNTRY
BORD WORKS THEY- AND SO THE-
OF THE DAM TO. BE AVAILABLE TO.
DO THAT SORT OF OUR. ADDITIONAL
IN HOUSE TO HOW WE MANAGE
FORESTS INCOME THE- SOURCE
WATER AREAS SUCH AS ABOUT-
AFTER. THE GROWTH CASTING AND
THE ECHO RANGE. AND I THINK
THAT REFLECT OF YOUR TAKE ON.
BIGGER VIEW OF FOR HEALTH THEM
SENDING OUR- THE FOR. BUT
LOOKING THE THING WE NEED TO DO
ORDER TO MOVE TO THE SORT OF.
LARGER TREES YOUR TREES MORE
HIGHER RESILIENCE WORKS
OVERTIME- HUNTINGTON WEEK SO
MAKING TERM THE CRITICAL THANK
YOU. X. LINE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS NATALIE REGARDING
HOW THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS SPEAKING ON
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR WE APPRECIATE
THE EMPHASIS ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE PROPOSED
WILDFIRE INVESTMENT BUT WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO ALSO INCLUDE
THE LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE
IN THAT WORKFORCE WORKING LOCAL
COURSE SERVED SOME OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE UNDER TWO THOUSAND
CORPS MEMBERS ARE READY TO TAKE
A SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF THE WORK
WE APPRECIATE THE CHAIRED THE
QUESTION WHAT. WHAT'S HAPPENING.
COUNTERPART AND HOPE. XIN
DRIZZLE AND TIME PROBABLY. FOR
SHOVEL PROJECTS THANK YOU.
NECKS LINE. THIRTY THANK YOU
CHEN MEMBERS NEED A CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. HERE TO
COMMENT ON SHE TWENTY THREE I'M
A BEEN A TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIANS FOR REFORM AFTER
THAT ACTION THAT IN THE CAL BY
MAIL NOT MY CAR THAT THE BEAR
WITH ME A I ATTEMPT TO FROM
POINT I'M WE ARE STILL THAT THE
PROPOSAL AND WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH FORTY FEEDBACK IN THE
COMING DAYS I'M WE APPRECIATED
THAT THE BILL BUCKLED AGENDA
FROM ACROSS OF WEEKS I GOT A IN
KERR. LAST TALKED MANAGED OF
THE PRIOR APPLE TIME TO BETTER
ALIGN THE STATE BY WILL COME
HEALTH AND GO WHICH ARE WE
SUPPORT UPDATING HEARING THE
PESTICIDE FEED TO DIFFERENT
KIND OF LIFE YOU'VE BEEN SIDE.
OPPOSE PLAN TO PROVIDE AND
FUNDING FOR TRANS. THAT THE
PATHWAY. DOESN'T COULD SEVERAL
AYE AYE HOWEVER WHICH WOULD
LIKE TO THANK. AND BUDGET
LEADERSHIP BROADBAND. THE
PHYSICALLY BE SUPPORT. BY ON
TECHNICAL. AND THAT WILL HELP
OUR- AND FARM. NOW PASSED THE
FLEET. BRITANNIC AT THE BARCODE
LIFE. TO SUPPORT BY. MINDED AND-
THEIR MONEY. AFTER AND ANT
PROGRAM THE PDF. HOWEVER WITH
MISSING FROM BOOK. IS FINE TO
SUPPORT YOUR. ARGUMENT HELD.
BETWEEN COURAGE THE SUB
COMMITTEE. TO ADD TWO ITEMS TO
THE PACKAGE. FIRST THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT FUND TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA AT GREATEST RISK
OF HARM FROM PESTICIDE USE. AS
WELL AS YOUR REQUIREMENT BY DPR
INCREASED OVERSIGHT OF
PESTICIDE. DETECTED IN THE AIR
THROUGH THE AIR MONITORING
NETWORK. WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
THIS. GIVEN THAT FUNDING
UNDERSTANDABLE. PRIOR THE- IN
BECAUSE PROTECTION. THE
PRACTICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
FARMERS. THANK YOU FOR ME TO
THE COMMITTEE. FORWARD AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED. IN THE-
WEEKS THANK YOU. NECKS. NINE
FORTY ONE. YEAH YOUR MORNING AT
MA'AM STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF
MEDICAL RE OPEN SPACE AND SAY
THE REDWOODS SPEAKING ON TWENTY
FOUR WE EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE PLAN PARTICULARLY INVESTOR
AND CAL SCORCHED HELP FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM THE- SHE'S
FORESTER FIRE PREVENTION
PROGRAM STATE PARKS SPEAKER
CONCERT AND B. C. B. WE ARE ALL
HAPPY TO SEE FOR THE SENATE BAY
AREA. PROGRAM ALTHOUGH WE
BELIEVE ME AND SHOULD BE MY
LARGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. TEX LINE EIGHT. THE
MORE MR CHAIRMAN THIS IS JULIE
BALLOT BALL ON THE HALF THE CAL
BY MY ENERGY ALLIANCE SPEAKING
EITHER A THREE AND FOUR ITEM
TWENTY WEEKS THE HIGHER EIGHTY
NINE OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD
THE ALL TURN ACT BURNING WE
SUPPORT THE FUN GOING TO THE
LOCAL JUST LOOKING BACK THE
PROBE. AND THERE'S BY ENERGY
INVEST ALREADY IN IN THE VALLEY
READY TO WITH THE WITH THIS-
OFFICER TO THE SENATE THE Y.
FUNDING PROPOSED IN A THIS IS A
THE DAL FOR FUEL REDUCTION PRO
SUCH AS THE HOW PROGRAMS EDA
ALTERS THE TO THE TEN MILLION
DOLLAR THAT IF BECAUSE TO MOVE
MORE WASTE OUT OF. UNDER IMPORT
BECAUSE ARAFAT OF WEIGHT WASTE.
ON THE FOR FLOOR MANY FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS HAVE ENOUGH.
ONLY THAT DOWN THE FUEL LOW.
BUT NOT ENOUGH TO. AND OTHER.
IN IDAHO WAY. REGION'S ELECT
ENOUGH TO BY A- IN. ALREADY
PLACE BE BACK. BECAUSE THIS
MATERIAL A HOME AND WILL BE
TURNED IN CREE RENEWABLE ENERGY.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORK WITH
YOU IN THE IN THE- ON HOW TO
MAKE FUN BACK TO WORK FOR THOSE.
ALONG THE LINE SUGGESTED BY
JOHN. AND GO THIS FUNDS LONG
AND DRASTIC BY SENATOR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WHY FOR TWO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND A READ
REPRESENT CAL LOW TWENTY EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
MORNING- WE HAVE ENJOYED THIS
ROLE KINDA. HOWEVER ONLY ONE
PERSON HAS MEANT STAFF A. K.
FIRE AND YOU CENTER FOR SOME OF
THOSE NUMBERS- I'VE BEEN TO
HAVE THEIR K. FIREFIGHTERS WITH
FORTY FIVE YEAR I'VE PROBABLY
BEEN TO HUNDRED. I WHAT THEY DO
UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL AND THERE
UNDER THERE LEFT NOW THAN THEY
WERE LAST YEAR AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT AND DROUGHT YEAR IN
YOU KNOW DOUBT A THERE WILL BE
FIRE IN SPITE OF THE PRINT IN
SPITE OF ALL THE GOOD WORK AND
THE FUNDING THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING THERE WILL BE FIRED
SOME OF THEM STARTED BY MAN-
MAN MADE SOME BY A LIGHTNING-
AND OTHERS AS WELL. WE NEED
MORE HAND CREWS AND WE NEED
MORE FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE IS WE HAVE
FIREFIGHTERS WORKING FOR A
MONTH AT A TIME WITHOUT A DAY
OFF AND THEN THEY MAKE IT WHEN
THEY ARE READY TO AND THEY'RE
BACK ON THE FIRES AGAIN FOR
ANOTHER MONTH THEY'RE EXHAUSTED
START FROM LAST YEAR THE YEAR
BEFORE THE YEAR BEFORE AND
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH STAFF TO GET
THEM RELEASED WE NEED IT
DESPERATELY ON MUTUAL AID
FIREFIGHTERS COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP. TWO WEEKS
MAXIMUM AND THEN THEY GET TO GO
HOME- OUR FIREFIGHTERS DON'T
GET THAT OPPORTUNITY BUT THEY
WORK A LONGER WORK WEEK AND
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS WE WORK A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR WORK WEEKS
LOCALS WORK A FIFTY SIX HOUR
WORK WEEK- SO I'M HERE TO MAKE
A PLEA NOT THAT YOU DO NOT DO
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WE DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THAT BUT YOU
HAVE TO DO MORE FOR THE
STAFFING OF CAL FIRE BECAUSE
THEIR BOOTS ON THE GROUND
THEY'RE OUT THERE PUTTING THE
FIRES OUT AND THEY'RE GOING TO
START WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A-
AND WE HAVE TO. REALIZE THAT
AND STACK THEM UP ACCORDINGLY
SO WE BEG YOU TO TAKE A SECOND
LOOK AT THE STAFFING OF THE
PRESIDENT. OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
HAVE BEEN ON THIS CALL BUT HE'S-
ON AN AIRPLANE- SO COULD DO IT
BUT WE MAKE SURE COMMUNITY. IN
A LETTER. TO EACH OF YOU. OF
THE LACK. FOR UNDERSTAFFING AND
CREWS AND OTHER RE. THE YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK. THREE PINE.
PINE GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS DIRECT MARKET SPEAKING
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND THE
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IT'S
PRACTICES STRATEGICALLY IMPROVE
SOIL THAN CARBON SEQUESTRATION
AS WELL AS REDUCING METHANE
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR THE HEALTH
PEOPLE- GRANT AFTER BECAUSE BY
THE GOVERNOR OUR HOPE IS THAT
THIS ITEM WILL BE DISCUSSED
DURING YOUR CAP AND TRADE
HEARING. ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST AND THE CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE I EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
PRESCRIBED BURNING PROPOSAL AND
FINALLY THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
IN AGRICULTURAL NETWORK
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SENATE'S
WORK ON THE MELFI AND
SUSTAINABLE CASH MANAGEMENT WE
ARE STILL ANALYZING THE SENATE
PROPOSAL AND LIKE FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS ON THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT. LINE FORTY THE LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN BRING
TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE CAL AIR
CAN OFF ASSOCIATION SPEAKING ON
HIS TWENTY AND TWENTY FOUR WE
AND SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED MILLION AND FUNDING FOR
THE FORMER PROGRAM IN THE
SENATE'S AGRICULTURE PLANNED-
INCENTIVES FOR PURCHASING THE
CLEANEST AVAILABLE VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT ARE CRUCIAL TO
ACHIEVING EMISSION REDUCTIONS
OF CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS.
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS IN
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL AND FORESTRY
SECTORS NECESSARY TO MEET
NATIONAL AMBIENT AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS IN NON ATTAINMENT
AREAS AND FULFILL CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS FURTHER WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
AIR DISTRICT PRESCRIBED FIRE
GRANTS IN THE SENATE'S WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCY
PACKAGE. TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPLEMENT
PRESCRIBED BURNING THANK YOU.
NECKS YEAH LINE FORTY LINE IS
OPEN. HEY GOOD MORNING
ASSISTING CAN THE UP THE
CALGARY TOWER ALLIANCE ON THE
ONLY SUPPORTS THE SENATE BEFORE
THE FORMAL YOUR PLAN I WOULD
THINK THIS IS THE ONE OF CAN
THAT THE NEED OF THE PROJECT
THE FUNDING FOR THE- CALGARY
TOWER COULD. HOWEVER THE NEED
GOES BEYOND THAT PROPERTIES-
THAT ARE IN THE FACE WE ARE AN
EXTRA NEED IN ORDER TO CONNECT
AT THE TOP OF SPORTS DOCTOR
PLAN. WE WOULD. WILD THERE ARE
COMPETITORS OUT THERE. YOU KNOW
THE AMERICAN. ABOUT THE ABILITY.
FOR THE FUNDS. SMALL TALK. HI
THIS OVER. NINE VISITORS. AND
AFTER. ARE WEEKEND. CONSERVE TO
WORK OUT. X. NINE FORTY SEVEN.
MR HEARING SENATORS CAN'T THEY
MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS OTHER
AG CLIENTS MAKING VARIOUS
COMMENTS ON ISSUE TWENTY THREE
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR THE FORMER
PROGRAM THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR AG BURN
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THIS FUNDING
SHOULD BE DIRECTLY FOCUSED ON
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY DUE TO
CARVE YOUR JUNCTION OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR DISTRICTS AG
BURN PLANT. ADDITIONALLY WERE
ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
BIODIVERSITY RELIANCE AND
FURTHERANCE OF THIS INVESTMENT
ON BIODIVERSITY WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE AN ADDITIONAL
PROPOSAL REQUESTING YOUR
CONSIDERATION FOR A ONE TIME
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION CDFA TO
PARTNER WITH YOU SEE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN THE
U. S. B. A. FOR GRANTS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OUTREACH TO IMPROVE AND ENHANCE
VOLUNTEER HABITAT AND FORAGE ON
AGRICULTURE'S WORKING MAN YOU
SEE THE CITY BUILDING ON THE-
PHONE. MY AND LAST. AND LASTLY-
WITH BY TO CHECK A COMMENT ON
MILITIA FOR PAST. WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THE CURED MILLER
SESSION AND WE HAVE. THE OF THE
SAN ONE TIME PROPOSED. OF
NINETEEN DOLLARS HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE DOUBLING THE FUNDING IS
TO NECESSARY. TIME WE BELIEVE
THAT NEED TO BE MORE DISK.
OVERSIGHT AND- ON THE PROGRAM
FUNDING OF MOVING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NECKS. LINE FORTY.
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE AT
THE LEAST SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEN THE AIR CONTROL CALL AND TO
A NUMBER TWENTY. AGUIAR-CURRY
CELL DATED IN THE HEARING THE
FACT VALLEY ONE OF THE MOST AIR
QUALITY CHAO IN THE COUNTRY IN
ADDITION ABOUT IS HOME TO
TWENTY OF THE MY DESERVED
COMMUNITIES THE STATE FOR THESE
REASONS DISTRICT COURT ONE AND
NINE FOR THE FOR PRO WHICH IS A
OLD PERSON PRIVATE PROGRAM THAT
CAN QUICKLY PROVIDE YOU COULD
NOT IN AND AS WELL AS PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFIT. THE DISTRICT
OFFICE THE WAY HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE IDENTIFY FOR A- I
BERNIE. FUNDING IS GOING TO THE
FANS OF BURNING AND THAT. THAT
CAR HAS A- IN ADDITION THAT.
WILL HELP TO MAKE BACK. SUCH AS
OLD ORCHARD WITH. FEASIBLE AND
WILL ENSURE THAT THE THAT NOT.
TO PROFIT THE MATURE IS THE BIG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT. WHY
SEVENTEEN YEAR LONG SO. THANK
YOU MICHAEL GOOD OR AFTER THE
RUMORS PATIENT I WONDER FOCUS
MY COM THE DAILY METHANE
REDUCTION. FUNDING AND START
AGAIN SON MARK WHO HAS BEEN ON
ON THIS ISSUE TO GET. ALL BUT
SUPER. FOR THE- HAVE BEEN. I
START METHANE EMISSIONS EACH
STATE SO. ANCHORAGE AND
APPRECIATE THE APPROPRIATION
BUT BELIEVE IT DOES NEED TO BE
CHANGED TO REFLECT ON THAT
IMPORTANT POINT ON THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE WILL NOT GET AS AN
INDUSTRY TO THE 40% REDUCTION
OUT AT DISCRETION. I DON'T GET
IT YOU CAN CLOSE TO THE FORTY
PERCENT. WERE MAKING TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS WITH PROGRAM. GIVES
YOU SEEN THAT SENATOR WHITE
CASKET BELIEVE YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
DERRY NOTHING ESTROGEN KERN
COUNTY RECENTLY AND YOU CAN SEE
HIM ON THAT. YEAH EFFORTS ALL
OF THE MOMENTUM BIRDS WILL BE
LOST IF YOU DON'T YOU FUND.
PROGRAMS SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE.
ADEQUATELY CHANGE IN MOOD.
BURKE YEAH. THANK YOU NECKS.
LINE. THIRTY SEVEN. NUMBER OF
REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AIR QUALITY COLLECTION CALLING
IN OR ITEM- TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE HEARING
TODAY I'M- NO. FOR- I'M GOING
TO BURN OKAY. ON THE SPECIAL IN
BALLINA AND YOU JUST ARE HAVE
TO MOVE ADDITION. IN THE NATION
AS WELL THE MONSTER THAT FROM-
I WOULD URGE THE HERE TODAY TO
GO THIS FUNDING IN THE BLACK
VALLEY. HARDWARE POLLUTION WAY
SOMEONE SHOULD BE ANTI
CORPORATION I'M- ALTERNATIVE
ARE. FEASIBLE FOR THE HEALTH
AND THAT LOCAL THANK YOU FOR
EXAMPLE IN AND FRESNO- SEVERAL
WORLD. ARE LEAD TO. SMOKE SO-
COMBUSTION OF ARE- NOT A
PRIORITY OF OURS AND WOULD LIKE
TO SEE A PHASE OUT OF ANY. OF
THOSE COMBUSTION. AN
ADDITIONALLY WE WERE LIKE TO
HEAR FINDING TARGET TOWARD
SMALL FAMILY AND FARMS COLOR
THANK YOU. NEXT WHY EIGHT HELLO
IS OPEN. HI THERE THANK YOU
CHAIR AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M JANE TO BE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY THREE I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
SEEKS US SUPPORTS AN UPDATE TO
THE MATH TESTIFIED MELFI
INCLUDING PEERING TO THIS
INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PESTICIDES AND TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FARMERS.
COLLUDING ORGANIC FARMERS WHO
PRODUCE FOOD WITHOUT THE USE OF
THESE TOXIC PESTICIDES- WE'VE
ANALYZED IT PROPOSED TIERED
FIT- FEE SCHEDULE AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT MATERIALS IN THE
LOWEST HERE WILL ONLY GO UP ONE
HALF OF ONE CENT PER DOLLAR
UNDER THE PROPOSED MIL FEE
SCHEDULE. WE JOIN WITH PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS IN A TRANSITION
AWAY FROM HARMFUL PESTICIDE USE
INCLUDING RESEARCH AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WILL
HELP FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS
MANAGE PASSED SAFELY INCLUDING
THROUGH ORGANIC METHODS. A DNA
BARCODE LIBRARY AND EXPANDED
PESTICIDE AIR MONITORING
NETWORK IT'S ALSO CRITICAL THAT
WE INVEST IN DIRECT PROTECTIONS
FOR COMMUNITIES HARMED BY
PESTICIDE USE AND URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ADD A COMMUNITY
SUPPORT FUND TO THE BUDGET TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA AT GREATEST RISK
OF HARM FROM PESTICIDE USE. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESSTHE
COMMENT BY SENATOR DOLLY
EARLIER THIS FUMIGANTS ARE
REQUIRED OR MANDATORY FOR
GROWING STRAWBERRIES STARTS IN
THAT THERE ARE NO ALTERNATIVES.
WELL IT'S TRUE THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO GROW STRAWBERRIES
STARTS ORGANICALLY IT'S NOT
IMPOSSIBLE AND YOU'RE GAINING
STRAWBERRY INDUSTRY IS SLOWLY
TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM CAN'T
CONVENTIONALLY GROWN STRAWBERRY
STARTS. BUT WE FUNDED RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT ORGANICALLY GROWN
STARTS ARE AS HIGH QUALITY AND
PRODUCTIVE AS THOSE GROWN
CONVENTIONALLY. INVESTING IN
PUBLICLY FUNDED ORGANIC
RESEARCH AND EXTENSION THROUGH
THE- REVENUES THAT BY THE END
THROUGH FROM THE INCREASE MELFI
CAN ACCELERATE PROGRESS IN THIS
AREA AND MAKE ORGANIC STARTS
MORE WIDELY. AND ECONOMICALLY
AVAILABLE. A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPING
ALL ALTERNATIVE PEST MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES IS NOT SUFFICIENT.
AND WE SUPPORT IMPLEMENTING THE
CHEERED ME MELFI SCHEDULED TO
PROVIDE THE ONGOING RESEARCH
AND EXTENSION NECESSARY TO
EQUIP FARMERS TO DECREASE THEIR
USE OF HIGHLY TOXIC PESTICIDES
AND TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE DISPROPORTIONATE EXPOSURE
TO THESE MATERIALS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT. BY
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I CAPTURE NINE AM AT THE
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA LINE TO
NURSES FOR HELP THE ENVIRONMENT
A NURSES WORK I'M SPEAKING TOP
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE OF
NURSES WERE CONCERNED WITH HOW
THIS PROPOSAL IMPACTS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BY MAKING IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT SAFER WE'RE PLEASED
WITH THE SENATE COMMITTEE HAS
PRIORITIZED TOXIC PAST CONTROL.
METHODS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
OBTAINING THE HEARING OF THE
MILKY AND IT WILL HOPEFULLY
INCENTIVIZE SAFER ALTERNATIVES.
TO DANGEROUS PESTICIDES. AND IT
WE ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
YOUR GAY FARM COMMON. I'M SORRY
HOUSEHOLD PART ARE CONCERNED
SHOULD NOT BE USING TOXIC
PESTICIDES TO CLEAN OUR HOMES
OUR SCHOOLS IN OUR DAY CARE
CENTERS ONE TIME FUNDING MUST
CAN IS NOT ADEQUATE IT FUNDING
MUST CONTINUE TESTIFIED DON'T
GO AWAY DESPITE WHAT THE
INDUSTRY TELLS US. WE ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED TO
OVERSIGHT TO FOUR OVERSIGHT OF
AIR MONITORING AND MEANINGFUL
ENFORCEMENT THAT WILL INCLUDE
NOTIFICATION ABOUT WHEN HOUSING
SECTORS DETECTED AND HOPEFULLY
SOME DAY PRIOR NOTIFICATION OF
ONE THESE PLACES WILL BE
SPRAYED ON COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER
CRITICALLY MISSING IS THAT
SUPPORT FUND FOR DIRECT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HARMED
CALIFORNIA'S FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THEY NEED THE FUNDS TO
PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED COMMUNITIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE THE
WORST AIR QUALITY AND TESTIFIED
CONTRIBUTED TO. OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR FAMILIES DESERVE
HEALTHY FAMILIES TO LIVE WORK
AND PLAY IN I JUST WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO THE SIXTIETH
ANNIVERSARY- DYING GRAVER- THE
PUBLISHING. OF SILENT SPRING.
WHAT WARNED. THE PESTICIDE TO
DANGER ONE ONE FOUR EVEN IT. SO
TO SAY THAT WE ARE JUST TO CAN-
IT IS. IT FAILED TO KNOWLEDGE
SIXTEEN YEARS GENERAL ONE
CLIENT. AT A PATH TO CLAIM
POINT. WE KNOW THE ATTACK BUT
WE HAVE YET TO FIND OUT ONE
TERM. WE COULD CAL FAMILIES AND
CAL. THANK YOU THE NEXT. WHY
FORTY THREE. HI MATT HOMES TURN
AN EDUCATOR CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH LITTLE MANILA ARRIVING
HERE IN SOUTH STOCKTON CALLING
IN TO COMMENT ON A COUPLE OF
ISSUES FIRST I JUST WANT TO
ELEVATE THE COMMENT ABOUT
INCLUDING THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN THE
WILDFIRE IN ISSUE- EITHER
AMAZING ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
TRAINING YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT OF THE ECONOMY
FOR DECADES- PUT THOSE FOLKS TO
WORK YOU WILL NOT BE TO EXPLAIN
THE POINTED MAKING UP CAL FIRE
CARRY THE LOAD- THE SECOND
ISSUE I WANT TO COMMENT ON OF
THE EXTENSION OF THE SIX MONTH
SEVEN LIQUIDATION DEADLINE.
EVERYTHING CALIFORNIA WITH
ALLOWED TO SCREECH TO A HALT
BECAUSE OF COME OF IT EXCEPT
FOR THE EMERGENCY FUNDING FOR
OUR MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR BEING DESTROYED BY AIR
POLLUTION WE WERE PUT UNDER THE
JOHN WILLIAMS- SACRED
LIQUIDATION DEADLINE AND THE
LIQUIDATION DEADLINES ARE USED
TO DIVIDE OUR COMMUNITY AND I'M
SPEAKING. SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
STOCKTON IN THE- WE WERE TOLD
THAT IF WE- YOU KNOW GO ALONG
WITH WITH WHAT YOU'RE DISTRICT
WANTED. ONE OF MY- OF. MY
WANTED ARE YOU TIRED PRODUCTION
BUDGET. WAS AT RISK WE HAVE FOR
FIVE MORE DAYS TO HELP FUND OUR
PORT ONE OF OUR MAJOR EMITTERS
IN THIS REGION AND WE WERE TOLD
NO LIQUIDATION DEADLINE IS
SACRED AND THAT'S GONNA THAT'S
GONNA JEOPARDIZE THE WHOLE
PROJECT. SO THE REALLY- THE-
DISILLUSIONED EXPERIENCE THAT
MADE PEOPLE LIKE ME THAT ARE
TRYING TO BELIEVE IN CAP AND
TRADE IN TRYING TO FIND A WAY
FOR THE BUDGET IMPACT
COMMUNITIES THAT MADE ME REALLY
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT I WAS A
PART OF A PERFORMING THEATER
ARE PART OF A CHANGE PROGRAM.
SO THOSE DOUBLE GRAYSON
DEADLINES ARE BEING USED
INAPPROPRIATELY TO UNDERMINE
THE SPIRIT IN AB SIX ONE SEVEN
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT IN THERE-
BUT THE MAIN ISSUE I'M CALLING
ABOUT THE TO HELP EVERYBODY
HERE PENETRATE THIS IDEA OF THE
FARMERS. ARE COULD WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS MONEY
COME INTO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY- AS OTHER PEOPLE SAID
MORE ELOQUENTLY- YOU KNOW IT
APPARENTLY NORMAL FOR ALL OF
US. ALL ABOUT THE GUY JUNIORS
YOUNGER- AND THOSE DON'T GO
INTO THE ECONOMIC. FEASIBILITY
OR. ANALYSES- BUT- THE FARMERS
BOARD THAT UC DAVIS INSTEAD
YOUR DISPATCH OF THE HOUSE
INTEGRATE BY ON. IN THE INTO
THE GROUND- AT THE- WILL ALMOST
ALL OF IT IS. FROM WIND AND
ALMOST ALL OF THAT IS COMING
FROM THE LARGEST WEALTHIEST.
INDUSTRIAL SCALE WINEGROWERS
THOSE FARMERS ARE USING THIS-
THIS TROPE THE STORY OF THE
FARMER AGAINST OTHER FARMERS.
ALMANAC I'M ASK YOU ALL TO
STAND UP FOR SMALL FARMERS AND
DIVERSE FARMERS. ARE AND OTHER
GREAT GROWERS THAT ARE DOING
UNIQUE THE I KNOW. PARENTS JIM
HAAS. RATES AREN'T AS
COMPELLING AS THE IDEA OF THE
FARMER THANK YOU HOPEFULLY WE
CAN. GET THAT BUDGET IN THERE
ABSOLUTELY BUT IT'S GOING TO
TREAT THIS IDEA OF A FARMER
PLEASE IT'S BEEN YEARS OF THE
BLANKET BLUDGEON. THANK YOU
NEXT. A LINE. FORTY FOUR. HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JULIA
DURING WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMENTING ON ISSUE TWENTY
THREE- WE SUPPORT MULTI
INCREASED THAT THE BASED ON
FEARS THAT ACCOUNT FOR THE
RELATIVE HAZARDS AND HAZARDOUS
REAL TRANSITION TO SAFER
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONE OR TWO
YEAR PROCESS THAT WILL TAKE
YEARS AND LONG TERM APPROPRIATE
NOTHING- MONITORING AND
INCREASED OVERSIGHT SUPPORT FOR
FARMERS TO SHIFT TOWARD MORE
AGROECOLOGICAL PRACTICES THAT
WILL OVER TIME BENEFIT THEM AS
WELL AS OUR STATE PRESIDENT OUR
WATER AIR AND BIODIVERSITY. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
RESIDENTS THAT WE WORK WITH AND
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR HOTEL AND I
MEAN MANY OF WHOM ARE PART OF
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY AB
WORKERS AS RESIDENTS CONTINUE
TO BE EXPOSED TO PESTICIDE
SPRAY DEVELOPED CANCER AND
CHRONIC ILLNESSES AND THEY NEED
AND WANT PROTECTION NOW NEITHER
THE SENATE NOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDE PROTECTION FOR
THOSE THAT EXPOSE THE
CLASSIFIED THINGS LIKE AIR
FILTERS OFFERS OUR OWN PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT- SO WE
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT EFFORT
OVERALL BUT THE MISSUS IS
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTING AND THE
VALUES OF THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO ARE
DEEPLY FAMILIAR WITH THE
REALITIES OF FARMING. IF WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT COST LET'S
BE REAL ABOUT THE COST OF THE
VIRGIN MEDICAL CARE THE COST
BUT OUR ENVIRONMENT AND THE
COFFIN PEOPLE'S LIVES AS WELL
BIOMASS I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AIR QUALITY COALITION
WITH SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THE
DOCKING BALLY THAT WOULD
SUPPORT NON COMBUSTION
ALTERNATIVE AND FUNDING ALSO
MUST INCLUDE NOTIFICATION FOR
RESIDENTS LIVING NEAR
AGRICULTURAL BURNING AND
PRIORITIZE. FUNDING FOR SMALL
SCALE FARMERS. WHO HAVE YOUR
RESOURCES. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHT YOUR LINER SO. SHE
GOOD AFTERNOON TAYLOR WITH FARM
BUREAU THIRTY THOUSAND FAMILY
FARMS ARE COMING TO RELATED
ISSUE TWENTY THREE WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATE PROPOSAL
TO PURSUE GENERAL FUND RATHER
THAN EMAILING CREE BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS CONCERN THAT
THE BILL THE FUNDING IS LIMITED
TERM THE STAFFING IN
PROGRAMMATIC OBLIGATION
PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED ARE NOT.
AT THE WE BELIEVE THIS WILL SET
A NEW FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE BUDGET FLOOR THAT MUST
BE BORNE BY FAMILY FARMERS-
RENDON RECTIFY MODEL STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT TODAY WE WILL BE
REQUIRED NEED A MUCH LARGER ONE
TOMORROW AT A 40% INCREASE OF A
ONE TENTH OF A PENNY DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE A LOT BUT IT
ACTUALLY MATRICULATED THOUSANDS
IF NOT TENS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR SMALL AND MIDSIZE FARMS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ALSO
EXPRESSED APPRECIATION FOR THE
PROPOSED FARMER FINDING MINIMUM.
MANAGEMENT ACT FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE. I THANK THE
SENATOR AND OF WHY ON THE FOR.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
AND I AM CALLING ON NECK.
PROJECT IN THE ADVERT PROPOSAL
AND THEN FINALLY THOUGH. YOU'D
BE IN OUR BUDGET ISN'T WITHIN
THE COMMITTEES IMMEDIATE
PORTFOLIO I THINK YOU HEARD A
COMMON THEME TODAY BY AND
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD AND
SECRETARY ROCK THAT. FULLY
FUNDING GIVE THE A AND R. WITH
MEDICINAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE JOINT BENEFIT
FOR FARMING. THE ENVIRONMENT
AND PURSUING THE STATE BOTH THE
WE ENCOURAGE THAT
CONSIDERATION. ACTUALLY. THANK
YOU. NEXT. ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING FARMER AND
BUSINESSMAN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE YOU CAN ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE I'M TOTAL SUPPORT
THE HUNDRED SEVENTY. HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION FOR FARMER
FINDING PROPOSED TO REPLACE
ADEQUATE MEANS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE PRIOR TO THE
MISSION OF THE DOLLARS SHOULD
BY BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE FACT THAT COMMITTEE. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR
BURNING BINDING WITH THE
CLARIFICATION THAT IT SHOULD BE
TARGETED TYPICALLY TOWARD THE
PALANQUIN VALLEY AND GO TOWARDS
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT IN
THAT REGION GOING FORWARD AND-
ASKED OTHERS WITH REGARD TO
GARY PROGRAMS EFA IN ORDER. TO
MEET THE GOAL OF CALIFORNIA'S.
AMANDA GOAL OF HER MY NORM.
EMISSIONS BY FORTY. BY TWENTY
THIRTY WE MUST IMPLEMENT BOTH
DIED AFTER AN AMP. ALTERNATIVE
MANURE METHANE PROJECT. VERY
MUCH SUPPORT FUNDING GOING
TOWARD BOTH THE AMP AND DERRY
DIGEST OR IS A BELIEVE THE
FIFTY MILLION IN THE BUDGET
SHOULD BE KNOWLEDGE IN NEUTRAL.
ALLOW THE PROGRAM TO CONTINUE
YEAH. AND FINALLY MISTER CHAIR
WE PPRECIATE THE NINETY
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
OPPOSED REGARDING THE FIRST
IMPACT MANAGEMENT. YEAH ARE.
YOU OF THE EXTERNAL ASSESSMENT
ARE CONCERNED I THINK SPREAD BY
OTHERS. AND IN FACT THE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS WILL CONCLUDE AND
A MASSIVE AN ATTACK ON FARMERS
AND ALL USERS WILL BE REQUIRED
TO SUSTAIN WHAT AMOUNTS TO A
40% INCREASE IN PPR PROJECT
GOING FORWARD. GIVEN THAT HE
BELIEVES. AND CONCURRENT OTHER
LAPTOP COMMITTEE SHE ADOPT A
MUCH LOWER IN THAT IT BELOW THE
FORTY FIVE MILLION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THANK YOU ARE YOU. NEXT
ONE FORTY NINE YARD LINE SO.
SHE GOOD MORNING SOME GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS GAIL
TELEHANDLER FORGETTING THREE
THOUSAND WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION FARMERS WHO GROW
FRESH PRODUCE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ISSUES TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY FOUR. I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND CAN CURVE WITH
SENATOR DOLLY COMMON CONCERNING
AND CONCERNS REGARDING SOME OF
THE ITEMS IN THE AGRICULTURAL
PLAN- THE PESTICIDE MIL OF THAT
MAN. WE WILL JUST THE LINER
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS WITH
THOSE ALREADY EXPRESSED BY OUR
AGRICULTURAL PARTNERS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION FOR THE
FARMER PROGRAM AND A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION. FOR ACT
BURNING WE DO COULD ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATING THESE BONDS AND
ALLOW THE FUNDS TO GET OUT THE
DOOR QUICKLY. WE ALSO SUPPORT A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FUNDING IN
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR THE WILDLIFE.
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCE THE
PACKAGE. THANK YOU AGAIN WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. NEXT. WHY FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CASH WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER KAREN SENATORS
LUCAS FRERICHS ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY EDITION
TWENTY FOUR WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE AND STEPS PROACTIVE
LEADERSHIP ON ISSUES OF
WILDFIRE RESPONSE AND
RESILIENCY INCLUDING THE
PREVIOUS ACTION ON EARLY
ACTIONS WILDFIRE PACKAGE TO
WEEKS AGO AND YOUR LEADERSHIP
NOW WITH THE PROPOSED WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCE
PACKAGE AND THERE IS MUCH TO
SUPPORT IN THE LATEST PROPOSAL.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A FEW
ADDITIONAL CONDUCTED CHANGES-
AT LEAST TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR YOU SEE AND OUR TRADITIONAL
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION FIRE
ADVISORS- NEED PHYSICIANS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE CRITICAL IN THE
YEARS AHEAD- AND ADDITIONALLY
WE BELIEVE THAT AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR FOR FOREST HEALTH- YOU
KNOW AND IT LEADS TO A HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION. IN PER I AM
IS GOING TO BE NEEDED AND SO
IT'S THE SAME AMOUNT IS THE
COMMITMENTS OF SB NINE A ONE
THIS AMOUNT FUNDING IS NEEDED
TO KEEP UP THE PACE AND SCALE
THIS WORK ON LANDSCAPE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL FOR YOU IF YOU
CURRENTLY IN THE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE BILLION POOREST HOW WE
THINK IT SHOULD- RESEMBLED WHAT
IF ANY CONTAINED IN ASKING NOT
A ONE IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR YOUR
SOCIAL WORK ON A SUPPORT ISSUE.
HAVE A GREAT DAY. AT THE SALE
IS. MONEY FOR THE BUY YEAR IN.
TO THAT- ACTION SO THAT TOTAL
AMOUNT IS TOO HIGH AND A MAY.
JUST SO. EVERYBODY THERE.
INCLUDE THERE IS A COMBINATION.
OUR NECKS MISS MISTER MODERATOR.
IT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE. FIFTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
CAROL DELGADO BEHALF OF THE
ANIMAL CONSERVATION SPEAKING ON
ISSUE TWENTY THREE AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
ANNABLE CONSERVATION SUPPORT
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS AMONG
PUBLIC PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT
STAKEHOLDERS TO ACHIEVE THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
ALL THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO RESPONSIBLE
ACTORS FOR ADOPTING INNOVATIVE
AND SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES THEY
MANAGE THEIR LAND. THE
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS THE WORTHWHILE
INITIATIVE THAT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY IN
ADDRESSING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AS WELL AS MANAGEMENT
WATER RESOURCES. AVAILABLE
CONSERVATION SUPPORT
CONTINUATION. AUGMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU. NECKS.
LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAN DELFINO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
SPEAKING TO ISSUE OUR TWENTY
FOUR. HOUR PLEASED TO SEE THE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROVIDED BY
THE SENATE PROPOSAL AND ARE
PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INCREASES FUNDING AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE TROUBLE
ENGAGEMENT PLANS AND MONITORING
VFW IN STATE PARKS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND INVESTMENT IN
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD. HOWEVER AS THE
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRES FORCED
ACTION RESILIENCE PLAN EXPLAINS
THAT WE CANNOT HAVE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL SOLUTION WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE LEVEL THE FIRE
PREVENTION FUNDING ARE DIRECTED
INTO THE RIGHT LOCATION TO
PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND
ECOSYSTEMS AND THAT ARE SCIENCE
BASED SOLUTIONS. THAT ARE BEING
USED IN THE DIFFERENT REGIONS
SO WE WOULD ASK FIRST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE DIRECT
HELP BUYER TO FIND FUEL
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS AND ACTIONS
AND CHAPARRAL AND- SHRUBLAND
HABITAT THAT DO NOT RESULT IN
TYPE CONVERSION OF HABITAT. OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EDUCATION
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES LIKE
MASTICATION. FROM TYPES OF
BURNING IN- THE HABITAT CARDS
TYPE CONVERSION INCREASED
RATHER THAN DECREASE FIRE
RESCUE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE FIRE PREVENTION
DOLLARS GOING TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT DO YOU MORE
HARM THAN GOOD AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WITHOUT MORE SPECIFIC
DIRECTION BY THE LEGISLATURE
HELLFIRE WILL ONLY RAMP UP-
COMMON PRACTICES IN CHAPARRAL
SUCH AS THOSE ALREADY MENTIONED
THAT WILL COME HIS. ECOLOGICAL
IMPACTS SECOND ONLY- WE URGE
THAT FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
HARDENING ALLOCATION SHOULD BE
INCREASED BEYOND WHAT'S
PROPOSED WE SUGGEST INVESTING A
STATE TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION AND THAT THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
SHOULD BE DIRECTED TO PARTNER
WITH LOCAL CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS EMPIRE STATE COUNCIL.
AND FINALLY AS NOTED IN A
LETTER SENT AT THE END OF LAST
WEEK REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE BUDGET
MORE THAN FIFTY DIVERSE
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET INCREASE
FOR TWELVE NEW POSITIONS THAT.
CDFW BRAND BY WE'LL REVIEW AND
PERMIT PARTICULARLY FOR THE
REVIEW AND CARD AT THIS WITH
WILDLIFE. I'M SORRY WILDFIRE
RISK. PROJECT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ALLEGED ADDED SECTION
FOUR ONE TO THREE TO THE PUBLIC
RE. CODE THAT WE CAL FIRED AT.
WITH THE DIP. JUDGE THAT THE
DESIGN OF THAT YOU REDUCTION
PROJECTS PROTECT BIODIVERSITY
WHILE ADDRESSING FIRE BEHAVIOR
AND PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S AN
CRITICAL BRITISCHEN ON BASSMAN
DIDN'T MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE DESIGNED AND
PERMITTED. ISSUE ONLY WHILE
PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIELLE
LYNCH AND I'D LIKE TO OFFER A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR ON THE
HAPPENED THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE ENCUMBER VIRUN
FIND WHERE WE FIFTY A PLAN TO
INCLUDE AN ADDITIONAL NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS
DICTATE PARKS THIS YEAR. AND
ALTHOUGH WE WOULD HOPE TO SEE
SOMETHING CLOSER TO THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AND SHOVEL
READY PROJECT NO STATE PARK YOU
CAN IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENT AFTER
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE WILDFIRE
PLAN ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND MAJOR
KERR ALL WE OFFER OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE WILD CARD PLAN IN THAT
THE BAKERY THAT. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SAN
GABRIEL AND LOWER LA RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY AND
FINALLY WE'RE HAPPY TO SEE THE
FIFTY MILLION DLLARS FOR THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD.
THAT BELIEVE THEY NEEDED MUCH
GREATER CHANCE SUPPORT THE
STATE'S WATER AND CLIMATE
RESILIENT MEET. THANK YOU.
NECKS ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS- GOOD
MORNING THIS IS RUSSELL NOW
ACTUALLY CANNOT BE AFTER
GENESIS REGARDING ISSUE TWENTY
FOUR- GENESIS APPLAUDS THE
SENATE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE WILDFIRE PREVENTION
RESILIENT PACKAGE. AS OUTLINED
TODAY WE WERE SPECIFICALLY
PLEASED TO SEE THE CREATION OF
FUNDING FOR THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION THAT RESILIENCY FIVE
GENESIS IS A CALIFORNIA COMPANY
BASED IN SAN DIEGO AND HAS
INSTALLED EMERGENCY WARNING
SYSTEMS IN SEVENTY TWO
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD. IT
HAS BEEN SPEAKING TO CITY AND
COUNTY OFFICIALS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ABOUT TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL BETTER PROTECT THEIR
CITIZENS IN THE EVENT OF A
WILDFIRE NATURAL DISASTER OR IN
INCIDENCES OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT DOWNS WITHOUT
EXCEPTION WHAT WE HEAR IS THERE
IS A STRONG DEMAND FOR EARLY
WARNING SYSTEMS BUT SECURING
THE REQUIRED FUNDING HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY MORE DIFFICULT.
WITH COVERT CONSTRAINED BUDGETS
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED OUT WE RECOMMEND ADDING
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THROUGH THE
W. P. R. F. WHICH FUNDS
ELIGIBLE PROJECT CATEGORIES
GENESIS HAS SUBMITTED A LETTER
ON THE STATE CAPITOL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT. PARDON ME ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BRUCE
I'M DAN WE CAN CAMP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
BIODIVERSITY TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE TWENTY THREE AND IF I
HAVE TIME ON TWENTY FOUR- THE
SENATE AGRICULTURAL BUDGET PLAN
WE WANT TO THANK YOU COMMITTEE
AND FOR YOUR AND YOUR HARD
WORKING STAFF FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO MOVING FORWARD-
THE CHAIR IS GRACIOUS WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR HOW THE GOOD
PEOPLE COME TOGETHER BECAUSE
RURAL AND URBAN TO SERVE ALL
CALIFORNIA. FROM FRESNO TO
PRETTY MUCH BALLPARK WE SUPPORT
UNTIL THE OTHER DAY AND
ESPECIALLY SUPPORT THE BOULDER
RESUMES PROPOSED INCLUDING
DISSIDENTS IN RESEARCH ALL
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS MANAGE
EFFECTIVELY EXPANDING THEIR
MONITORING NETWORK IN THE IN A
MARKET LIBRARY WITH THE
TRANSFORMATIONAL BENEFITS THAT
SECRETARY. ROSS INCLUDING
DESCRIBED. HELLO INCOME AND
COMMUNITY OF COLOR. ARSENAL
DIFFERENTIAL IMPACT MY COUSIN
IDAHO MINUTES OR AT WORK WE
JOIN WITH OUR- PARTNERS IN
URGINGS. TO ALSO. ADDING IT
COULD BE SAID FUND BUDGET. I
MEAN THIS IS PROVIDE CREDIT
DIRECT. PROTECTION. THINGS AS
PROTECT ON THE GREEN KNOWN
BETWEEN THE TREATED. AND MOST.
COMMUNITIES BASIC BANK LIKE IN
FAILED BUILDERS FOR SENSITIVE
SIDE. PERSONAL EQUIPMENT TO
WORKERS IMPACT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. ARE MONITORING THIS
TIED TO ENFORCE. AND PROVIDE
CULTURALLY. AND TIMELY NOTICE.
CAN YOU. BETTER COURSE OF. THAT
ENSURES THAT THESE RENDON IN
AND AREAS. THEY HAVE AUTHORITY
TO DECIDE AND PRIORITIZE. THE
PROTECTION THAT THEM BASED ON
THE LOCAL CONDITION. AND WHAT
WORKS FOR THE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY WE DON'T WANT TO ALLOW
COM WITH THE BEGINNING OF YOU
KNOW WITH REGARD TO I PEOPLE
SPECIFIC DIRECT. YOU DIDN'T TO
AVOID. HARM DUE TO TREATING
SHALL. THE SAME WE TREAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND AGAIN
THINKING MUCH FOR HARD WORK AND
ALL OF THAT. THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
LINES. NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
FIFTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN CAN JUST WITH AMERICAN
COUNCIL JUST A BRIEF COMMENT ON
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AS IT
RELATES TO THE- SETTLEMENT
PROPOSAL. WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE OVERALL
INCREASE. THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED EIGHT EIGHT LACK OF
ANY SORT OF LAKE COUNTY BILITY
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
EFFICIENTLY AND ON PRIORITY
PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS THE TIERED
APPROACH IN THE UNINTENDED BY
IN OUR BE UNINTENDED IMPACTS OF
THAT APPROACH MAY HAVE ON
MANUFACTURERS. AND USERS OF A
CRITICAL DISINFECTANT AND CROP
PROTECTION. PRODUCTS I WILL
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITNESS
COMMUNIONS AS WELL MISTER BROWN
MADE EARLIER- AND APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU X.
MOVING ON WE'RE GOING LINE
SIXTY GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED SENATORS- HI
MY KAMALA THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION BLANKET GROWERS
I'LL I'LL BE VERY BRIEF- WE
APPRECIATE AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND FUNDING CRITICAL ISSUES ON
THE OTHER FOR YOU TODAY
SPECIFIC TO ISSUE TWENTY THREE
THE SENATE AND BUDGET PLANS AND
FOR VERY BRIEF COMMENTS.
RELATIVE TO ADMIN SUPPORT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS THIS FUNDING IS
MUCH NEEDED AS THERE'S A HUGE
CHALLENGE FOR WONDER COURSE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT WE
ACTUALLY CONSIDERED CANCER
PROGRAM THOSE FUNDS MATHIS
DIRECTED TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. I'M SIGNED A BILL SAYS
THAT ISSUE WE APPRECIATE THE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTFALL THROUGH TWO YEAR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE YOU'RE NOT
PROPOSED GOES WELL BEYOND THE
AND MORE RESULT IN EMPIRE
BUILDING WHICH WE WILL NEED TO
FIND. FIVE HUNDRED FOR DOWN THE
ROAD I DO WANT TO QUICKLY KNOW
THAT. THE TIERED APPROACH.
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN TAX ON ALL
PASSAGE INCLUDING OR- WE ARE
WORK ON THE PROJECT. BUSY
DESTINY THAT. WOULD REALLY BE
YOUR AFTER. WE ALSO CREATE
SUPPORT HIS BANKS THE FARMER
PROGRAM. WHICH YOU FOR THAT.
ADDITIONALLY WAS A YOU TO FOUR
THE WILDLIFE. THANK AND
RESILIENCY PACK. THANK YOU FOR
LEADERSHIP AND- MY COM ON THE
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOUR
YOUR STAFF HAVE A GREAT DAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. I'M
SORRY I WAS MUTED LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY
ABOUT THAT GOOD AFTERNOON THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAKING FOR A LARGER
WITH CENTER HERE TO SPEAK ON
REPORT- WE APPRECIATE THE GOAL
THE PLAN AND THINK COMMUNITY
THANK MANY PARTS WORK BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
IDEA THAT PACKAGE INCLUDE
GREATER EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCY. AT THE TOP
OF THE PREVIOUS BUDGET YEARS
THAT IS ACTUALLY TRUE IN LIGHT
OF THE EXPECTED BUDGET SURPLUS
AND CHECK FOR FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING WE ALL
KNOW THAT AS CLIMATE CHANGE
WORSENS WE WILL CONTINUOUSLY
CLIMATE DRIVEN GREAT
DESTRUCTION AND THIS PROBLEM
BECOMES EVEN MORE ACUTE AS WE
ELECTRIFIED. MORE MORE MARKS ON.
IT TWO BUDGET YEAR HAVE THE L.
A HUNDRED FIVE NO DOLLARS.
HELLO YEAH I WILL GO
GOVERNMENTS BUT MOST OF THIS
MONEY GONE THE SHE OF ALL
YOU'LL GENERATE. FURTHER
EXACERBATE ARTICLE- PROBLEMS.
WE CAN BETTER WAGE ONE HAD.
ENERGY RESILIENCE EIGHT THIRTY
CLEAN ENERGY SUCH AS YOURSELF
OR SO CARE WITH THAT STORAGE.
THESE NEW DISTRIBUTED ENERGY WE
NEED TO BE CITED WOULD YOU TELL
WORKING PARTNERSHIP LOCAL. WE
DON'T HAVE A- STATE PRETTY MUCH
DO THIS THERE IS ONE THAT IS
OUTLINED IN THIS YEAR'S ASKING
NINETY NINE BIT COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCY ACT. AUTHORED
BY SENATOR DODD. THE BILL
DIRECTION CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION J. CREATE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND GRANT PROGRAM THAT WILL
SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
CREATING COMMUNITY ENERGY. PLAN
I'M SORRY FOR STEPS OKAY
FEDERAL STATE AND PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENT IN ENHANCE
ENERGY REVEALING. THAT HE HAS
ALREADY SPENT MILLIONS ON
MICHAEL GET PILOT PROJECT AND
THIS KNOWLEDGE MUST BE SHARED
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS THEY
INCREASE THEIR COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCY EFFORTS.
PARTICULARLY. VULNERABLE
COMMITTEES. AS SUCH WE- THAT
THE- SENATE. LOOK AT HI
MANAGING THIS. PRO WITH A
BRUTAL TWENTY TWENTY VIRUS PRO
WITH MIGHT INCLUDE MORE POWER
OUTAGES WE URGE YOU TO FIND
RESULTS PROGRAMS NOW AND CHART
TOWARDS CLEANER MORE REJECT
FUTURE MORE DETAILS CAN BE
FOUND IN THE LETTER THAT WE MR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. NEXT THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE JASON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN UNITED
DAIRIES REPRESENTING EIGHT
HUNDRED DAIRY FARMING FAMILIES
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE BUT UNITED
DAIRY SUPPORTS THE STANCE
PROPOSAL. ALLOCATE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO SEE GET THEY-
SUPPORT ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS TO ASSIST
DAIRY FARMS BUT MEANING OUR
MENTOR METHANE EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS. WE KNOW MORE
INVESTMENT NEEDS BEING MADE TO
ENSURE OF CALIFORNIA DAIRY
INDUSTRY CAN ACHIEVE. OUR
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS WE
ARE COMMITTED TO ACHIEVING
THOSE GOALS WITHIN SENTENCE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. AND BEST PRACTICES.
ALSO AS A STEP FORWARD AND
EVERY FAMILIES OF SIZES IN
CALIFORNIA BY WESTERNIZED
JERRY'S INTERNATIONALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR. STATE
COLLEGES ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL TO APPROPRIATE FIVE
BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCY. HOWEVER THE SENATE
PLAN ONLY PROPOSES MODEST
INCREASES IN BUDGETING FOR
WILDFIRE FUEL BREAKS. WITH
INCREASED WILDFIRE RESIGNS
FUNDING FOR TO SEE SIGNIFICANT
HAD INVESTMENTS IN PRESCRIBED
FIRE. AS PRESCRIBED FIRES THE
SINGLE BEST TOOL IN THE
PREVENTION OF WILDFIRE. THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK THIS MORNING
THANK YOU. NECKS ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN
ABSENT WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
I'LL START BY ECHOING THE
SUPPORT OF COMMENT SO MY
COUNTERPART CAPCO- WITH RESPECT
TO PRESCRIBED FIRE AND FUNDING
FOR THE PARTNER PROGRAM IN
ADDITION ALL EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR FUNDING FOR CLEAN AIR
CENTERS- AND WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE INCREASING THAT
AMOUNT AND I'D ALSO LIKE THE-
BUDGET COMMITTEE CONSIDER. THAT
THE FUNDING BE ADMINISTRATED
BY- CARD WHICH IS CURRENTLY THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY SIX CLEAN AIR
CENTERS INTENT OF PROGRAM THANK
YOU. NECKS THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARON MEMBERS CHENEY GO ON
BEHALF OF RELEASE. ISSUED
TWENTY FOUR WE SUPPORT DEFINING
PROPOSALS FOR. AWHILE BACK
PACKAGE AN ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
FUNDS FOR URBAN FORESTRY BUT WE
LIKE TO STRESS THAT THERE IS A
MUCH GREATER NEED FOR. THE NEED
OF MUCH GREATER THAN THE
AVERAGE PERSON WILL REALLY
SATISFY ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT
TO MAKE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT IN
MITIGATING THE IMPACT OF
EXTREME. EIGHT COMMUNITY
REBELLION AND HIGHLIGHTED AND
PPL AND OPTION. WE ALSO NEED
ROBUST GREENING SUPPORT ANY A
LOT. IN FUNDS FOR URBAN
GREENING AT IN WILDFIRE PACKAGE
COMP. TO YOU BUT- FROM THE
URBAN FORESTRY. CALIFORNIA
RELEASED LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
HONEST AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE NEXT.
ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS DOUG HOUSTON
I'M- WAITING IN THE BEHALF OF
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL
YOUR CONSORTIUM AND THE
WATERSHED CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY ALL OF THESE FOLKS MY
CLIENTS ARE ENTHUSIASTICALLY.
ENDORSED. THEME I DON'T TWENTY
FOUR. YOU'RE THE SENATE TWELVE
FIRE PREVENTION PACKAGE
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE CONSERVANCY ALLOCATION
THANKS SO MUCH. Q. THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE SEVENTY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S ROBERT
TERRY AND I'M AN INDEPENDENT
ENERGY POLICY ANALYST WITH
SYNERGISTIC SOLUTIONS
CONSULTING HERE TO COMMENT ON
ITEM TWENTY FOUR CONCERNING
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCE. THEIR CURRENT THERE
IS CURRENTLY BUDGETED FIFTY
MILLION PER COMMUNITY POWER
RESILIENCY BUT OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS THE CITY ALLOCATED A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE BILLION TO
COW- YES THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND MOST OF THIS MONEY HAS GONE
TO ACQUISITION OF NEW FOSSIL
FUEL BACKUP GENERATION WHICH
RUNS COUNTER TO CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. A BETTER
WAY TO ENHANCE ENERGY
RESILIENCY THROUGH CLEAN
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
LOCATED WITHIN COMMUNITIES THE
STOCK TECHNOLOGIES WILL ALLOW
OUR COMMUNITIES TO WHETHER
GRADE ADVERSE EVENTS WHILE
PROVIDING BENEFITS TO THE WIDER
GRID. THERE CURRENTLY IS NO
STATE POLICY FRAMEWORK TO DO
THIS BUT SB NINETY NINE THE
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE ACT
AUTHORED BY SENATOR DODD
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CREATE A
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WILL SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND CREATING
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE
PLANS THAT'S A TOTAL TO
DISSIPATE FEDERAL STATE AND
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT IN
ADVANCED ENERGY RESILIENCE. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON
WILL LIKELY INCLUDE MORE POWER
OUTAGES AND I URGE YOU TO FUND
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE
PROGRAMS NOW TO MOVE CALIFORNIA
TOWARDS A CLEANER MORE
RESILIENT ENERGY FUTURE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE NEXT. THANK
YOU LINE SEVEN FIVE. YOU ARE
OPEN. EARNERS REMAINING CAMACHO
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GREENLEAF POWER WHICH OPERATES
TO BIOMASS FACILITIES- IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TEN
MILLION SATISFIED- FOR GROUP IN
THE MOVE WOULD WAIT OUT OF OUR
FOR IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. WELCOME OUR NEXT. MR
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALRIGHT THEN WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE PANEL- CENTER
STERN. HI YOU HAVE A COMMENT TO
US. FOLLOWING OUR PUBLIC
HEARING. I'M WILLING TO DEFER
TO A TO INTERNAL DISCUSSIONS I
WAS JUST LOOKING TO APPLAUD
YOUR WORK ON SOME OF THE ITEMS
DISCUSSED THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCY AND OPR AND-
I'M PLANNING DOLLARS MIGHT.
EXTENDED THE INCREASE DID NOT
GET TO THAT PIECE OF IT SO WHEN
APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT WORK AS
WELL AS THE W. C. B. ELEMENTS
AND THE CONSERVANCY PIECES OF
THIS STUFF. THANKS WELL.
WELCOME WHAT WE LIKE TO DO IS
HAVE A MOTION OR THE GENERAL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. ON ISSUES
NUMBER. TWO THREE FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT. TEN ELEVEN TWELVE.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWO IS THAT A MOTION
SENATOR STERN. SO MOVED. OKAY
SO ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE A- C.
THIS IS A MOTION ISSUES NUMBER.
TWO THREE FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT.
231-110-1112 FOURTEEN THROUGH
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE THROUGH
TWENTY TWO MISS ROY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WHY CASKEY HI MY
COUNTY HIGH TALLY OF TELLY AYE
MCGUIRE. PLAN HI STERN- NINE
STERN AYE FOUR ZERO CLOSE
ROLLED KEPT TALLY VOTES YOU
GUYS HAVE IT FOUR ZERO NOW
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN IS THAT
EMOTIONS AND REQUIRE THIS ISSUE
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN ON ITS
OWN. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MY
CASKEY HI WE CAN ASK YOU I DALY.
THE NO NO NO C. DELANO MY
CLIENT CODE HERE. MCGUIRE AYE
STERN YOUR NINE. CLOSE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTE THREE ONE IT'S
THREE ONE THAT THAT ISSUE IS A
APPROVED AND FINALLY WILL HAVE
A MOTION ON ISSUES NUMBER. ONE
THREE NINE FIFTEEN NINETEEN AND
TWENTY ONE FOUR ONE FOUR SKEWS
ME THIS IS A MOTION ON ISSUES
NUMBER. ONE FOR NINE FIFTEEN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY. CENTER
STERNER SAID EMOTION. SO MOVED
ALL RIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CASKEY HI MY COUNTY HIGH DALY.
NOW NOT MONNING MCGUIRE RIGHT
MCGUIRE AND STERN. STERN I'D
CLOSE REAL TALLY THE VOTE THREE
ZERO THIS IS HAVE EIGHT THREE
ZERO THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
TODAY ON- AT THE SEVEN TWO WE
WILL BE BACK NEXT WEEK AT NINE
O'CLOCK ON CAP AND TRADE AND
OTHER SUNDRY ITEMS WE ARE NOW
TURN.